E
CASE OF U.S. VERSUS NIXON.
>> WE'LL HEAR ARGUMENTS IN
73-1766, UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AGAINST NIXON AND THE
CROSS-PETITION, RICHARD M. NIXON
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES.
MR. JAWORSKI, THERE HAS BEEN A
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL TIME.
THE COURT THEN SET ADDITIONAL
TIME OF ONE-AND-A HALF HOURS, I
UNDERSTAND.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR.
>> IT'LL BE ALLOWED TO EACH SIDE
AND WE WILL NOT INTERRUPT THE
ARGUMENT WITH ANY RECESS.
WE'LL GO RIGHT THROUGH UNTIL
YOU'RE FINISHED.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.
>> YOU MAY PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY, MR. JAWORSKI.
>> MR. CHIEF JUSTICE AND MAY IT
PLEASE THE COURT.
ON MARCH 1 LAST, UNITED STATES
DISTRICT COURT GRAND JURY, SET
IT HERE, RETURNED AN INDICTMENT
AGAINST SEVEN DEFENDANTS
CHARGING VARIOUS OFFENSES
INCLUDING AMONG THEM A
CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE UNITED
STATES AND ALSO TO OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE.
JOHN MITCHELL, ONE OF THE
DEFENDANTS, WAS A FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES AND ALSO CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE TO REELECT THE
PRESIDENT.
ANOTHER, H.R. HALDEMAN, WAS THE
PRESIDENT'S CHIEF OF STAFF.
ANOTHER, JOHN EHRLICHMAN, WAS
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT FOR
ECONOMIC -- FOR DOMESTIC
AFFAIRS.
THE OTHERS WERE EITHER ON THE
PRESIDENT'S STAFF OR HELD
RESPONSIBLE POSITIONS ON THE
REELECTION COMMITTEE.
IN THE COURSE OF ITS
DELIBERATIONS, THE GRAND JURY
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY WITH 19
MEMBERS CONCURRING THAT THE
COURSE OF EVENTS IN THE
FORMATION AND CONTINUATION OF
THE CONSPIRACY WAS SUCH THAT
PRESIDENT NIXON, AMONG A NUMBER
OF OTHERS, SHOULD BE IDENTIFIED
AS AN UNINDICTED CO-CONSPIRATOR
IN THE BILL, PARTICULAR AS TO BE
FILED IN CONNECTION WITH THE
PRETRIAL PROCEEDINGS.
NOW, ALTHOUGH THIS PARTICULAR
DECISION AND DETERMINATION ON
THE PART OF THE GRAND JURY
OCCURRED IN FEBRUARY, IT WAS A
WELL-KEPT SECRET FOR TWO-AND-A
HALF MONTHS.
THE GRAND JURY, OF COURSE, KNEW
IT.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PROSECUTION
STAFF KNEW IT.
IT WAS DONE SO TO AVOID
AFFECTING THE PROCEEDINGS IN A
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
IT WAS SO KEPT DURING THESE
TWO-AND-A HALF MONTHS UNTIL IT
BECAME NECESSARY TO REVEAL IT AS
A RESULT OF THE PRESIDENT'S
MOTION TO QUASH A SUBPOENA, AS I
WILL INDICATE SUBSEQUENTLY IN MY
ARGUMENT.
NOW, TO OBTAIN ADDITION EVIDENCE
WHICH THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HAS
GOOD REASON TO BELIEVE IS IN THE
POSSESSION OF AND UNDER THE
CONTROL OF THE PRESIDENT AND
WHICH IT IS BELIEVED BY THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AS QUITE
IMPORTANT TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE GOVERNMENT'S PROOF AT THE
TRIAL IN UNITED STATES VERSUS
MITCHELL.
A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR, ON BEHALF
OF THE UNITED STATES, MOVED FOR
A SUBPOENA DUCES TECUM.
AND, IT IS THE SUBPOENA HERE IN
QUESTION.
THE DISTRICT COURT ORDERED THE
SUBPOENA TO ISSUE RETURNABLE ON
MAY 2 AND THE SUBPOENA, OF
COURSE, CALLED FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF TAPE RECORDINGS IN
ADVANCE OF SEPTEMBER 9, 1972
WHICH IS A TRIAL DATE.
AND, THIS WAS DONE TO ALLOW TIME
FOR LITIGATION IN THE EVENT
LITIGATION WAS TO ENSUE OVER THE
PRODUCTION OF THE TAPES AND ALSO
FOR TRANSCRIPTION AND
AUTHENTICATION OF ANY TAPE
RECORDINGS THAT WERE PRODUCED IN
RESPONSE TO THE SUBPOENA.
ON APRIL 30, THE PRESIDENT
RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC AND
SUBMITTED TO THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE 1,216 PAGES OF EDITED
TRANSCRIPTS OF 43 CONVERSATIONS
DEALING WITH WATERGATE.
PORTIONS OF 20 OF THE SUBPOENAED
CONVERSATIONS WERE INCLUDED
AMONG THE 43.
THEN, ON MAY 1, THE PRESIDENT
ADVISED COUNSEL TO FILE A
SPECIAL APPEARANCE, A FORMAL
CLAIM OF PRIVILEGE, AND A MOTION
TO QUASH A SUBPOENA.
NOW FOR THE UNITED STATES TO
CONDUCT A FULL AND APPROPRIATE
HEARING ON A MOTION TO QUASH THE
SUBPOENA, IT BECAME NECESSARY TO
REVEAL THE GRAND JURY'S FINDING
REGARDING THE PRESIDENT.
AND, THIS WAS FIRST DONE BY THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR CALLING ON
THE CHIEF OF STAFF, GENERAL
ALEXANDER HAIG, AND THE
PRESIDENT'S COUNSEL, MR. ST.
CLAIRE, AND ADVISING THEM OF
WHAT HAD OCCURRED TWO-AND-A HALF
MONTHS PRIOR.
AND THEN, ON THE FOLLOWING
MORNING, ADVISING JUDGE RICO OF
WHAT HAD OCCURRED IN CAMERA AND
POINTING OUT AT THE NECESSITY OF
THIS BEING USED IN CONNECTION
WITH THE ARGUMENTS ON A MOTION
TO QUASH BECAUSE OF THEIR
RELEVANCE AND THE NECESSITY OF
THESE MATTERS BEING MADE A PART
OF THE PROCEEDING.
NOW, THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
JOINED COUNSEL FOR THE PRESIDENT
IN URGING THAT MATTER BE HEARD
IN CAMERA, WHICH, WAS DONE.
THREE OF THE DEFENDANTS HAD
JOINED THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR IN
MOVING FOR THE SUBPOENA.
ALL OF THE DEFENDANTS, AT THE
TIME OF ARGUMENT IN CAMERA TO
JUDGE SIRICA, OPPOSED THE MOTION
TO QUASH.
>> I DON'T SEE THE RELEVANCY OF
THE FACT THAT THE GRAND JURY
INDICTED THE PRESIDENT AS
CO-CONSPIRATOR.
THE LEGAL ISSUE, AS TO THE DUTY
TO DELIVER PURSUANT TO THE
SUBPOENA THAT YOU ARE ASKING FOR
--
>> THE ONLY RELEVANCE, MR.
JUSTICE, LIES IN IT BEING
NECESSARY TO SHOW UNDER RULE 17C
THAT THERE IS SOME RELEVANCE TO
THE MATERIAL THAT WE WERE
SEEKING TO SUBPOENA, AND --
>> YES, BUT 17C PRESUPPOSES A
SUBPOENA RUNNING AGAINST THE
PARTY, AND THE PRESIDENT IS NO
PARTY.
HE'S NOT A DEFENDANT IN ONE OF
THESE CASES.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR, BUT IT
WAS FELT IT WOULD BE NECESSARY
TO SHOW WHY.
AND, IN ORDER TO PROVE THIS
CONSPIRACY AND IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE ALL OF THE LINKS IN THE
CONSPIRACY, IT WAS DEEMED
NECESSARY TO SHOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT OR HIS NAME WAS
INDICTED CO-CONSPIRATOR AND ALSO
THAT THERE'S PRUDENCE.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS PRIMARILY
JUST FOR THE COLLAGE INFORMATION
OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
>> NO, SIR.
THAT IS NOT CORRECT, SIR.
IT BECAME VERY IMPORTANT, MR.
JUSTICE, FOR US TO HAVE THAT AS
A PART OF PROCEEDINGS SO THAT WE
COULD USE THE VARIOUS LINKS IN
THE TESTIMONY, SO AS TO SHOW
THAT THE CONVERSATIONS WERE SUCH
AS TO MAKE ONE ADMISSIBLE AS
AGAINST A CO-CONSPIRATOR.
>> THE GRAND JURY SENT IT TO THE
HOUSE COMMITTEE, DIDN'T IT?
>> THE GRAND JURY SENT NOTHING
OF AN ACCUSATORY NATURE TO THE
HOUSE COMMITTEE.
NO, SIR, WHAT THE GRAND JURY
SENT TO THE HOUSE COMMITTEE WAS
THE EVIDENCE THAT HAD BEEN
ACCUMULATED AND IT, VERY
CAREFULLY, EXCISED FROM IT
ANYTHING BY WAY OF THE GRAND
JURY'S INTERPRETATION OR
ANYTHING ALONG THAT LINE, MR.
JUSTICE.
NOW, IN ITS OPINION AND ORDER OF
MAY 20, THE DISTRICT COURT FIRST
--
>> YOU'D STILL BE HERE, MR.
JAWORSKI, WHETHER OR NOT THE
PRESIDENT HAD BEEN NAMED AS AN
UNINDICTED CO-CONSPIRATOR BUT
THAT SIMPLY GIVES YOU ANOTHER
STRING TO YOUR BOW.
ISN'T THAT ABOUT IT?
>> IT'S TRUE THAT IT ADMITS SOME
EVIDENCE THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
NOT BE ADMISSIBLE.
>> RIGHT, BUT EVEN HAD THE
PRESIDENT NOT BEEN NAMED, YOU
WOULD STILL HAVE SUBPOENA AT
LEAST PART OF THIS MATERIAL.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT, YES, SIR.
>> AND YOU'D STILL BE HERE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SIR.
>> WOULD YOU NOT?
BUT, IN ORDER TO PRESENT THE
FULL PICTURE AND IN ORDER TO
PRESENT, THAT ALSO WAS A PART OF
IT.
DISTRICT COURT DENIED THE MOTION
TO QUASH AND THE MOTION TO
EXPUNGE HAD ALSO BEEN FILED.
>> NO ONE YET HAS EVER SUGGESTED
THAT IF YOU'RE IN A CRIMINAL
TRIAL, CONSPIRACY TRIAL, AND
SOME EVIDENCE IS AUTHORED OF AN
OUT-OF-COURT STATEMENT OF
SOMEONE WHO'S ALLEGED TO BE A
CO-CONSPIRATOR, THAT IT'S ENOUGH
FOR THE PROSECUTION TO THEN SHOW
THAT THE GRAND JURY HAD NAMED
HIM THE CO-CONSPIRATOR.
>> NO.
>> THAT NEVER GETS YOU OR WILL
NEVER GET YOU OVER THE --
>> NO, AND WE DON'T SO CONTEND.
>> WELL, THEN THAT WAS THE
POINT.
THAT WAS THE DIRECTION OF YOUR
--
>> NO, THIS WAS IN CONNECTION
WITH THE SUBPOENAING OF THIS
EVIDENCE, MR. JUSTICE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THIS WAS IN
CONNECTION WITH SHOWING THAT WE
HAD THE RIGHT TO THIS EVIDENCE.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> YES, SIR.
>> BUT --
>> AND THAT WAS THE POINT.
>> BUT YOU DO NOT SUGGEST THAT
THAT'S ALL YOU NEED TO SHOW.
IS THAT IT?
>> NO, SIR, OF COURSE NOT.
>> OR YOU DON'T SUGGEST THAT THE
GRAND JURY FINDING IS BINDING ON
THE COURT OR NOT?
>> I DO SUGGEST THAT IT MAKES A
PRIMA FACIE CASE.
AND I THINK, UNDER THE
AUTHORITIES, IT SO DOES.
>> LET ME UNDERSTAND THIS, MR.
JAWORSKI.
YOU DON'T SUGGEST THAT YOUR
RIGHT TO THIS EVIDENCE DEPENDS
UPON THE PRESIDENT HAVING THE
NAME AS AN UNINDICTED
CO-CONSPIRATOR.
>> NO, SIR.
>> AND SO, FOR THE PURPOSES OF
OUR DECISION, WE COULD LAY THAT
FACT ASIDE, COULDN'T WE?
>> WHAT I WAS REALLY DOING IN
POINTING TO THAT --
>> WELL, COULD WE?
>> YES.
PRIMARILY WAS AN ORDER TO SHOW A
REASON FOR THE GRAND JURY'S
ACTION.
THERE IS ALSO BEFORE THIS COURT
A MOTION TO EXPUNGE THE ACT OF
THE GRAND JURY IN NAMING THE
PRESIDENT AS AN UNINDICTED
CO-CONSPIRATOR.
AND, I WAS TRYING TO LAY BEFORE
THE COURT THE ENTIRE SITUATION
THAT WARRANTED THAT ACTION.
>> MR. JAWORSKI.
>> YES, SIR.
>> AS I UNDERSTAND YOUR BRIEF,
YOU GO BEYOND WHAT YOU HAVE
ADDRESSED SO FAR.
I THINK YOU SAY THAT THE MERE
FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
NAMED AS AN UNINDICTED
CO-CONSPIRATOR FORECLOSES HIS
CLAIM OF PRIVILEGE.
>> WELL, WE CERTAINLY POINT --
>> IT'S IN PAGE 91 OF YOUR
BRIEF.
>> WE CERTAINLY MAKE THAT AS ONE
OF THE POINTS, WHICH, I INTEND
TO DISCUSS THAT LATER.
>> WELL, THAT REDUCES HIM, IN IT
OF ITSELF, TO THE STATUS OF ANY
OTHER PERSON ACCUSED OF CRIME.
>> I DON'T SAY THAT IT FORECLOSE
THIS.
WHAT I THINK WE SUGGEST IS THAT
IT DOES PRESENT A SITUATION
HERE.
THAT SHOULD NOT MAKE THE
APPLICATION OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE APPROPRIATE.
WE DO SAY THAT.
>> BUT ONLY PRIMA FACIE.
>> PRIMA FACIE, THAT'S CORRECT.
BUT WHEN YOU GET TO THE MATTER,
MR. JUSTICE POWELL, OF BALANCING
INTERESTS WE DO FEEL THAT THAT
PARTICULAR SITUATION IS A FACTOR
THAT IS IMPORTANT.
AND, THIS IS WHY WE LAID STRESS
ON IT.
THE COURT'S ORDER, OF COURSE,
WAS TO DELIVER TO THE COURT THE
ORIGINALS OF ALL SUBPOENAED
ITEMS AS WELL AS AN INDEX
ANALYSIS OF THOSE ITEMS,
TOGETHER WITH TAPED COPIES OF
THOSE PORTIONS OF THE SUBPOENA
RECORDINGS FOR WHICH TRANSCRIPTS
HAD BEEN RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC
BY THE PRESIDENT ON APRIL 30.
NOW, THIS CASE PRESENTS FOR
REVIEW THE ACTION OF THE LOWER
COURT.
NOW MAY I, BEFORE I GET TO THE
JURISDICTIONAL POINTS, BRIEFLY
STATE WHAT WE CONSIDER TO BE A
BIRD'S EYE VIEW OF THIS CASE.
NOW INVEST IN ALMOST 500 PAGES
OF BRIEFS, WHEN BOILED DOWN,
THIS CASE REALLY PRESENTS ONE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE.
WHO IS TO BE THE ARBITER OF WHAT
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS?
BASICALLY, THIS IS NOT A NOVEL
QUESTION, ALTHOUGH THE FACTUAL
SITUATION INVOLVED IS, OF
COURSE, UNPRECEDENTED.
THERE ARE PRIMARY QUESTIONS TO
BE SURE.
BUT IN THE END, AFTER THE ROUNDS
HAVE BEEN MADE, WE RETURN TO
FACE THESE FLARING FACTS THAT I
WANT TO BRIEFLY REVIEW FOR THE
FINAL ANSWER.
IN REFUSING TO PRODUCE THE
EVIDENCE SOUGHT BY A SUBPOENA
DUCES TECUM IN THE CRIMINAL
TRIAL OF SEVEN DEFENDANTS, AMONG
THEM, FORMER CHIEF OF AIDS AND
DUBIETIES, THE PRESIDENT INVOKES
THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
HIS COUNSEL'S BRIEF IS REPLETE
WITH REFERENCES FOR THE
CONSTITUTION AS JUSTIFYING HIS
POSITION.
AND IN HIS PUBLIC STATEMENT, AS
WE ALL KNOW, THE PRESIDENT HAS
EMBRACED THE CONSTITUTION THAT'S
OFFERING HIM SUPPORT FOR HIS
REFUSAL TO SUPPLY THE SUBPOENAED
TAPES.
NOW, THE PRESIDENT MAY BE RIGHT
IN HOW HE READS THE
CONSTITUTION.
BUT, HE MAY ALSO BE WRONG.
AND IF HE IS WRONG, WHO IS THERE
TO TELL HIM SO?
AND IF THERE'S NO ONE, THEN THE
PRESIDENT, OF COURSE, IS FREE TO
PURSUE HIS COURSE OF ERRONEOUS
INTERPRETATIONS.
WHAT THEN BECOMES OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL FORM OF
GOVERNMENT?
SO WHEN COUNSEL FOR THE
PRESIDENT, IN HIS BRIEF, STATES
THAT THIS CASE GOES TO THE HEART
OF OUR BASIC CONSTITUTIONAL
SYSTEM, WE AGREE BECAUSE, IN OUR
VIEW, THIS NATION'S
CONSTITUTIONAL FORM OF
GOVERNMENT IS IN SERIOUS
JEOPARDY.
IF THE PRESIDENT, ANY PRESIDENT,
IS TO SAY THAT THE CONSTITUTION
MEANS WHAT HE SAYS IT DOES AND
THAT THERE IS NO ONE, NOT EVEN
THE SUPREME COURT, TO TELL HIM
OTHERWISE --
>> MR. JAWORSKI.
>> YES?
>> THE PRESIDENT WENT TO A
COURT.
HE WENT TO THE DISTRICT COURT
WITH HIS MOTION TO QUASH AND
THEN HE FILED A CROSS-PETITION
HERE.
HE'S NOT -- HE'S ASKING THE
COURT TO SAY THAT HIS POSITION
IS CORRECT AS A MATTER OF LAW.
IS HE NOT?
>> HE'S SAYING HIS POSITION IS
CORRECT BECAUSE HE INTERPRETS
THE CONSTITUTION THAT WAY.
>> CORRECT.
>> THIS IS WHAT HE SAYS --
>> AND HE'S ASKING -- HE'S
SUBMITTING HIS POSITION TO THE
COURT AND ASKING US TO AGREE
WITH HIM.
HE WENT, FIRST, TO THE DISTRICT
COURT AND HE PETITIONED IN THIS
COURT.
HE'S NOT -- HE HAS, HIMSELF,
INVOKED THE JUDICIAL PROCESS AND
HE IS COMMITTED TO IT.
>> WELL, THAT'S NOT ENTIRELY
CORRECT, MR. JUSTICE.
>> DIDN'T HE FILE A MOTION TO
QUASH THE SUBPOENAS IN THE
DISTRICT COURT OR THE UNITED
STATES?
>> WHILE THE MOTION TO QUASH THE
SUBPOENA IN SIRICA HAS ALSO
TAKEN THE POSITION THAT WE HAVE
NO STANDING IN THIS COURT TO
HAVE THIS ISSUE HEARD.
>> AS A MATTER OF LAW.
HE'S MAKING THAT ARGUMENT TO A
COURT.
AS A MATTER OF CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW, HE IS CORRECT.
>> SO THAT, OF COURSE, THIS
COURT COULD THEN NOT PASS UPON
THE CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION OF
HOW HE INTERPRETS THE
CONSTITUTION IF HIS POSITION
WERE CORRECT, BUT --
>> AS A MATTER OF LAW, IF HIS
POSITION IS CORRECT --
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SIR.
>> THEN HE IS THE SOLE JUDGE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND HE'S ASKING THIS COURT TO
AGREE WITH THAT PROPOSITION AS A
MATTER OF CONSTITUTIONAL LAW.
>> BUT WHAT I'M SAYING IS, IF HE
IS THE SOLE JUDGE AND HE IS TO
BE CONSIDERED THE SOLE JUDGE AND
HE IS IN ERROR IN HIS
INTERPRETATION, THEN HE GOES ON
BEING IN ERROR IN HIS
INTERPRETATION.
>> WELL, THEN THIS COURT WILL
TELL HIM SO.
THAT'S WHAT THIS CASE IS ABOUT,
ISN'T IT?
>> WELL, THAT'S WHAT I THINK THE
CASE IS ABOUT.
YES, SIR.
>> IN SUBMITTING HIMSELF TO THE
JUDICIAL PROCESS IN THE SAME
SENSE THAT YOU ARE, IS THAT NOT
SO, MR. JAWORSKI?
>> WELL, I CAN'T SAY THAT --
>> YOU TAKE ONE POSITION AND HE
TAKES ANOTHER.
>> WELL MR. CHIEF JUSTICE, IN MY
VIEW, FRANKLY, IT IS A POSITION
WHERE HE SAYS "A CONSTITUTION
SAYS THIS AND NOBODY IS GOING TO
TELL ME WHAT THE CONSTITUTION
SAYS" BECAUSE, UP TO THIS POINT,
HE SAYS THAT HE AND HE ALONE IS
THE PROPER ONE TO INTERPRET THE
CONSTITUTION.
NOW, THERE'S NOW WAY TO ESCAPE
THAT BECAUSE THE BRIEFS
DEFINITELY POINT THAT OUT TIME
AFTER TIME.
>> I THINK THIS MATTER MAY BE
ONE OF SEMANTICS.
EACH OF YOU IS TAKING A
DIFFERENT POSITION ON THE BASIC
QUESTION AND EACH OF YOU IS
SUBMITTING FOR DECISION TO THIS
COURT.
>> WELL, WE START WITH --
>> IT MAY BE, SIR.
>> WE START WITH A CONSTITUTION
THAT DOES NOT CONTAIN THE WORDS
"EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE," IS THAT
RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SIR.
>> SO, WHY DON'T WE GO ON FROM
THERE?
>> ALRIGHT, SIR.
THAT IS A VERY GOOD BEGINNING
POINT BUT, OF COURSE, OTHER
THINGS HAVE NEEDED TO BE
DISCUSSED AS MUCH AS THEY'VE
BEEN RAISED.
>> PERHAPS IT WOULD FURTHER
NARROW THE AREA IF, AS I TAKE IT
FROM YOUR BRIEFS, YOU DO
EMPHASIZE THERE IS NO CLAIM HERE
OF TYPICAL MILITARY SECRETS OR
DIPLOMATIC SECRETS OR WHAT, IN
THE BURR CASE, WERE REFERRED TO
AS STATE SECRETES.
NONE OF THOSE THINGS ARE IN THIS
CASE.
IS THAT RIGHT?
>> THAT IS CORRECT, SIR, AND WE
DO POINT TO THE AUTHORITIES TO
SHOW THAT THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
IN THE SITUATION HERE.
I DO THINK THAT IT'S PROPER, AS
MUCH AS I REGRET TO HAVE TO DO
IT, TO POINT THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S INTERPRETATION OF
WHAT HIS ACTION SHOULD BE IN
THESE PARTICULAR SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AS ONE THAT REALLY
REQUIRES JUDICIAL INTERVENTION,
PERHAPS MORE SO THAN A NORMAL
ONE WOULD.
I THINK THAT WE REALIZE THAT
THERE IS AT STEAK THE MATTER OF
THE SUPPLYING OF EVIDENCE THAT
RELATES TO THE DUE FORM OF CLOSE
AIDS AND DUBIETIES.
I THINK WE'RE AWARE OF THE FACT
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAD PUBLICLY
STATED THAT HE BELIEVED THAT
THESE TWO AIDS OF HIS, MR.
HALDEMAN AND MR. EHRLICHMAN
WOULD COME OUT ALRIGHT IN THE
END.
ADDED TO THAT, THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS SENSITIVITY OR OWN
INVOLVEMENT IS ALSO A MATTER
THAT CALLS FOR THE EXERCISE OF
THE QUESTION TO WHICH MR.
JUSTICE DOUGLAS ALLUDED AS ONE
THAT IS SOMEWHAT UNUSUAL.
TURNING NOW TO JURISDICTION,
BEFORE THE COURT ARE THE TWO
QUESTIONS OF STATUTORY
JURISDICTION.
THE COURT DIRECTED THE PARTIES
TO BRIEF AND ARGUE.
>> MR. JAWORSKI, AT THIS POINT,
HELP ME OVER ONE HURDLE.
DO YOU FEEL THAT THE MANDAMUS
CASE AS SUCH AS HERE?
I SEARCHED YOUR PETITION --
>> YES, WE DO, SIR.
>> I SEARCHED YOUR PETITION FOR
CERTIORARI IN VAIN TO FIND EVEN
A MENTION OF IT, AND I WONDER.
IT'S A TECHNICAL QUESTION BUT
THE -- WHAT IS YOUR POSITION?
THAT THE ISSUE IS IN ANY OF
ENTERED HERE?
>> YES, SIR.
>> WHETHER THE CASE IS NOT --
>> WE SAY IT'S HERE NOT ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE APPEAL ITSELF,
BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF THE PETITION
FOR MANDAMUS.
NOW WE DID, MR. JUSTICE,
DISCUSSED THAT IN ONE OF THE
BRIEFS.
NOW, IT MAY BE THAT IT WASN'T
ORIGINALLY WHEN WE FILED THE
ORIGINAL BRIEF ON JURISDICTION.
>> YOU MENTIONED IT IN YOUR
SECOND BRIEF ON THE MERITS.
>> YES.
>> BUT NOT AT ALL IN YOUR
PETITION FOR CERTIORARI.
>> WELL, WE DID IN THE -- IT WAS
IN THE FOOTNOTE ON PAGE 2 OF THE
PETITIONER FOR WRIT OF
CERTIORARI, MR. JUSTICE.
WELL, I WOULD THINK SO BUT THERE
REALLY IS NO ISSUE BETWEEN THE
PARTIES HERE ON THE ISSUE OF
JURISDICTION.
I MEAN, THERE'S NO ARGUMENT AS
BETWEEN THE PARTIES ON IT.
AND, WHILE OF COURSE THE PARTIES
CAN'T AGREE ON IT, I MUST SAY
THAT ON THREE DIFFERENT BASES
THE JURISDICTION DOES EXIST AS
WE SEE IT.
NOW, I AM NOT YET GETTING TO THE
QUESTION OF THE INTRA-EXECUTIVE
MATTER THAT HAS BEEN RAISED BUT
I AM DISCUSSING NOW THE
STATUTORY BASIS OF JURISDICTION,
AND --
>> (INAUDIBLE)
>> TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
DIRECTLY, SIR, THIS IS CORRECT.
WE ARE STANDING UPON NOT ONLY
THE MATTER THAT THIS IS AN
APPEAL THAT PROPERLY HAD BEEN IN
THE COURT OF APPEALS AND, FOR
THAT REASON, HAS BEEN MOVED UP
HERE PROPERLY UNDER 1254-1.
WE ALSO SAY THAT COURT HAS
JURISDICTION OVER THE PETITION
AND CROSS-PETITION UNDER 1254-1
BECAUSE IT PRESENT FOR REVIEW
ALL QUESTIONS RAISED BY THE
PRESIDENT'S PETITION FOR WRIT OF
MANDAMUS.
AND THEN WE ALSO SAY THAT, IN
ADDITION TO THAT, THE ALL WRITS
ACT GIVES THIS COURT
JURISDICTION TO PROCEED.
>> OF COURSE, IN A MANDAMUS
ACTION, JUDGE SIRICA WOULD BE
THE PARTY RESPONDENT AND HE'S
NOT A PARTY IN THIS CASE AND
HE'S NOT REPRESENTED BY COUNSEL
HERE, IS HE?
>> AS FAR AS I KNOW, HE'S NOT,
NO, SIR.
IN FACT, I'M SURE HE'S NOT.
>> AND THE MANDAMUS WOULD BE
NIXON VERSUS SIRICA, WOULD IT
NOT?
>> BUT IT WAS BROUGHT UP BY THE
PRESIDENT IN THEIR PETITION FOR
MANDAMUS AND THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S THE WAY IT GOT INTO THIS
COURT.
IT RAISES THE SAME QUESTIONS
ACTUALLY THAT WERE RAISED ON THE
MATTER THAT WE BROUGHT UPON.
>> WHAT WAS THE CHRONOLOGY, MR.
JAWORSKI?
THE NOTICE OF APPEAL FROM JUDGE
SIRICA'S ORDER WAS THE FIRST
STEP TAKEN TO GET TO THE COURT
OF APPEALS, WAS IT?
>> THAT'S, I BELIEVE, RIGHT, SIR
AND --
>> AND WHILE THAT WAS PENDING,
THEN I GATHER, THE PRESIDENT
PETITIONED FOR MANDAMUS WAS
BROUGHT.
>> RIGHT, SIR.
YES.
>> AND THEN THE LAST STEP WAS
THAT YOU FILED THE PETITION TO
BYPASS HERE.
>> RIGHT, SIR.
>> AND THAT PETITION TO BYPASS
FILED, I GATHER, TO WHATEVER
CASE WAS PENDING IN THE COURT OF
APPEALS?
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR.
>> AND AT THAT TIME, THE CASE
PENDING WAS BOTH THE APPEAL FROM
JUDGE SIRICA'S OFFICE --
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SIR.
>> AND THE PRESIDENT'S PETITION
--
>> MANDAMUS, CORRECT.
>> WHICH YOU FEEL THEY ARE NOT
TWO CASES?
>> NO, SIR.
THEY RAISE THE SAME QUESTIONS
BUT THAT'S --
>> AND YET, YOU COULD BRING EACH
UP SEPARATELY IF YOU SO CHOSE.
>> I COULD HAVE, SIR, YES.
>> IT SEEMS TO ME THERE'RE TWO
CASES.
>> BUT IN AS MUCH AS THEY
PRESENT THE SAME QUESTIONS, IT
OCCURRED TO US THAT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE TO RELY UPON THE
JURISDICTION AS TO BOTH OF THEM.
>> EXCEPT, I WOULD SUGGEST AGAIN
THAT, WITH RESPECT TO THE
MANDAMUS ACTION, ONE OF THE
PARTIES ISN'T HERE IN COURT OR
PRESENTED BY COUNSEL.
HE IS THE PARTY RESPONDENT.
>> WELL, IT IS -- I DON'T HAVE
THE RECORD BEFORE ME BUT, I MUST
SAY AND I WILL NOT MAKE AN
OUTRIGHT REPRESENTATION THAT
JUDGE SIRICA IS, AND THAT'S WHY
I HESITATED A FEW MINUTES AGO,
WAS MADE A PARTY AFTER ALL THAT
WAS BROUGHT UP BY THE PRESIDENT.
BUT, I AM ADVISED BY A NOTE JUST
PASSED TO ME BY MR. LACOVARA
THAT JUDGE SIRICA IS A PARTY TO
THAT PROCEEDING.
>> WHO REPRESENTS HIM HERE?
>> I DON'T KNOW OF ANYONE
REPRESENTING HIM HERE, MR.
JUSTICE.
>> HAS HE FILED ANY BRIEF OR
MADE AN APPEARANCE AT ALL IN ANY
SENSE?
>> SO FAR AS I KNOW, NONE.
>> WELL, IF YOU'RE RIGHT THAT,
AT ANY EVENT, JUDGE SIRICA'S
ORDER WAS AN APPEALABLE ORDER.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> IF YOU'RE CORRECT IN THAT
SUBMISSION, DO WE EVER HAVE TO
REACH ANY ISSUES RAISED BY THE
MANDAMUS?
>> NO, IT WOULD NOT.
WE WERE POINTING OUT THAT THE
JURISDICTION RESTS ON A
THREE-PRONG BASIS.
>> BUT THE MANDAMUS IS NOT YOUR
ACTION.
>> IT'S NOT, NO, SIR.
>> AND YOU'RE NOT OBLIGING THE
DEFENDANT, ARE YOU?
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR.
WE, HOWEVER, WERE POINTING OUT
THAT THE SAME ISSUES REALLY WERE
RAISED BY IT IF THE PETITIONER
IS PROPERLY BEFORE THE COURT.
NOW, IF THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON THE MATTER OF
STATUTORY JURISDICTION, I WOULD
LIKE TO PASS TO THE
INTRA-EXECUTIVE DISPUTE.
FIRST, WE RECOGNIZE, OF COURSE,
THAT JURISDICTION CANNOT BE
WAIVED AND NOTHING THAT IS
PRESENTED HERE IS WITH THE IDEA
OF SUGGESTING EVEN REMOTELY THAT
THERE IS ANY WAIVER WITH RESPECT
TO THE QUESTIONS OF
JURISDICTION.
BUT, WE DO SAY THAT THE
CONTENTION IS THAT THERE IS AN
INTRA-EXECUTIVE DISPUTE AND, FOR
THAT REASON, THIS COURT CANNOT
PASS UP ON THESE QUESTIONS AS
NOT SOUND.
BEFORE DISCUSSING THE CASE AS,
HOWEVER, I THINK THAT IT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE FOR US TO
UNDERTAKE THE BASES IN THE RIGHT
PERSPECTIVE.
LET ME SAY, FIRST, THAT WE STAND
UPON TWO BASES.
FIRST, THAT, ACTUALLY, THE
ORDERS THAT WERE ENTERED
CREATING THE OFFICE OF THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AND
DELINEATING HIS AUTHORITY, EVEN
THE ORIGINAL ORDER AT THE TIME
THAT MY PREDECESSOR WAS ACTING
AS SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HAD THE
FORCE AND EFFECT OF LAW.
WE ALSO POINT TO THE FACT THAT
THE ARRANGEMENT MADE ITSELF WITH
THE ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT
I MADE, IF I MAY POINT TO IT,
AND ONE REASON I HAVE NO
RESONANCE IN DISCUSSING THE
FACTS IS BECAUSE THE FACTS ARE
UNDISPUTED.
THERE HAS BEEN NO DISPUTE RAISED
AS TO JUST WHAT ACTUALLY
TRANSPIRED.
THE SITUATION IS ONE OF THE
ARRANGEMENTS ITSELF WHICH THE
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL POINTS
TO, WITH RESPECT TO THE MATTER
OF INDEPENDENCE HAVING BEEN
DISCUSSED BY HIM WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THUS, MEANING THAT THE
PRESIDENT, HIMSELF, HAD APPROVED
THE SETTING UP OF THIS
PARTICULAR OFFICE AND THE RIGHTS
AND THE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT IT
HAS UNDER THE CHARTER.
NOW, LET ME -- WE SET THIS OUT
IN THE APPENDIX, OF COURSE,
POINTING PRECISELY TO WHAT THE
AUTHORITY AND RESPONSIBILITIES
AND OBLIGATIONS OF THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR ARE.
ONE OF THE EXPRESSED DUTIES
THAT'S DELEGATED TO THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR IS THAT HE SHALL HAVE
FULL AUTHORITY FOR INVESTIGATING
AND PROSECUTING, AMONG OTHERS,
ALLEGATIONS INVOLVING THE
PRESIDENT.
AND A DELEGATION OF AUTHORITY
EXPRESSLY STATES IN PARTICULAR
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR SHALL
HAVE FULL AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT TO CONTEST THE
ASSERTION OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
OR ANY OTHER TESTIMONIAL
PRIVILEGE.
NOW IN THE INSTANCE OF MY
APPOINTMENT, UNLIKE THE
APPOINTMENT THAT HAD BEEN MADE
PRIOR THERETO, THERE WAS AN
AMENDED ORDER AND IT REFERRED TO
ASSURANCES GIVEN BY THE
PRESIDENT TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THAT THE PRESIDENT WILL
NOT EXERCISE HIS CONSTITUTIONAL
POWERS TO AFFECT THE STORIES OF
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR OR TO
LIMIT THE INDEPENDENCE THAT HE'S
HEREBY GIVEN, AND THAT HE WILL
NOT BE REMOVED FROM HIS DUTIES
EXCEPT FOR EXTRAORDINARY
IMPROPRIETIES ON HIS PART AND
WITHOUT THE PRESIDENT'S FIRST
CONSULTING THE MAJORITY AND THE
MINORITY LEADERS AND THE
CHAIRMAN IN RANKING THE MINORITY
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES AND THE SENATE AND
HOUSE REPRESENTATIVES, AND
ASCERTAINING THAT THEIR
CONSENSUS IS IN ACCORD WITH THE
PROPOSED ACTION.
AND THEN, THAT THE JURISDICTION
OF THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR WILL
NOT BE LIMITED WITHOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S FIRST CONSULTING
WITH SUCH MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
AND ASCERTAINING THAT THEIR
CONSENSUS IS IN ACCORD WITH HIS
PROPOSED ACTION.
NOW, AT THE TIME --
>> IT'S NOT IMPORTANT.
WHAT DOES CONSENSUS MEAN,
UNANIMOUS?
>> NO, SIR, IT HADN'T BEEN
INTERPRETED BY THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CONVERSATION
AS MEANING 6 OF 8.
>> I TAKE IT WHEN YOU MAKE
REFERENCE TO THIS YOU ARE, IN
EFFECT, SUGGESTING THAT YOUR
POSITION IS CERTAINLY DIFFERENT
THAN IF A UNITED STATES ATTORNEY
WERE PROSECUTING THIS CASE.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR.
I THINK WE HAVE WHAT MIGHT BE
TERMED A QUASI-INDEPENDENT
STATUS WHERE THEY WERE DELEGATED
TO THIS PARTICULAR OFFICE THE
PERFORMANCE OF CERTAIN FUNCTIONS
AND THERE'S NO REASON WHY THE
PRESIDENT COULDN'T HAVE
DELEGATED THOSE TO US.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, WHEN --
>> MR. JAWORSKI.
>> YES?
>> QUASI-INDEPENDENT IN THE
SENSE OF AN AGENCY?
>> YES, SIR, FOR INSTANCE, AS A
CONTROL OF CURRENCY.
HE HAS A STATE OF SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR TO THAT.
AND, WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SUITS BROUGHT BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
CONTROLLER JUST THE OTHER DAY.
>> I AM TROUBLED WITH YOUR
POSITION BEING SIMILAR TO US
ATTORNEY BECAUSE THE US ATTORNEY
IS ABSOLUTELY UNDER THE THUMB OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> WELL, I DIDN'T IT.
WHAT I MEANT WAS WE HAD AN
INDEPENDENT STATUS THAT WAS
REALLY DIFFERENT FROM THE STATUS
OF THE UNITED STATES ATTORNEY.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE WAY I
ANSWERED THE QUESTION.
NOW, I SHOULD SAY THAT IT'S
INTERESTING WHEN THE CASE OF
NIXON VERSUS SIRICA WAS BEFORE
THE COURT OF APPEALS.
PROFESSOR CHARLES ALAN WRIGHT,
WHO WAS THEN ARGUING THE CASE
AND WHO WAS NOT ON THE ORIGINAL
BRIEF BUT HAVE SERVICED ON THE
REPLY BRIEF FILED ON BEHALF OF
THE PRESIDENT, AT THAT TIME
ARGUED WITH RESPECT TO THE
PARTICULAR OFFICE OF THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR.
NOW, IN THIS INSTANCE, WE HAVE A
DIVISION OF FUNCTION WITHIN THE
EXECUTIVE AND THAT MY FRIEND MR.
COX, REFERRING TO MR. ARCHIBALD
COX, HAS BEEN GIVEN ABSOLUTE
INDEPENDENCE.
IT IS FOR HIM TO DECIDE WHOM HE
WILL SEEK TO INDICT.
IT IS FOR HIM TO DECIDE TO WHOM
HE WILL GIVE IMMUNITY, A
DECISION THAT ORDINARILY WOULD
BE MADE AT THE LEVEL OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR, IN AN
IMPORTANT ENOUGH CASE, AT THE
LEVEL OR THE PRESIDENT.
BUT THE PRESIDENT'S PRESENT
COUNSEL IN HIS MOTION TO QUASH,
AS HE DOES HERE ACCEPT THE WORDS
USED ARE DIFFERENT BUT THE
EFFECT IS THE SAME, IS
CONTENDING TO THE COURT THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS THE RIGHT TO
DETERMINE WHO, WHEN, AND WITH
WHAT INFORMATION INDIVIDUALS
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED.
>> NIXON VERSUS SIRICA WAS
DIFFERENT, IN THAT, THE PARTIES
THERE WHERE THE GRAND JURY, ON
THE ONE HAND, REPRESENTED TO BE
SURE BY THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
BUT THE GRAND JURY, WHICH IS AN
ADJUNCT OF THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT ON THE ONE HAND,
AND THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE ON THE
OTHER.
AND HERE, NOW THAT AN INDICTMENT
HAS BEEN RETURNED, THE TWO
PARTIES ARE BOTH MEMBERS OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
ISN'T THAT CORRECT THAT THERE IS
THAT DIFFERENCE?
>> YES, BUT THE INDEPENDENT --
YES, SIR, THAT IS CORRECT BUT I
DON'T THINK IT'S A DISTINCTION
AS TO THE SUBSTANTIVE RIGHT --
>> NOW, YOU ARE A MEMBER.
YOU'RE UNITED STATES AND THE
PEOPLE OF UNITED STATES, WHOM
YOU REPRESENT.
YOU ARE NOT A MEMBER OF THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH UNLIKE THE GRAND
JURY IN NIXON AGAINST SIRICA.
YOU'RE A MEMBER OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT, ARE YOU
NOT?
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR, YES.
>> AND THERE IS THAT DIFFERENCE.
>> THERE IS THAT DIFFERENCE,
YES, BUT --
>> IT MIGHT BE A CRUCIAL
DIFFERENCE, WAS IT NOT?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT THE
DESCRIPTION TO WHICH I HAVE
POINTED AS TO THE INDEPENDENT
STATUS OF THE INDEPENDENT
EXECUTOR WOULD BE DIFFERENT IN
THE SIRICA CASE AS IT WOULD BE
IN THIS CASE.
AND, I WAS BARELY --
>> NO.
YOU'RE, IF ANYTHING, MORE
INDEPENDENT THAN MR. COX WAS
UNDER THE REGULATION.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR.
>> BUT THAT DOESN'T REALLY GO TO
THE QUESTION THAT I RAISED.
>> YES, SIR.
I REALIZE THAT.
NOW MAY I, HOWEVER, INDICATE
VERY BRIEFLY, AND I KNOW THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION BUT I DO
FEEL THAT THE FACTS OUGHT TO BE
BEFORE THE COURT IN DETAIL,
INDICATE JUST WHAT DID TRANSPIRE
WITH RESPECT TO HOW THESE
PARTICULAR REGULATIONS, THIS
ORDER, WAS INTERPRETED BY THE
PRESIDENT'S ACTING ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND ALSO BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DESIGNATE AND ALSO BY
THE PRESIDENT, HIMSELF, AND BY
THE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF OF STAFF,
GENERAL HAIG.
MR. BORK, IN HEARINGS AT A TIME
WHEN CONGRESS WAS PRESSING THE
BILL OF AN INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR, TESTIFIED THAT
"ALTHOUGH IT IS ANTICIPATED THAT
MR. JAWORSKI WILL RECEIVE
COOPERATION FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
IN GETTING ANY EVIDENCE HE
FEELS, HE NEEDS TO CONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS FROM
PROSECUTIONS."
IT IS CLEAR AND UNDERSTOOD ON
ALL SIDES THAT HE HAS HE POWER
TO USE JUDICIAL PROCESSES TO
PURSUE EVIDENCE IF DISAGREEMENT
SHOULD DEVELOP.
IT WAS FURTHER POINTED OUT --
>> YOU'RE QUOTING FROM WHOM AND
WHAT --
>> ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL
BORK'S TESTIMONY IN THE HOUSE.
>> AND IN WHAT OCCASION?
>> AFTER I HAVE BEEN APPOINTED
AND IN CONNECTION WITH THE
HEARINGS ON THE BILL TO
ESTABLISH AN INDEPENDENT
PROSECUTOR BY CONGRESSIONAL ACT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THEN, HE FURTHER SAID, I
UNDERSTAND AND IT IS CLEAR TO
ME, THAT "MR. JAWORSKI CAN GO TO
COURT AND TEST OUT," AND THESE
ARE THE IMPORTANT WORDS, "AND
TEST OUT ANY REFUSAL TO PRODUCE
DOCUMENTS ON THE GROUNDS OF
CONFIDENTIALITY."
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL SAXBE, THEN
A DESIGNATE WHO WAS ALSO PRESENT
AT THE TIME THAT THIS MATTER WAS
DISCUSSED AND AT THE TIME THAT I
ACCEPTED THE RESPONSIBILITIES,
TESTIFIED THAT I HAD THE RIGHT
TO CONTEST AN ASSERTION OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AND STATED
THAT I CAN GO TO COURT AT ANY
TIME TO DETERMINE THAT.
NOW THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF, AS WE
POINT OUT IN OUR BRIEF, IN
ANNOUNCING THE APPOINTMENT OF A
NEW INDEPENDENT PROSECUTOR,
STATED TO THE NATION THAT HE HAD
NO GREATER INTEREST THAN TO SEE
THAT THE NEW SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
HAS THE COOPERATION FROM THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND THE
INDEPENDENCE THAT HE NEEDS TO
BRING ABOUT THAT CONCLUSION OF
THE WATERGATE INVESTIGATION.
THE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF OF STAFF,
AT THE TIME THAT THIS
APPOINTMENT WAS ACCEPTED AND AT
THE TIME THAT THE NEW
REGULATIONS WERE THEN DRAFTED BY
THE ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL, HAD
ASSURED ME, AND THIS IS A PART
OF THE RECORD, BECAUSE A LETTER
WAS WRITTEN AT THE REQUEST OF
SENATOR HUGH SCOTT TO THE WHITE
HOUSE AS A RESULT OF DISCUSSIONS
THAT HE HAD WITH GENERAL HAIG IN
WHICH I SENT A COPY OF THE
TESTIMONY THAT I HAD GIVEN TO
THE CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES, TO
THE WHITE HOUSE SO IT WOULD
FULLY BE AWARE OF IT AND THE
RECEIPT OF IT WAS ACKNOWLEDGED
WITHOUT ANY CHANGE IN THE
TESTIMONY.
SO, I HAD BEEN ASSURED OF THE
RIGHT TO JUDICIAL PROCESS AND BY
HIM AFTER HE HAD REVIEWED THE
MATTER WITH THE PRESIDENT AND HE
CAME AND TOLD ME THAT I WOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT TO TAKE THE
PRESIDENT TO COURT, AND THAT
THESE WERE THE KEY WORDS IN THIS
ARRANGEMENT, AND THAT THE RIGHT
WOULD NOT BE QUESTIONED.
OF COURSE, THIS INDEPENDENCE WAS
GIVEN TO THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
ACTUALLY, IT WAS BUT AN ECHO OF
PUBLIC DEMAND.
AND, IF I MAY BE PERMITTED TO
SAY SO, IT WAS THE ONLY BASIS ON
WHICH, AFTER WHAT HAD OCCURRED
AND A PREDECESSOR HAD BEEN
DISCHARGED, IT WAS ON A BASIS ON
WHICH THAT SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
COULD HAVE FELT THAT HE COULD
COME AND SERVE AND UNDERTAKE TO
PERFORM THESE FUNCTIONS.
IT'S IMPORTANT, I THINK, TO
OBSERVE THAT THE COUNSEL FOR THE
PRESIDENT IN HIS BRIEF, BY
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSITION THAT
THE PRESIDENT AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL CAN DELEGATE CERTAIN
EXECUTIVE FUNCTIONS TO
SUBORDINATE OFFICERS, IMPLICITLY
HAS CONCEDED, SO WE THINK, THE
VALIDITY OF THE REGULATIONS
DELEGATING PROSECUTORIAL POWERS
TO THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
THE REGULATIONS SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDE, AS YOU WILL NOTICE FROM
THE APPENDIX AND WE HAVE SET
THEM OUT, THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WILL NOT COUNTERMAN OR
INTERFERE WITH THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR'S DECISIONS OR
ACTIONS.
THIS IS ALSO A PART OF THE
CHARTER.
JUST TO ARGUE AS HAS BEEN DONE
IN THESE BRIEFS, THAT THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS PRECLUDES
THE COURTS FROM ENTERTAINING
THIS ACTION BECAUSE IT IS THE
EXCLUSIVE PREROGATIVE OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, NOT THE
JUDICIARY, TO DETERMINE WHOM TO
PROSECUTE, ON WHAT CHARGES, AND
WITH WHAT EVIDENCE, WE THINK,
MISSES THE POINT.
WHAT HAS EVOLVED FROM THE
REGULATIONS, IN OUR VIEW, IS A
PROSECUTORIAL FORCE WITH CERTAIN
EXCLUSIVE RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND THIS IS WHY I SAY THAT TO
SOME DEGREE IT COULD BE
DESCRIBED AS A QUASI-INDEPENDENT
AGENCY.
IT'S NOT UNLIKE OUR SITUATION AS
THE CASE WE ALLUDED TO A FEW
MINUTES AGO, DECIDED BY THE
COURT JUST A WEEK OR SO AGO.
IT'S NOT UNLIKE THE CASE OF THE
SECRETARY OF AGRICULTURE VERSUS
THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT
THERE HAS BEEN AN ACTION BROUGHT
BY ONE MEMBER OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AGAINST ANOTHER OFFICIAL
IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
AND, WE REFER TO THESE CASES IN
OUR BRIEFS IN DETAIL.
NOW, I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THE PRESIDENT, AT NO POINT
OF COURSE, DELEGATED TO THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR THE EXCLUSIVE
RIGHT TO PASS ON THE QUESTION OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE OR ANY OTHER
PRIVILEGE, ATTORNEY-INCLINED
PRIVILEGE, OR ANY OTHER
TESTIMONIAL PRIVILEGE.
WHAT WE ARE MERELY SAYING IS
THAT WE HAVE THE CLEAR RIGHT TO
TEST IT IN THIS COURT, AND THIS
IS ON WHAT WE STAND.
WELL BECAUSE OF THE PASSAGE OF
TIME, IF I MAY, I THINK I SHOULD
GET TO OTHER DISCUSSIONS UNLESS
THERE ARE QUESTIONS ON THIS
PARTICULAR POINT.
PASSING TO THE MERITS, WE WOULD
SAY THAT IF THERE IS ANY ONE
PRINCIPLE OF LAW THAT MARBURY
VERSUS MADISON CITES, IT IS THAT
IT IS UP TO THE COURT TO SAY
WHAT THE LAW IS AND ALMOST TO
THE POINT OF REDUNDANCY BUT
NECESSARY BECAUSE IT WAS A
LANDMARK DECISION.
CHIEF JUSTICE MARSHALL REASONED,
WE THINK, WITH CLARITY AND
EMPHASIS THAT IT IS EMPHATICALLY
THE PROVINCE AND THE DUTY OF THE
JUDICIAL DEPARTMENT TO SAY WHAT
THE LAW IS.
AND THIS COURT OF COURSE,
THROUGH THE YEARS, HAS
REAFFIRMED CONSISTENTLY APPLIED
THAT RULE.
IT'S DONE IT IN A NUMBER OF
CASES, IN POWELL VERSUS
MCCORMACK, IN THE YOUNGSTOWN
STEEL SEIZURE CASE, AND DOE
VERSUS MCMILLAN.
AND A FOOTNOTE, I THINK A VERY
IMPORTANT ONE, APPEARS IN THAT
OPINION WHEN MR. JUSTICE WHITE
POINTED OUT THAT WHILE AN
INQUIRY SUCH AS INVOLVED IN A
PRESENT CASE, BECAUSE IT
INVOLVES TWO COORDINATE BRANCHES
OF GOVERNMENT, MUST NECESSARILY
HAVE SEPARATION OF POWER
IMPLICATIONS.
THE SEPARATION OF POWERS
DOCTRINE HAS NOT PREVIOUSLY
PREVENTED THIS COURT FROM
REVIEWING THE ACTS OF CONGRESS
EVEN WHEN, IT IS POINTED OUT,
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH IS ALSO
INVOLVED.
NOW, THERE ARE A NUMBER OF CASES
THAT SPEAK TO THAT.
I THINK ONE OF THE CASES THAT
WENT INTO GREATER DETAIL AND
ALSO POINTS OUT QUITE A
DISTINGUISHING FEATURE IS THE
GRAVEL CASE WHERE AS, IN THE
GRAVEL CASE, THE COURT DID HOLD
THAT IT WAS APPROPRIATE TO GO
INTO CERTAIN MATTERS WHERE A
PRIVILEGE HAD BEEN EXERCISED ON
A PART OF A SENATOR ON BEHALF OF
HIS AID.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT I
BELIEVE CLEARLY HELP US IN THAT
DECISION AND ALSO OTHER
DECISIONS AS FAR AS THE
QUESTIONS HERE ARE INVOLVED.
ONE IS THAT THE SPEECH OR DEBATE
CLAUSE IS IN THE CONSTITUTION,
AS IS THE JOURNAL CLAUSE.
IT'S IN THE CONSTITUTION.
IT'S WRITTEN IN THERE.
AND, THIS IS WHAT WAS INVOKED.
I DON'T FIND ANYTHING WRITTEN IN
THE CONSTITUTION AND NOTHING HAS
BEEN POINTED THAT IS A WRITING
IN THE CONSTITUTION THAT RELATES
TO THE RIGHT OF THE EXERCISE OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE ON THE PART
OF THE PRESIDENT.
ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT THING
THAT'S POINTED OUT IN THAT CASE
IS THAT IT DID INVOLVE AN
EXAMINATION INTO WRONGDOING ON
THAT PART OF THOSE WHO WERE
SEEKING TO INVOKE THE PRIVILEGE.
>> IS THE TERM "EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE" AN ANCIENT ONE?
>> I BEG YOUR PARDON, SIR?
>> IS THE TERM "EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE" AN ANCIENT ONE?
>> IT HAS BEEN USED OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME.
HOW ANCIENT, MR. JUSTICE
BRENNAN, I'M NOT IN POSITION TO
SAY.
BUT, CERTAINLY, IT HAS BEEN ONE
THAT'S BEEN USED OVER THE YEARS
BUT IT IS NOT ONE THAT I FIND IT
A BASIS FOR IN THE CONSTITUTION.
>> ARE YOU, NOW, ARGUING THAT
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
>> NO, SIR.
>> I DIDN'T THINK SO.
>> NO, SIR, BUT I SAID IT HAD NO
BASIS FOR IT IN THE
CONSTITUTIONS BUT --
>> DO YOU THINK, IF ANYTHING,
IT'S A COMMON LAW PRIVILEGE?
IS THAT YOUR POINT?
>> YES, SIR, AND THAT IT HAS
BEEN JUDICIALLY RECOGNIZED, AND
APPROPRIATELY SO, IN A NUMBER OF
CASES.
AS WE SEE IT, WE DO NOT THINK
THAT IT IS AN APPROPRIATE ONE IN
THIS CASE BUT WE CERTAINLY DO
NOT, FOR A MOMENT, FEEL THAT IT
HAS ANY CONSTITUTIONAL FACE.
>> IN SAWYER AGAINST ROSE I
THOUGHT WE HELD THAT THERE IS A
COMMON LAW PRIVILEGE IN THE
EXECUTIVES DEALING AT THE STATE
LEVEL, BUT THAT IT IS A
QUALIFIED PRIVILEGE, IS THAT NOT
SO?
>> MR. CHIEF JUSTICE, THAT IS
EXACTLY THE POINT.
THIS COURT HAS EXAMINED A NUMBER
OF SITUATIONS AND IN SOME
SITUATIONS AS, I THINK, WAS
POINTED OUT EARLIER WHERE
MILITARY SECRETS AND SUCH AS
THAT WERE INVOLVED OR NATIONAL
SECRETS OF GREAT IMPORTANCE, THE
COURT HAS TAKEN A GOOD CLOSE
LOOK AND HAS UPHELD PRIVILEGE.
BUT --
>> WHEN YOU SAY "HAS TAKEN A
GOOD CLOSE LOOK," WITHOUT
LOOKING AT THE EVIDENCE
SOMETIMES HAS TAKEN A GOOD CLOSE
LOOK AT THE CLAIM AND THE BASIS
OF THE CLAIM.
IS THAT WHAT YOU MEAN?
>> THAT'S WHAT I MEAN.
YES, SIR.
>> BUT HASN'T THIS COURT SAID
THAT IT DID HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL
OVERTONE?
>> IT SAID THAT IT HAD
CONSTITUTIONAL OVERTONES AND I
DON'T KNOW IT MAY HAVE BEEN USED
BUT IT --
>> TORT CLAIMS, I THINK.
>> YES, BUT IT CERTAINLY HAS
NEVER PLACED IT IN THE
CONSTITUTION, SO FAR AS I'M
AWARE OF, AND PRESIDENT'S
COUNSEL WHO HAVE CAREFULLY
EXAMINED THE AUTHORITIES.
>> THAT WAS (INAUDIBLE) CHEMICAL
CORPORATION WHO SUPPORTED THE
CLAIMS.
>> YES.
>> IN THAT GREAT REVIEW.
>> IT'S JUDICIALLY TAILORED?
>> YES, SIR.
>> IS IT YOUR VIEW THAT THERE
ARE NO INFERENCES TO BE ARRIVED
FROM THE DOCTRINE OF SEPARATION
OF POWERS OR YOU'RE SAYING THIS
IS PURELY AN EVIDENTIARY
PRIVILEGE?
>> THAT THE PRIVILEGE, AS
RECOGNIZED JUDICIALLY, MAY HAVE
BEEN TIED INTO THE SEPARATION OF
POWERS DOCTRINE, WE DON'T DENY.
WHAT WE SAY IS THAT SEPARATION
OF POWERS DOCTRINE, IN THE
EXERCISE AND THE CALLING FOR
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, HAS NOT
BEEN APPLIED.
IN A NUMBER OF INSTANCES
INVOLVING BOTH CONGRESS AND
INVOLVING ALSO THE EXECUTIVE,
DESPITE THE FACT THAT EVEN IN
CONGRESSIONAL SITUATIONS, SPEECH
AND DEBATE CLAUSE IS THERE.
WHAT I AM SAYING IS THAT THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS DOCTRINE,
AS WAS POINTED TO IN THE DOE
VERSUS MCMILLAN CASE, HAS NOT
BEEN PERMITTED TO STAND IN THE
WAY OF THIS COURT EXAMINING IT
IN THE STANDPOINT OF WHETHER THE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE SHOULD BE
PERMITTED OR NOT.
THIS IS WHAT I'M SAYING.
>> IN REYNOLDS, THE COURT ENDED
UP TREATING THE ASSERTION OF
PRIVILEGE THERE AS AN
EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGE, BUT IT
DID ALLUDE TO THE FACT THAT
THERE WAS A CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTION AND SAID THE COURT
WASN'T REACHING IT, AS I RECALL.
>> THE ISSUE OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, I SHOULD POINT OUT
HERE, IS A VERY NARROW ONE.
AND, I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE BEAR THIS IN MIND.
IT DOESN'T INVOLVE A VERY LARGE
OR BROAD PRIVILEGE RIGHTS.
WHAT IT REALLY NARROWS DOWN TO
IS SOMEWHAT SIMPLE BUT VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND THAT IS WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT, IN A PENDING
PROSECUTION, CAN WITHHOLD
MATERIAL EVIDENCE FROM THE COURT
MERELY ON HIS ASSERTION THAT THE
EVIDENCE INVOLVES CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS AND THIS IS WHAT
REALLY IT GETS DOWN TO.
WE KNOW THAT SOVEREIGN
PREROGATIVES TO PROTECT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY NECESSARY TO
CARRYOUT RESPONSIBILITIES IN THE
FIELDS OF INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS AND NATIONAL DEFENSE
ARE NOT, HERE, INVOLVED.
AND, THERE IS NO CLAIM OF ANY
STATE SECRETS OR THAT DISCLOSURE
WILL HAVE DIRE EFFECT ON A
NATION OR ITS PEOPLE.
ACTUALLY, I THINK WHEN WE GET TO
WAYNE AND THE NON-DISCLOSURE AS
AGAINST DISCLOSURE AND I THINK
WHEN WE BEGIN TO LAY THE BALANCE
OF INTEREST, IT WOULD SEEM TO ME
THAT THE BALANCE CLEARLY LIES IN
FAVOR OF A DISCLOSURE IN A
SITUATION SUCH AS THE
CIRCUMSTANCE HERE.
OF COURSE --
>> IT CERTAINLY WOULD NOT BE
TRUE IN CASE THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
WAS INVOLVED, BUT THAT'S NOT
PRESENT HERE.
>> NOT PRESENT, MR. JUSTICE
DOUGLAS, AND THERE IS NO
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT HAS VERY PLAINLY
WRITTEN OUT IN THE CONSTITUTION
AND IS INVOKED AS A CLEAR
CONSTITUTIONAL PRIVILEGE.
I THINK IT WOULD BE OF HELP IF I
MAY POINT OUT TO THE COURT, THAT
THERE IS AN EXCELLENT ARTICLE
THAT WE HAVE ALLUDED TO IN OUR
BRIEFS BY PROFESSOR BERGER THAT
APPEARS IN A YALE LAW JOURNAL
WHICH DISCUSSES THE EHRENBERG
CASE AT LENGTH AND ALSO OTHER
CASES THAT HAVE BEEN POINTED TO
SINCE THE TIME OF THAT CASE.
AND, IF I MAY JUST SAY VERY
BRIEFLY, THAT SUMMARIZES THE
SITUATION BY SAYING THAT THE
HEART OF MARSHALL'S OPINION WAS,
THEREFORE, JUST AS SUMMARIZED BY
THE COURT OF APPEALS IN THE
NIXON V. SIRICA CASE AND THE
TAPES CASE THAT WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT.
THE COURT WAS TO SHOW RESPECT
FOR THE PRESIDENT'S REASON, BUT
THE ULTIMATE DECISION REMAINED
WITH THE COURT.
AND WE ARE NOT SUGGESTING, FOR A
MOMENT, HERE THAT THE MATTER OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE SHOULD NOT
BE LOOKED INTO.
THIS IS NOT -- IT DESERVES TO BE
TESTED.
IT SHOULD BE TESTED AND WE URGE
THAT IT BE TESTED.
BUT, THE ULTIMATE DECISION IS
NOT ONE OF SAYING THAT IT IS
ABSOLUTE THAT IT RESTS ON THE
CONSTITUTION THAT IT DOESN'T
ENTITLE ANYONE AND DOESN'T
AUTHORIZE ANYONE.
IT DOESN'T EVEN AUTHORIZE THIS
COURT TO LOOK INTO IT, BECAUSE
IF THE COURTS ARE THE ULTIMATE
INTERPRETERS OF THE CONSTITUTION
AND CAN RESTRAIN CONGRESS TO
OPERATE WITHIN THE
CONSTITUTIONAL BALANCE, THEYCE'D
AND LEST TO MEASURE PRESIDENTIAL
CLAIMS OF CONSTITUTIONAL POWERS.
I WANTED BRIEFLY TO MAKE MENTION
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED BY COUNSEL FOR THE
PRESIDENT THAT INVOLVES A MOTION
TO EXPUNGE THE FINDING OF THE
GRAND JURY'S ACTION THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS TO BE NAMED AS AN
UNINDICTED CO-CONSPIRATOR ALONG
WITH A NUMBER OF OTHERS WHEN THE
PRETRIAL PROCEEDINGS ARE GOING
INTO, AND A BILL OF PARTICULARS
AND I SAY THAT THE GRAND JURY'S
FINDING, PAINFUL AS IT IS, I
THINK, ON THE PART OF THE COURT,
MUST BE CONSIDERED AS BEING
VALID AND SUFFICIENT TO SHOW A
PRIMA FACIE.
IT IS SUFFICIENT TO SHOW A PRIMA
FACIE THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
INVOLVED IN THE PROCEEDINGS IN
THE COURSE AND THE CONTINUATION
OF THE PARTICULAR CONSPIRACY
THAT WAS CHARGED.
>> WELL, IS THAT THE ISSUE, MR.
JAWORSKI, OR IS THE ISSUE
WHETHER THERE COULD BE A
COLLATERAL ATTACK?
>> THAT'S ALSO ANOTHER ISSUE.
BUT I MERELY WANTED TO POINT OUT
THAT I BELIEVE THAT THIS COURT
WOULD NOT GO INTO THE GRAND
JURY'S FINDINGS, BUT IT'S A
PRIMA FACIE MATTER AND THAT THIS
COURT WOULD NOT GO INTO IT FOR
THE PURPOSE OF DETERMINING A
MATTER OF THAT KIND.
>> I THOUGHT WE HAVE PUT THAT
ISSUE ASIDE A WHILE AGO.
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
RELEVANCE IT IS TO THIS CASE.
>> WELL, I HAVE TO AGREE WITH
YOU, NEITHER DO I SEE WHAT THE
RELEVANCE IS OF THE MATTER OF
SAYING THAT THERE'S ANOTHER
ARGUMENT ADVANCED HERE AND THAT
IS THAT THE PRESIDENT CAN'T BE
INDICTED.
AND, I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
RELEVANCE OF THAT IS IN THIS
CASE EITHER, VERY FRANKLY,
BECAUSE IT ISN'T BEFORE THE
COURT.
AND, YET, THE ARGUMENT IS MADE
AND MANY PAGES OF BRIEFS ARE
DEVOTED TO IT.
>> I JUST WONDER, MR. JAWORSKI,
WHY YOU DON'T, ON CONTENT, WITH
JUST ARGUING IT IS IRRELEVANT
WITHOUT THINKING ON THE RIGHT --
>> WELL, THIS IS WHY I SKIPPED
THE ARGUMENT WITH RESPECT TO THE
MATTER OF WHETHER HE COULD BE
INDICTED OR NOT.
BUT AS MUCH AS THE QUESTION HAD
BEEN RAISED AND BRIEFED AND A
MOTION EXIST BEFORE THE COURT, I
HAVE TO AGREE THAT IT IS
IRRELEVANT BUT IT IS A PART OF
THE CASE, AND THAT'S THE ONLY
REASON I ALLUDED TO IT AND I
HAVE NO INTERESTING IN SPENDING
MUCH TIME ON IT.
>> WELL, EXCEPT, PART OF THE
GROUNDS ON WHICH YOU REST IN
SUBPOENAING THIS MATERIAL IS THE
FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
HIMSELF BEEN NAMED AS A
CO-CONSPIRATOR, AN UNINDICTED
ONE.
AND, THAT'S TRUE, ISN'T IT?
THAT'S A PART OF --
>> RIGHT.
>> THESE TWO GROUNDS UPON WHICH
YOU REST IN SUBPOENAING THIS
MATERIAL.
AND, THE RESPONSE TO THAT IS,
THE PRESIDENT CANNOT
CONSTITUTIONALLY BE NAMED AS AN
UNINDICTED CO-CONSPIRATOR.
SO, TO THAT EXTENT, IT'S IN THIS
CASE.
THE QUESTION'S IN THIS CASE.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK IT'S A
MATTER THAT, VERY FRANKLY, HAS
ANY PARTICULAR BASIS TO IT
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE HOW THIS
COURT COULD BE ASKED TO
SUBSTITUTE ITS JUDGMENT FOR THAT
OF THE GRAND JURY.
>> WELL, THAT'S SOMETHING QUITE
DIFFERENT AGAIN, WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WAS SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
BEFORE THE GRAND JURY TO JUSTIFY
THE GRAND JURY IN NAMING THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S QUITE A DIFFERENT AND, AS
CHIEF JUSTICE SUGGESTED, A
COLLATERAL ISSUE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> BUT THE ISSUE OF WHETHER OR
NOT THE PRESIDENT CAN
CONSTITUTIONALLY BE NAMED BY A
GRAND JURY AS A CO-CONSPIRATOR,
EVEN THOUGH AN UNINDICTED ONE,
IT IS AT LEAST TANGENTIALLY
BEFORE US BECAUSE THAT'S -- IT'S
THE FACT THAT HE'S PART OF THE
GROUNDS AND PART OF THE
FOUNDATION UPON WHICH YOU HAVE
BASED YOUR SUBPOENA DUCES TECUM.
>> NOT ONLY THAT, I THINK THAT
IT HAS, TO PINPOINT IT IN OUR
VIEW, A MATERIALITY BECAUSE IT
DOES RELATE TO THE QUESTION OF
THE PROOF THAT WE ARE SEEKING
THE RELEVANCE OF THE PROOF THAT
WE ARE SEEKING.
AND THIS GETS INTO, OF COURSE, A
DISCUSSION OF MATTERS THAT ARE
SEALED AND WHICH I CANNOT
DISCUSS WITH THE COURT.
>> I UNDERSTAND, RIGHT.
>> BUT WHETHER OR NOT HE HAD THE
AUTHORITY, THEY DID, IT IS A
FACT THAT THE GRAND JURY DID IT.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR.
>> SO IT DOESN'T -- I DON'T SEE
HOW WE HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
WHETHER THEY HAD AUTHORITY OR
NOT.
IT'S A FACT.
ISN'T THAT TRUE?
>> THAT'S, I THINK, CORRECT.
NOW --
>> I THOUGHT THE HEART OF THIS
CASE WERE THE RIGHTS OF
DEFENDANTS IN CRIMINAL TRIAL?
>> THAT --
>> NEVERTHELESS --
>> THAT IS VERY MUCH --
>> THAT MAY BE EXCULPATORY AND
FREE THEM OF ALL LIABILITIES.
I DON'T KNOW BUT I --
>> WELL, CERTAINLY, IT'S IN THE
CASE NOW AND, OF COURSE, WHICH
YOU HAVE REFERENCE TOO ALSO, I'M
SURE, MR. JUSTICE DOUGLAS, AS
THE BRAY AND THE JINKS, MARYLAND
VERSUS BRAY AND THE JINKS.
AND, THIS IS A PART OF THE
CASE.
HOWEVER, IT HAPPENS NOT TO BE A
PART OF THE APPEAL, ALTHOUGH IT
IS A PART OF THE CASE.
BUT AS FAR AS OUR POSITION IS
CONCERNED, IT DOESN'T RELATE TO
THAT.
BUT, CERTAINLY, IT'S TRUE THAT
THIS MATERIAL, AS WE HAD POINTED
OUT IN OUR COMMUNICATIONS TO THE
PRESIDENT, MAY WELL INVOLVE
EXCULPATORY MATTERS AND WE, TIME
AND AGAIN, POINTED OUT WE WANTED
THEM NOT SIMPLY BECAUSE WE FELT
THAT THERE WERE MATTERS THAT
NEEDED TO BE DEVELOPED IN
CONNECTION WITH THE PROSECUTION,
BUT THAT THEY COULD WELL CONTAIN
EXCULPATORY MATTERS.
>> BUT THE BRADY QUESTION REALLY
LURKS JUST IN THE BACKGROUND,
DOES IT NOT?
THAT IS, IF YOU GET INFORMATION,
WHATEVER YOU GET --
>> WOULD BE AVAILABLE.
>> YOU WOULD CONCEDE IS
AVAILABLE TO ANY DEFENDANT --
>> THAT'S RIGHT, MR. CHIEF
JUSTICE.
>> WHO CAN MAKE THE SHOWING.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR.
>> AND THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
OR NOT THE DEFENDANTS, UNDER THE
BRADY DOCTRINE, ARE ENTITLED TO
SUBPOENAING INFORMATION.
AND MATERIAL THAT'S NOT NOW IN
YOUR POSSESSION, BUT IS IN THE
POSSESSION OF THE PRESIDENT, WAS
AN ISSUE THAT WAS LEFT UNDECIDED
BY THE DISTRICT COURT.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR.
>> AM I RIGHT ABOUT THAT?
>> IT'S NOT BEFORE THIS COURT.
I BELIEVE, WITH THE PERMISSION
OF THE COURT, UNLESS THERE ARE
FURTHER QUESTIONS, I'LL RESERVE
THE REST OF THE TIME FOR THE
CLOSE.
>> MR. ST. CLAIR.
>> MR. CHIEF JUSTICE AND MEMBERS
OF THE COURT.
MY LEARNED BROTHERS APPROACHED
THIS CASE I THINK IN THE
TRADITIONAL POINT OF VIEW,
NAMELY, THIS IS AN ATTEMPT BY A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO OBTAIN
WHAT HE THINKS IS DESIRABLE
EVIDENCE IN A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION THAT HE HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY FOR.
NOT ONCE, HOWEVER, HAVE I HEARD
HIM MENTION WHAT I THINK IS
REALLY INVOLVED, AT LEAST IN A
SIGNIFICANT PART, AND THAT IS
THE CO-PENDENCY OF THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS BEFORE
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
AND, THE REALISTIC FUSION THAT
HAS TAKEN PLACE WITH RESPECT TO
THESE TWO PROCEEDINGS AND THE
PROMISE OF CONTINUED FUSION, AS
I UNDERSTAND MY BROTHER'S
POSITION.
MAY I QUOTE FROM PAGE 50 --
>> NONE OF OUR PROBLEMS, ARE
THEY?
>> I THINK, SIR, THEY REALLY
ARE.
FIRST, BY WAY OF FACTUAL
BACKGROUND --
>> THE SOLE AUTHORITY TO IMPEACH
THIS IN THE HOUSE --
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> THE SOLE AUTHORITY TO TRY
THIS IN THE SENATE.
>> RIGHT, AND THE COURT SHALL
NOT BE USED TO IMPLEMENT OR AID
THAT PROCESS WHICH WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THIS CASE.
THIS CASE WOULDN'T BE HERE ON
JULY 8.
>> HOW IS THAT?
>> JUST HOW IS THIS DONE?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> HOW IS THIS CASE IMPLEMENTED?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO REVIEW SOME
OF THE FACTS FOR YOU IN THIS
REGARD.
>> WHICH ARE IN THE RECORD?
>> YES, MY BROTHER HAS MENTIONED
THEM TO YOU.
>> NO, BUT ARE THEY IN THE
RECORD, NOT WHAT HE'S MENTIONED.
>> YES, SIR.
>> WELL, WE'RE JUST AN ADJUNCT
OF THE HOUSE.
THIS CASE SHOULD BE DISMISSED AS
IMPROVIDENTLY GRANTED, ISN'T IT?
>> EXACTLY RIGHT, SIR.
NOT ONLY THAT, IT MAKES THE CASE
UNJUSTICIABLE AT LEAST.
NOW --
>> BUT THE DISTRICT COURT'S
DECISION STANDS.
IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT?
>> NO, THE CASE SHOULD BE
DISMISSED, SIR.
>> IF WE DISMISS AS
IMPROVIDENTLY GRANTED, I SUBMIT
THE DISTRICT COURT'S PREMIUM
WOULD -- THE JUDGMENT WOULD
STAND.
>> THEN I WOULD RETRACT WHAT I
SAID.
THIS CASE SHOULD BE
DISMISSED.[LAUGHTER]
>> THE CASE WOULD BE ON APPEAL
IN THE COURT OF APPEALS IF WE
DISMISSED IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> ARE YOU NOW TALKING ABOUT THE
BYPASSING OF THE COURT OF
APPEALS?
>> NO, SIR.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE PROCEEDING
BEFORE THE DISTRICT COURT
THROUGH THE COURT OF APPEALS TO
THIS COURT.
>> WELL, IF WE DISMISS THIS
APPEAL AS IMPROVIDENTLY GRANTED,
IT WOULD GO BACK TO THE COURT OF
APPEALS.
>> WELL, AS I SAY, I THINK THIS
CASE SHOULD BE DISMISSED.
>> NO, REALLY WHAT YOU MEAN,
ISN'T IT, YOU THINK THAT THE
ORDER OF JUDGE SIRICA SHOULD BE
VACATED --
>> SET ASIDE.
>> AND SET ASIDE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, YES.
>> THAT'S QUITE DIFFERENT FROM
DISMISSING THE CASE.
>> I AGREE.
>> THAT'S DECIDING IT ON THE
MERITS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S WHY I'M TRYING TO GET
ACROSS TO THIS COURT, PERHAPS ON
OUR PLEA, THIS CASE SHOULD BE
DISPOSED OF, BE IT BY VACATING
THE ORDER BELOW OR NOT.
BUT, IN ANY EVENT, IT IS
IMPROPER IN OUR VIEW THAT THIS
CASE SHOULD BE HEARD IN THE
CONTEXT IT IS NOW BEING HEARD.
WE WOULDN'T BE HERE ON JULY 8
BEFORE A CROWDED COURTROOM IF IT
WAS NOT RECOGNIZED GENERALLY.
>> WELL, IT'S A POLITICAL
QUESTION HERE --
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> IT'S A POLITICAL QUESTION IN
THE DISTRICT COURT.
>> AND, THEREFORE, IT'S A
NON-JUSTICIABLE ISSUE IN THIS
AND IN THE DISTRICT COURT.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN THIS CASE
IS --
>> DID YOU ARGUE THAT TO THE
DISTRICT JUDGE?
>> I BELIEVE WE ARGUED A
NON-JUSTICIABILITY ARGUMENT.
YES, SIR.
I KNOW WE DID, BUT IF YOU'RE --
>> YOUR POSITION IS THAT THE
ISSUANCE OF A SUBPOENA DUCES
TECUM IS NOT A JUSTICIABLE
ISSUE.
>> IN THIS CONTEXT AT THIS TIME,
SIR.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS THIS.
AS YOU KNOW, ON FEBRUARY 24, A
GRAND JURY SECRETLY NAMED THE
PRESIDENT AMONG OTHERS AS AN
UNINDICTED CO-CONSPIRATOR.
THAT FACT WAS NOT MADE KNOWN.
ON MARCH 1, AN INDICTMENT WAS
RETURNED AGAINST A NUMBER OF THE
PRESIDENT'S CHIEF AIDS.
COINCIDENT WITH THAT IN AN OPEN
COURTROOM, THE ASSISTANT
PROSECUTOR, SPECIAL PROSECUTOR,
HANDED UP TO THE JUDGE A BAG
TOGETHER WITH A SEALED LETTER
REQUESTING THAT THIS MATERIAL BE
SENT OVER TO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
THE PRESIDENT TOOK NO POSITION
REGARDING THAT PROPOSAL BECAUSE
HE CONSIDERED IT TO BE PROBABLY
APPROPRIATE, UNDER THE BELIEF
THAT THERE WAS NOTHING
ACCUSATORY IN THAT MATERIAL.
JUDGE SIRICA, HIMSELF, REVIEWED
THE MATERIAL, FOUND NOTHING
ACCUSATORY AND SAID IT WOULD
THEREFORE BE QUITE APPROPRIATE
TO SEND THIS MATERIAL TO THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES NOT
REALIZING AND NOT KNOWING THAT
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HAD
PREVIOUSLY OBTAINED A SECRET
CHARGE AGAINST THE PRESIDENT AND
OTHERS WHICH WAS DEFINITELY
ACCUSATORY.
>> BUT THAT, AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
WAS NOT AMONG THE MATERIAL THAT
WAS CONVEYED TO THE GRAND JURY.
THERE SEEMS TO BE, IF I'M -- AT
LEAST THAT'S WHAT I UNDERSTOOD
MR. JAWORSKI TO TELL US THIS
MORNING.
>> THE MATERIAL WAS TURNED OVER.
IT WAS BEFORE THE GRAND JURY.
>> NOW, JUST A MOMENT.
I UNDERSTOOD MR. JAWORSKI TO
TELL US THIS MORNING, VERY
UNAMBIGUOUSLY AND EXPLICITLY,
THAT THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT
WAS NAMED AS AN UNINDICTED
CO-CONSPIRATOR WAS NOT CONVEYED
TO THE GRAND JURY.
>> A GRAND JURY --
>> IT WAS RELEASED, I THINK, TO
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
>> NO, IT WAS NOT.
>> I THOUGHT-
>> THE MATERIAL WAS SENT TO THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES IN THE
BELIEF THAT IT WAS
NON-ACCUSATORY IN NATURE.
IT WAS SIMPLY A RECITAL OF
FACTS.
>> EXACTLY, AND THAT'S WHAT MR.
JAWORSKI HAS REPRESENTED AGAIN
TO US THIS MORNING, WAS THE FACT
OF THE MATTER.
>> BUT THE --MR. JAWORSKI HAD
AVAILABLE TO HIM, UNKNOWN TO THE
JUDGE AND UNKNOWN TO COUNSEL FOR
THE PRESIDENT, A SECRET
INDICTMENT NAMING THE PRESIDENT
AS A CO-CONSPIRATOR.
THE ACCUSATORY PART FOLLOWED
LATER.
>> NOW, FOLLOWED IN WHAT FORM?
>> BY A NEWSPAPER LEAK.
>> YES, IT WASN'T SENT FROM THE
COURT OVER TO THE HOUSE, WAS IT?
>> IT DIDN'T HAVE TO BE.
ALL THEY HAD TO DO WAS READ THE
NEWSPAPER.
THERE CAN BE NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
AND THEREFORE, I SAY, THIS CASE
HAS TO BE VIEWED REALISTICALLY
IN THE CONTEXT THAT IT IS NOW
BEING HEARD.
>> I'M NOT SURE, PERHAPS YOU CAN
HELP ME.
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT THERE
WAS SOME DUTY ON THE PART OF THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO DISCLOSE
TO THE DISTRICT JUDGE THAT THERE
WAS THIS SECRET INDICTMENT
BEFORE THE JUDGE PASSED ON
WHETHER THE MATERIAL SHOULD BE
SENT TO THE HOUSE?
>> I THINK IT WOULD'VE BEEN
QUITE APPROPRIATE BECAUSE THE
JUDGE'S DECISION WAS BASED ON
THE PROPOSITION THERE WAS
NOTHING ACCUSATORY.
THAT, UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES,
ABSOLUTE FAIRNESS WAS
APPROPRIATE AND REQUIRED IN SO
FAR AS THE PRESIDENT WAS
CONCERNED.
NO ONE COULD ARGUE THAT THE
INDICTMENT AS A CO-CONSPIRATOR
OR NAMING AS A CO-CONSPIRATOR
DOES ANYTHING BUT IMPAIR THE
PRESIDENT'S POSITION BEFORE THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
THAT SHOULD, IN MY JUDGMENT,
HAVE BEEN MADE KNOWN TO THE
JUDGE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE WOULD'VE
DONE UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES.
HIS DECISION WAS BASED SOLIDLY
ON THE PROPOSITION THERE WAS
NOTHING ACCUSATORY IN THE
MATERIAL.
NOW, MY BROTHER SAYS IN HIS
BRIEF THAT THIS MATERIAL HE NOW
SEEKS, OF COURSE, WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO THE HOUSE COMMITTEE
AND WILL BE USED TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
SO, THIS FUSION IS GOING TO
CONTINUE.
AND UNDER THE CONSTITUTION, AS
WE VIEW IT, ONLY THE LEGISLATURE
HAS THE RIGHT TO CONDUCT
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
THE COURTS HAVE BEEN, FROM THE
HISTORY INVOLVED AND FROM THE
LANGUAGE OF THE PROVISIONS,
EXCLUDED FROM THAT FUNCTION.
AND, YET, THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
IS DRAWING THIS COURT IN TO
THOSE PROCEEDINGS INEVITABLY AND
INEXORABLY.
NO ONE COULD STAND HERE AND
ARGUE WITH ANY CANDOR THAT THE
DECISION OF THIS COURT WOULD
HAVE NO IMPACT WHATSOEVER ON THE
PENDING INQUIRY BEFORE THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES CONCERNING
THE IMPEACHMENT OF THE
PRESIDENT.
>> HOW FAR DOES YOUR POINT GO?
LET'S ASSUME THAT A MURDER TOOK
PLACE ON THE STREETS OF
WASHINGTON OF WHICH THE
PRESIDENT HAPPENED TO BE ONE OF
THE VERY FEW EYEWITNESSES, AND
SOMEBODY WAS INDICTED FOR THAT
MURDER AND THE PRESIDENT WAS
SUBPOENAED AS A WITNESS.
WOULD YOU SAY HE CANNOT BE
SUBPOENAED NOW BECAUSE THERE IS
AN IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY GOING ON
AND THE COURTS ABSOLUTELY HAVE
TO STOP DEAD ON THEIR TRACKS OF
DOING THEIR ORDINARY JUDICIAL
BUSINESS?
>> I WOULD NOT SAY THAT.
I DON'T THINK HE COULD BE
NECESSARILY SUBPOENAED.
I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
SUBJECT TO THE PROCESS OF THE
COURT, UNLESS HE SO DETERMINES
HE WOULD GIVE EVIDENCE.
BUT, THE MURDER WOULD HAVE --
>> SETTING THAT TO ONE SIDE.
>> IN THIS CASE --
>> YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE
COURTS, AS I UNDERSTAND IT, HAVE
TO STOP DEAD IN THEIR TRACKS
FROM DOING THEIR ORDINARY
BUSINESS IN ANY MATTER INVOLVING
EVEN, TANGENTIALLY, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IF OR AS OF WHEN THE COMMITTEE
OF THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVE
S IS INVESTIGATING IMPEACHMENT.
>> NO, JUSTICE STEWART, I'M NOT.
THE SUBJECT MATTER -- THESE TWO
MATTERS, IS THE SAME SUBJECT
MATTER.
>> WELL, HERE ARE --
>> SHOULD THE PRESIDENT --
>> SEVEN PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
INDICTED.
SIX OF WHOM REMAIN UNDER
INDICTMENT.
>> RIGHT.
>> THE TRIAL IS SCHEDULED FOR
NEXT SEPTEMBER 9.
>> RIGHT.
>> THE PROSECUTOR IS PREPARING
FOR THAT TRIAL.
HE IS TRYING TO, UNDER RULE 17
OF THE FEDERAL RULES OF CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE, TO ADDUCE MATTERS TO
BE USED IN EVIDENCE AT THAT
TRIAL.
YOU SAY THAT CANNOT GO FORWARD
BECAUSE OF SOME TANGENTIAL
EFFECT OR, YOU SAY, DIRECT
EFFECT UPON SOME OTHER MATTER
GOING OUT IN ANOTHER BRANCH OF
THE GOVERNMENT.
AND HOW FAR DOES YOUR --
>> I SAY IT SHOULD NOT GO
FORWARD A THIS TIME, AT THE VERY
LEAST, BECAUSE THE SUBJECT
MATTER BEING INQUIRED OF IN THE
LARGE MEASURE BEFORE THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE IS EXACTLY THE SAME
SUBJECT MATTER BEING INVOLVED IN
THIS ARGUMENT.
>> HOW DO WE KNOW?
>> NAMELY, SHOULD THE PRESIDENT
PRODUCE TAPES?
SHOULD HE --
>> WELL, WHAT --
>> NOT STAND ON --
>> ONE IN THESE TAPES INVOLVES
THE IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
>> PARDON?
>> WHAT, IN ANY OF THESE TAPES,
IS INVOLVED IN THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS?
>> WELL, IF YOUR HONOR PLEASE,
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
HAVE SUBPOENAED THESE AND MORE
TAPES.
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHICH OF
THE TAPES.
I ASSUME YOU DO.
>> NO, I DON'T.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW EITHER.
WELL, HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT
THEY'RE SUBJECT TO THE GREATER
PRIVILEGE?
>> WELL, I DO KNOW THAT THERE'S
A PRELIMINARY SHOWING THAT THEY
ARE CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS CLOSE AIDS,
AND --
>> REGARDLESS OF WHAT IT IS.
>> REGARDLESS OF WHAT IT IS AND
MAY INVOLVE A NUMBER OF
SUBJECTS.
>> BUT YOU DON'T KNOW.
>> BUT DOES NOT THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR CLAIM THAT THE
SUBJECT MATTER IS THE SAME?
>> HE CLAIMS THAT, BUT HE HAS NO
WAY OF SHOWING IT.
IN FACT, HE SAYS IT'S ONLY
PROBABLE OR LIKELY.
THERE IS NO WAY OF SHOWING THAT
THEY, IN FACT, INVOLVE THE
SUBJECTS OF WATERGATE.
>> THIS CLAIM WAS HONORED BUT
THIS COURT -- ALL WOULD HAVE TO
LEAVE THE EVIDENCE AND GO TO
JUDGE SIRICA WHO WOULD TAKE IT,
EXAMINE IT IN CAMERAS.
>> I PRESUME THAT'S SO AND HE
WOULD THEN -- IT WOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR.
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR SAYS
THAT, OF COURSE, THIS WOULD THEN
BECOME PART OF THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS, AND HERE WE ARE.
>> MR. ST. CLAIR, GOING BACK TO
THIS MURDER WITNESS SITUATION.
IF THE PRESIDENT, ANY PRESIDENT,
WITNESSED AN AUTOMOBILE ACCIDENT
AND WAS THE SOLE WITNESS OF
MURDER, AS MR. JUSTICE STEWART
SUGGESTED, YOU'RE NOT INDICATING
THAT HIS TESTIMONY, HIS
EVIDENCE, WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE
TO THE COURT BUT MERELY THAT HE
CAN'T BE SUBPOENAED BUT MIGHT
GIVE IT BACK BY DEPOSITION AS
SEVERAL PRESIDENTS HAVE IN THE
PAST.
>> THAT IS QUITE CORRECT.
>> THE TESTIMONY OF THE JUSTICES
OF THIS COURT HAS BEEN GIVEN IN
PAST TIMES BY DEPOSITIONS, HAS
IT NOT?
>> REALLY, IT'S A MATTER OF
ACCOMMODATION NOT AS A MATTER OF
ASSERTION OF A RIGHT OF ONE
BRANCH OVER ANOTHER.
BUT THE POINT I WANT TO MAKE,
JUSTICE BURGER, IS THAT THE SAME
SUBJECT MATTER IS INEXORABLY
INVOLVED IN BOTH PROCEEDINGS,
NOW PROCEEDING ON AT THE SAME
TIME.
AND, THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES HAS NOT SOUGHT
THE --
>> IF THAT'S TRUE, WHY ARE YOU
WILLING TO GIVE UP 20 OR SO?
>> WELL, THAT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION I'D LIKE TO ANSWER.
THE DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE IN
AN IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDING,
JUSTICE MARSHALL, ARE
ESSENTIALLY POLITICAL DECISIONS.
>> WELL, I'M TALKING ABOUT THIS
CASE.
YOU SAY YOU'LL GIVE UP 20 OF
THEM IN THIS CASE.
>> YES, WE WILL BECAUSE THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN MADE PUBLIC.
>> THE TAPES OR THE
TRANSCRIPTION?
>> WE ARE -- AS SOON AS A JUDGE
APPROVES SOME METHOD OF
VALIDATING THE ACCURACY OF THESE
TAPES, THEY CAN HAVE --
>> THE TAPES?
>> THEY CAN HAVE THE TAPES, BUT
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
THE TAPE IS A PART OF A REEL.
A REEL MAY COVER A DOZEN
CONVERSATIONS.
SO, THERE'S A MECHANICAL PROBLEM
OF TRYING TO VALIDATE OR BE SURE
THAT THIS IS CORRECT BUT IT'S
ONLY A MECHANICAL PROBLEM.
BUT ONCE THAT'S SOLVED, SUBJECT
TO THE JUDGE BELLOW'S APPROVAL,
THEY HAVE THE AVAILABILITY OF
THAT BUT --
>> WOULD THE TAPES THAT YOU'RE
WILLING TO RELEASE BE VALUABLE
TO THE WATERGATE COMMITTEE IN
TIME?
>> WE THINK SO.
THAT'S WHY WE MADE THEM.
>> WELL, I THOUGHT YOU SAID YOU
DIDN'T WANT THEM TO HAVE
ANYTHING.
>> NO, SIR.
>> AND THIS WAS MERELY AN
EVIDENT WAY OF GETTING STUFF
OVER TO HIM, BUT YOU WERE
GETTING SOME.
>> I SAY THIS.
I SAY THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
DECIDE AS A POLITICAL MATTER OF
WHAT SHOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
THE HOUSE, THAT THE COURT OUGHT
NOT TO BE DRAWN INTO THAT
DECISION.
>> THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
HE HAS NO RIGHT TO TAKE THAT
VIEW.
>> THE HOUSE TAKES A DIFFERENT
THE HOUSE HAS SUBPOENAED
SOMETHING IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
145 TAPES, AND THAT'S A
POLITICAL DECISION.
>> SO IF THE HOUSE CAN GET THEM,
THE PRESIDENT CAN GET THEM, AND
THE ONLY PEOPLE I KNOW WHO CAN'T
GET THEM IS THE COURT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT HONORED
ANY OF THE SUBPOENAS OTHER THAN
THE FIRST ONE ISSUED BY THE
HOUSE, SO THAT THERE IS A
DISPUTE IN THE HOUSE NOW BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT AND THE COMMITTEE
ON THE JUDICIARY.
IT'S ESSENTIALLY A POLITICAL
DISPUTE.
IT'S A DISPUTE THAT THIS COURT
OUGHT NOT TO BE DRAWN INTO AND
THIS RESULT OF A DECISION IN
THIS CASE WOULD INEXORABLY
RESULT IN BEING BROUGHT INTO IT.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN POINTING TO ME
THAT WE'RE BROUGHT INTO IT BY
DECIDING THIS CASE.
HOW ARE WE DRAWN INTO THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS BY
DECIDING THIS CASE?
>> THE IMPACT OF A DECISION IN
THIS CASE, UNDENIABLY, MR.
JUSTICE BRENNAN, IN MY VIEW --
>> WELL, ANY NUMBER --
>> CANNOT HAVE -- IT WILL NOT BE
OVERLOOKED.
>> ANY NUMBER OF DECISIONS OF
THIS COURT HAS --
>> WHAT I WOULD THINK WOULD BE
INAPPROPRIATE THING TO DO AT
THIS TIME BECAUSE THERE IS
PENDING --
>> YOU'VE BEEN ARGUING WE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO AUTHORITY --
>> NO, I --
>> CONSTITUTIONALLY TO DECIDE
THIS CASE.
>> I WILL ARGUE THAT IN A
MOMENT, BUT I'M ARGUING NOW THAT
YOU SHOULD NOT.
I'M ARGUING NOW, SIR, ONLY THAT
YOU SHOULD NOT BECAUSE IT WOULD
INVOLVE THIS COURT INEXORABLY IN
A POLITICAL PROCESS WHICH HAS
BEEN DETERMINED BY THE
CONSTITUTION TO BE SOLELY THE
FUNCTION OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH.
AND, IT CANNOT BE THAT THE
IMPACT OF THE COURT'S DECISION
IN THIS MATTER, WHICH IS ONE OF
THE PRINCIPLE MATTERS NOW
PENDING BEFORE THE HOUSE, WOULD
BE OVERLOOKED.
IT WOULD CERTAINLY, AS A MATTER
OF REALISTIC FACT, TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
>> BUT AS I HAVE SAID BEFORE, WE
HAVE THE BENEFICIARIES HERE ARE
SIX DEFENDANTS WHO ARE BEING
TRIED FOR CRIMINAL CHARGES.
AND, WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE
FREEDOM COMPLETELY --
>> MR. JUSTICE DOUGLAS, WE --
>> IS THAT TRUE THEORETICALLY?
>> IT MAY.
THE BRADY ISSUE, WE DON'T
BELIEVE, IS PROPERLY BEFORE THE
COURT AND HAS NOT BEEN BRIEFED
BY US NOR BY MY BROTHER.
>> AND WAS NOT DECIDED BY THE
DISTRICT COURT.
I WOULD ONLY SAY THIS, THAT IN
THE EXPERIENCE THAT I'VE HAD IN
CONNECTION WITH CASES TRIED SUCH
AS THE STAN MITCHELL CASE IN NEW
YORK, THE CHAPMAN CASE IN
WASHINGTON, THE EHRLICHMAN CASE
NOW GOING ON.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A CLAIM
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT MADE
AVAILABLE APPROPRIATE AND
ADEQUATE BRADY MATERIAL.
BUT, I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S BEFORE
THIS COURT AT THIS TIME, WHAT IS
BEFORE THIS COURT IS A
PROSECUTOR'S DEMAND FOR
EVIDENCE.
AND MAY I DIRECT MY REGARDS FOR
A MOMENT TO THAT PROBLEM.
HE SAYS THAT, IN EFFECT, WE HAVE
NO RIGHT TO BE HERE.
WE HAVE DELEGATED THE WHO, THE
WHEN, AND WITH WHAT ISSUES TO
HIM.
WE HAVE DELEGATED THE WHO AND
THE WHEN.
AND, PURSUANT TO THAT, HE HAS
INDICTED A NUMBER OF PEOPLE AND
HE HAS INDICTED HIM AS SUCH TIME
AS HE THOUGHT APPROPRIATE.
BUT, EVEN HE CONCEDES THAT WE
DID NOT DELEGATE TO HIM WHAT
PRESIDENTIAL CONVERSATIONS WOULD
BE USED AS EVIDENCE.
THAT WAS RESERVED, AND HE
CONCEDES THAT THAT IS THE FACT
AND THAT'S WHAT IS AT ISSUE
HERE.
NOT WHEN AND WHO IS TO IS TO BE
INDICTED, BUT WHAT PRESIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS ARE GOING TO BE
USED AS EVIDENCE?
AND THAT'S WHAT THE ISSUE IS IN
THIS CASE.
>> MR. ST. CLAIR, YOU LEFT ME IN
A LITTLE BIT OF DOUBT ABOUT THIS
MECHANICAL PROBLEM.
I THINK, PERHAPS, WE DIVERTED
YOU FROM IT.
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT ON A
GIVEN TAPE, WHICH IS A REAL TYPE
OF THING HAVING AN HOUR OR MORE
OF MATERIAL AND MAYBE SEVERAL
HOURS OR --
>> TWO OR THREE DAYS.
>> TWO OR THREE DAYS?
I SEE.
THAT THE FIRST THREE HOURS MIGHT
BE THE MATERIAL WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN TRANSCRIBED AND
RELEASED, THE NEXT THREE OR FOUR
HOURS MIGHT BE A CONFERENCE WITH
THE JOINT CHIEF OF STAFF OR THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE ATOMIC ENERGY
COMMISSION ON THE PROGRAM TO
GIVE UNDER DEVELOPED NATIONS,
FOR EXAMPLE AID FOR PEACEFUL
USES OF ATOMIC ENERGY, MATTERS
TOTALLY IRRELEVANT BUT
CONFIDENTIAL.
IS THAT YOUR ARGUMENT?
>> IT'S MY ARGUMENT AND THE
FACT.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE --
>> AND YOU WANT SOME MECHANISM
SET UP SO THAT THESE THINGS CAN
BE SCREENED OUT.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN SCREENED OUT
IN THE TRANSCRIPTS.
WHATEVER HAS BEEN PUBLISHED TO
THE PUBLIC, WE ARE QUITE
PREPARED TO VERIFY THE ACCURACY
OF.
IN THE COURSE OF THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS, THERE ARE FIRST
PORTIONS LEFT OUT.
>> HAVE YOU, AT ANY TIME,
TENDERED OR PROFFERED A
STATEMENT THAT A PARTICULAR TAPE
FROM 18 MINUTES AFTER 11 UNTIL
3:00 THAT AFTERNOON, INCLUDING
THE LUNCH HOUR, INCLUDED A
CONFERENCE WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE, THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE,
AND SOMEONE ELSE HAVING TO DO
WITH TOTALLY UNRELATED MATTERS,
HAS THAT KIND OF A TENDER BEEN
MADE?
>> NO, WE SIMPLY PUBLISHED THE
PORTION OF THAT CONVERSATION
THAT DID NOT RELATE TO THAT WITH
A NOTATION THAT A PORTION HAS
BEEN LEFT OUT.
>> BUT NO EXPLANATION OF WHY
IT'S LEFT OUT.
>> IT WAS LET OUT BECAUSE IT DID
NOT INVOLVE PRESIDENTIAL ACTION
AS IT RELATED TO WATERGATE OR
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT.
WE DID NOT DISCLOSE THE
SUBSTANCE OF THAT LEFT OUT
MATERIAL.
>> IS THERE ANY PARTICULAR
REASON WHY AT LEAST THE IDENTITY
OF THE COQUETRIES COULD NOT BE
MADE --
>> THERE MIGHT WELL BE SUCH A
REASON.
MY PROPER TO MY BROTHER HAS BEEN
THAT WE WILL VERIFY THE ACCURACY
OF THE PRINTED TRANSCRIPT.
SO, THIS 1,240 ODD PAGES OF
PRESIDENTIAL CONVERSATIONS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND
AVAILABLE TO HIM WILL BE USABLE
IN THE TRIAL.
NOW, THIS MAY WELL INVOLVE A
MECHANISM APPROVED BY THE COURT
INVOLVING COUNSEL FOR THE
DEFENDANTS TO BE SATISFIED.
SO, THEY'RE SATISFIED THAT THE
COPY IS ACCURATE.
BUT, THIS ALL HAVE TO BE
EXPURGATED OUT OF A REEL OF TAPE
THAT MAY INVOLVE SEVERAL DAYS'
CONVERSATIONS.
>> BUT IN THE --
>> BUT IT'S ESSENTIALLY A
MECHANICAL PROBLEM.
>> BUT IN THE TAPES THAT THEY
ASK FOR IN THIS SUBPOENA DUCES
TECUM, WHICH IS THE ONLY THING
FOR COURT, HAS ANY EFFORT BEEN
MADE TO SAY WHAT, IF ANY, PART
OF THAT CAN BE PUBLISHED?
>> OTHER THAN THE 20 THAT ARE
ALREADY PUBLISHED, NO EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE AS YET, SIR.
>> WHY NOT?
>> BECAUSE, IF YOUR HONOR
PLEASE, WE HAVEN'T FELT THAT IT
HAS BEEN NECESSARY TO DO SO
BECAUSE WE FIRMLY FEEL --
>> WELL, WHY -- WELL, YOU DON'T
THINK --
>> THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS EVERY
RIGHT TO REFUSE TO DO SO.
>> YOU DON'T THINK THAT A
SUBPOENA DUCES TECUM IS
SUFFICIENT REASON FOR YOU TO
PRY?
>> WELL, WE MOVE TO QUASH IT.
>> YOU JUST IGNORED IT, DIDN'T
YOU?
>> NO, SIR, WE DIDN'T.
WE MOVED TO QUASH IT.
>> YOU FILED A MOTION TO QUASH
IT, DIDN'T YOU?
>> AND WE --
>> AND THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
IGNORING AND FILING A MOTION TO
QUASH IS WHAT?
I WANT HIS ANSWER.
WHAT?
>> WELL, IF YOUR HONOR PLEASE,
WE ARE SUBMITTING THE MATTER --
>> YOU'RE SUBMITTING THE MATTER
TO THIS COURT.
>> TO THIS COURT, UNDER A
SPECIAL APPEARANCE ON BEHALF OF
THE PRESIDENT.
>> YOU STILL LEAVE IT UP TO THIS
COURT TO DECIDE IT.
>> WELL, YES, IN A SENSE.
>> YES?
>> IN A SENSE.
>> WELL, IN WHAT SENSE?
>> IN THE SENSE THAT THIS COURT
HAS AN OBLIGATION TO DETERMINE
THE LAW, ALRIGHT?
THE PRESIDENT ALSO HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO CARRY OUT HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL FUNCTIONS.
>> YOU ARE SUBMITTING TO THIS
COURT FOR US TO DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IS
AVAILABLE IN THIS CASE.
>> WELL, PROBABLY, THE QUESTION
IS EVEN MORE LIMITED THAN THAT.
IS THE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
WHICH MY BROTHER CONCEDES,
ABSOLUTE OR IS IT ONLY
CONDITIONAL?
>> I SAID, IN THIS CASE.
CAN YOU MAKE IT ANY NARROWER
THAN THAT?
>> NO, SIR.
>> WELL, DO YOU AGREE THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S BEFORE THIS COURT
AND YOU ARE SUBMITTING IT TO
THIS COURT FOR DECISION?
>> THIS IS BEING SUBMITTED TO
THIS COURT FOR ITS GUIDANCE AND
JUDGMENT WITH RESPECT TO THE
LAW.
THE PRESIDENT, ON THE OTHER
HAND, HAS HIS OBLIGATIONS UNDER
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> ARE YOU SUBMITTING IT TO THIS
COURT FOR THIS COURT'S DECISION?
>> AS TO WHAT THE LAW IS, YES,
OF COURSE.
>> IF IT WERE NOT SO, YOU WOULD
NOT BE HERE.
>> I WOULD NOT BE HERE.
NOW, MY BROTHER SAYS I HAVE NO
RIGHT TO EVEN CHALLENGE HIS
RIGHT TO BE HERE, AND I'D LIKE
TO DEAL WITH THAT FOR A MOMENT.
THIS IS, AS WE POINT OUT IN OUR
BRIEF, ESSENTIALLY AN EXECUTIVE
DEPARTMENT MATTER.
WHATEVER MAY HAVE BEEN THE
ARRANGEMENTS BETWEEN THE
BRANCHES OF THE EXECUTIVE MATTER
WITH RESPECT TO EVIDENTIARY
MATTERS, AND IN FACT THERE WERE
NO ARRANGEMENTS REGARDING
EVIDENTIARY MATTERS, IT IS NOT
THE FUNCTION OF THE COURT TO
DIRECT OR RULE WHAT EVIDENCE
WILL BE PRESENTED TO IT BY THE
EXECUTIVE AND THAT EXECUTIVES
DULLY PROSECUTE IT.
IF THIS WAS A UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY, THIS CASE WOULDN'T BE
HERE, OF COURSE.
IT'S HERE ONLY BECAUSE CERTAIN
THINGS WERE DELEGATED TO THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
BUT, THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR WAS
NOT DELEGATED THE RIGHT TO TELL
THE PRESIDENT ONE OF HIS
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE AS EVIDENCE.
THAT WAS SPECIFICALLY RESERVED
AND THE ONLY THING THAT MY
BROTHER CAN DO IS ARGUE ABOUT
IT, AND THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING
RIGHT HERE TODAY.
AND, THEREFORE --
>> NOW, WHY WOULDN'T THIS CASE
BE HERE IF THIS WERE A UNITED
STATES ATTORNEY?
I THINK I AGREE WITH YOU, BUT
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU YOUR ANSWER
IN KNOWING WHY.
>> WELL, THE UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY WOULD BE DIRECTED.
>> BY WHOM?
>> BY THE PRESIDENT OR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AT THE
DIRECTION OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> I THOUGHT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WAS THE ONE WHO DIRECTED
THE UNITED STATES ATTORNEY.
>> BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AT
THE DIRECTION OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> NO, IN THE NORMAL CASE, THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT MINE-RUN FEDERAL
PROSECUTIONS.
THAT'S FAIR TO SAY, ISN'T IT?
>> I THINK SO, BUT MOST CASES
DON'T INVOLVE PRESIDENTIAL
CONVERSATIONS.
>> AND, IN FACT, IN MINE-RUN
CASES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
DOESN'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT IT.
>> I THINK THAT'S --
>> BUT LET'S -- JUST A
MOMENT.[LAUGHTER]
>> WITH ALL DUE RESPECT.
>> RIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
SO, THE UNITED STATES ATTORNEY
BRINGS TO PROSECUTION AND IN THE
COURSE OF THAT PROSECUTION HE,
BEFORE TRIAL, SUBPOENAS UNDER
RULE 17 OF THE FEDERAL RULES OF
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
THE JURY SUBPOENAS MATERIAL IN
THE CUSTODY OF THE PRESIDENT.
SO, WHAT HAPPENS?
>> THE PRESIDENT SAYS TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL "I'M NOT GOING
TO PRODUCE THIS MATERIAL."
>> NO, IT'S THE UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY SUBPOENAING IT UNDER
YOUR HYPOTHETICAL CASE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND SO, WHAT HAPPENS?
>> IN MY VIEW, THE PRESIDENT
WOULD INSTRUCT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO INSTRUCT THE UNITED
STATES ATTORNEY TO WITHDRAW HIS
MOTION.
>> AND THE UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY SAYS "I'M NOT GOING TO
DO THAT BECAUSE I'M --
>> THEN WE'D HAVE A NEW UNITED
STATES ATTORNEY.
>> THE ONE WHO UPHOLDS JUSTICE
--
WELL, HOW WOULD YOU HAVE A NEW
UNITED STATES ATTORNEY?
>> WELL, I MADE A LITTLE --
>> NO, I'M BEING SERIOUS BECAUSE
--
>> I THINK THAT UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY, IN ALL RESPECT, WOULD
AND SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM THAT
CASE.
>> I KNOW.
>> THE EXECUTIVE POWER OF THE
GOVERNMENT IS NOT VESTED IN THE
UNITED STATES ATTORNEY.
IT'S VESTED IN ONE MAN, AND THAT
MAN IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> WELL, IT'S SET BY STATUTE.
IT'S VESTED IN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S VESTED IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
>> YES, BUT THAT STATUTE, WHICH
MY BROTHER CITES IN HIS BRIEF --
>> YES?
>> DOES NOT DEPRIVE NOR COULD IT
DEPRIVE THE PRESIDENT OF HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO BE
THE CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER.
HE SHALL TAKE CARE TO SE THAT
THE LAW IS ENFORCED.
THE EXECUTIVE POWER IS VESTED IN
HIM, IN ONE MAN.
AND, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
NOTHING BUT A SURROGATE FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> BUT, I'M AFRAID, YOUR
ARGUMENT WOULD BE -- IS A VERY
GOOD AS A MATTER OF POLITICAL
SCIENCE.
IT WOULD BE A VERY FINE ONE AS A
MATTER OF CONSTITUTIONAL AND
PROBABLY STATUTORY LAW, EXCEPT
IT HASN'T.
YOUR CLIENT DEALT HIMSELF OUT OF
THAT ARGUMENT BY WHAT'S BEEN
DONE IN THE CREATION OF THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
>> PERHAPS AS TO EVERYTHING --
>> YOU'VE JUST POINTED OUT THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR IS QUITE
DIFFERENT FROM THE UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY.
>> RIGHT.
>> AS A MATTER --
>> PERHAPS, WITH RESPECT TO
EVERYTHING EXCEPT, THE PRESIDENT
DID NOT DELEGATE TO THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR THE RIGHT TO TELL HIM
WHETHER OR NOT HIS CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATION SHOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE AS EVIDENCE.
SO THAT, WITHIN THE PACKAGE OF
EXECUTIVE POWER --
>> BUT HE HAS --
>> NORMALLY REPRESENTED --
>> EXCUSE ME.
>> NORMALLY REPRESENTED BY THE
EXECUTIVE DEPARTMENT AS TO WHO
SHALL BE PROSECUTOR THAT'S BEEN
DELEGATED TO THIS GENTLEMAN.
HE HAS EXERCISED THAT POWER.
WHEN, HE'S DONE THAT.
WITH WHAT EVIDENCE, HE'S DONE
THAT AS WE'LL DEAL WITH IN A FEW
MOMENTS.
BUT, NOT WITH THAT PORTION OF
THE EVIDENCE THAT'S AVAILABLE
THAT CONSTITUTES PRESIDENTIAL
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION.
THAT'S BEEN SPECIFICALLY
RESERVED.
AND THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
CANNOT, AND EVEN IF THE
PRESIDENT DID GIVE HIM THAT
AUTHORITY, PROBABLY COULD NOT,
AS A CONSTITUTIONAL MATTER,
DELEGATE THAT.
BUT IN ANY EVENT, HE DID NOT --
>> HE DIDN'T WHAT?
HE COULD NOT AND PROBABLY COULD
NOT --
>> THE RIGHT TO ORDER THE
PRESIDENT TO GIVE UP
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS.
THAT WAS NOT DELEGATED.
>> I KNOW, NOT THE UNFETTERED
RIGHT TO GET IT BUT THE RIGHT TO
GO TO COURT AND ASK A COURT TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT HE'S
ENTITLED TO IT.
>> RIGHT, AND THE PRESIDENT,
UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES, GAVE UP
ANY OF HIS DEFENSES WITH RESPECT
TO THAT.
>> YOU'RE MAKING THOSE DEFENSES
IN --
>> AND I'M MAKING THEM RIGHT
NOW.
AND EVEN IF WE DID AGREE BETWEEN
US THAT WE WOULD VEST THIS COURT
WITH JURISDICTION SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF THE POLITICS OF THE
SITUATION, THIS COURT IN ITS
DECISIONS WOULD NOT ACCEPT THE
VESTING OF SUCH JURISDICTION.
>> WHY NOT?
>> BECAUSE THIS COURT DETERMINES
ITS JURISDICTION.
>> WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> THE PARTIES CAN AGREE THAT IT
HASN'T BUT-
>> YES, BUT -- AND IF SURELY
YOU'RE RIGHT, AS I SAY, A
LAWSUIT BETWEEN THE SECRETARY OF
COMMERCE, FOR EXAMPLE, SUING THE
PRESIDENT OVER A MATTER OF
EXECUTIVE POLICY, WE BOTH AGREE,
WOULD BE UNTHINKABLE.
AND SINCE ANY CABINET OFFICER IS
THE CREATURE OF THE PRESIDENT
WHO APPOINTED HIM, THE ANSWER
WOULD BE "YOU'RE FIRED," IF YOU
WANT TO --
>> IF IT GOES THAT FAR.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> BUT AREN'T WE HERE BOTH
FACTUALLY AND, I SUGGEST,
LEGALLY WITH QUITE A DIFFERENT
SITUATION?
>> I THINK NOT IN THE TERMS OF
SEPARATION OF POWERS, IF I MAY.
MY BROTHER'S POINT OF VIEW IS,
HE VIEWS HIMSELF AS THE UNITED
STATES AS DISTINGUISHED FROM A
MEMBER OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
AND, IN HIS BRIEF, HE INVOKES
THE UNITED STATES IS REALLY A
FOURTH ENTITY.
>> WELL, THE SOVEREIGN PEOPLE OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> CONSTITUTIONALLY, A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR WITH THE POWERS THAT
MY BROTHER SUGGESTS HE HAS IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL ANOMALY.
WE HAVE ONLY THREE BRANCHES, NOT
THREE-AND-A THIRD OR THREE-AND-A
HALF OR FOUR.
THERE'S ONLY ONE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AND THE EXECUTIVE POWER
IS VESTED IN A PRESIDENT.
NOW IF, FOR POLITICAL REASONS,
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO DOLE OUT
SOME OF THOSE POWERS, HE MAY SO
DO AND HAS DONE IN THIS CASE.
BUT, HE CANNOT VEST JURISDICTION
ON A COURT THAT, OTHERWISE, THE
COURT WOULD NOT HAVE NOR SHOULD
THE COURT ACCEPT JURISDICTION.
>> BUT HASN'T YOUR CLIENT ALSO
INHIBITED HIMSELF FROM THE
ULTIMATE SANCTION THAT YOU
SUGGESTED HE COULD IMPOSE WITH
RESPECT TO YOUR HYPOTHETICAL
UNITED STATES ATTORNEY, I.E. THE
SANCTION OF DISMISSING THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
>> AND AS A MATTER OF LAW,
REGULATIONS THAT HAVE THE FORCE
OF LAW.
>> THAT IS CORRECT, AND HE HAS
NOT BEEN DISMISSED.
>> AND UNTIL OR UNLESS HE IS --
>> NOR IS HE LIKELY TO BE
DISMISSED.
>> WE HAVE A CASE OF CONTROVERSY
OF A VERY REAL KIND.
>> THE POINT IS, IF I MAY MAKE
IT, THE ONLY ISSUE HERE IS
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT GAVE UP
HIS RIGHT TO PROTECT THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF HIS
CONVERSATIONS.
>> CERTAINLY, HE HASN'T.
>> NO CLAIM IS MADE THAT HE DID.
>> YOU'RE A LIVING TESTIMONY OF
THE FACT THAT HE DID NOT GIVE UP
HIS RIGHT TO DEFEND HIS POSITION
IN COURT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> AND MY BROTHER
CONCEDES.
>> THE VERY FACT THAT THE
DELEGATION TO MR. JAWORSKI GAVE
HIM THE RIGHT TO CONTEST THE
PRESIDENT'S CLAIM OF PRIVILEGE
PRESUPPOSES THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAD A RIGHT TO ASSERT THE
PRIVILEGE BUT NOT THE RIGHT TO
ASSERT IT NECESSARILY WITH
COMPLETE FINALITY.
>> THAT'S --
>> THAT'S THE --
>> THAT'S WHAT WE --
>> THAT'S WHAT WE'RE REALLY
ARGUING ABOUT HERE TODAY, ISN'T?
NOW --
>> IF WE GET BEYOND THE SUBJECT
MATTER SITUATION.
NOW, IF THIS WERE THE NIXON
AGAINST SIRICA CASE WHERE YOU
DIDN'T HAVE WHAT I THINK IS A
DISPOSITIVE PROBLEM IN THIS
CASE, NAMELY, THE LACK OF
JURISDICTION IN THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH TO DETERMINE THIS
INTRA-EXECUTIVE BRANCH IF WE HAD
A GRAND JURY SUBPOENA, AS WAS
TRUE IN THE NIXON AGAINST SIRICA
CASE.
THEN, YOU HAVE INTRA-BRANCH AND
THE COURT WOULD HAVE A BETTER
STANDING IN ITS RESPONSIBILITY
TO SEE THE GRAND JURIES WHICH
ARE UNDER ITS JURISDICTION TO
HAVE SUCH EVIDENCE AS THEY
THOUGHT APPROPRIATE.
BUT, WE'RE WELL BEYOND THAT
STAGE.
17C REQUIRES A GREAT, MUCH MORE
RESTRICTED FORM OF EVIDENCE
THAT'S GOT TO BE RELEVANT AND
ADMISSIBLE.
IT'S NOTHING LIKE A GRAND JURY
SUBPOENA.
>> MR. ST. CLAIR.
>> YES, SIR.
>> WITH REFERENCE TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT WHETHER THERE ARE THREE
BRANCHES OR THREE-AND-SOME
FRACTION, IS NOT THE CONTROLLER
GENERAL SOMETHING OF AN
AUTONOMOUS FRACTIONAL MORE THAN
A THIRD BRANCH FIGURE?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THAT THE
CONTROLLER GENERAL --
>> HE'S A CREATURE --
>> REPRESENTS, IF YOUR HONOR
PLEASE, THAT BASIC
CONSTITUTIONAL STRUCTURE HAS
BEEN CHANGED.
IT MAY BE THAT HE HAS EXECUTIVE
--
>> BUT HE MAY PROCEED BUT NOT --
>> AND HE MAY HAVE LEGISLATIVE
FUNCTIONS.
>> HE MAY PROCEED WITH REFERENCE
TO THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND, I
WOULD ASSUME, WITH REFERENCE TO
EXPENDITURES OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH AND WITHOUT CONSULTING
EITHER ONE OF THEM.
IS THAT NOT IT?
>> I UNDERSTAND.
HE IS CREATED BY A LEGISLATIVE,
VERY MUCH LIKE A
SEMI-INDEPENDENT AGENCY.
IN ONE ASPECT, HE'S AN AGENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE.
IN THE OTHER ASPECT, HE'S AN
AGENT OF THE EXECUTIVE.
BUT, WE DON'T HAVE ANY MORE THAN
LEGISLATIVE, JUDICIAL, AND
EXECUTIVE BRANCHES.
>> MR. JAWORSKI, AS I UNDERSTAND
IT, IS CLAIMING THAT HE'S
SOMEWHAT LIKE, NOT NECESSARILY
PRECISELY LIKE BUT SOMEWHAT LIKE
THE CONTROLLER GENERAL.
THAT, HE MAY MAKE DECISIONS AND
THAT CONGRESS CANNOT RECALL HIM
SHORT AS, I BELIEVE, A 15-YEAR
TERM FOR THE CONTROLLER GENERAL
AND NO PRESIDENT CAN FIRE THE
CONTROLLER GENERAL.
AND, I SUPPOSE, THE COURT COULD
NOT FIRE HIM.
>> WELL, I'M SURE THE COURT
COULDN'T.
I'M NOT TOO CLEAR ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT UNDER THE MYERS CASE.
I REALLY HAVEN'T THOUGHT THAT
MUCH OF IT.
IT COULD BE THAT HE COULD BE
FIRED, BUT I THINK THAT'S REALLY
SOMEWHAT BESIDE THE POINT
BECAUSE THIS ISSUE REALLY TURNS
ON AN ADMISSION THAT, AS TO THE
ELEMENT OF THE EXECUTIVE POWER
HERE INVOLVED, NAMELY,
PRESIDENTIAL CONVERSATIONS, THEY
WEREN'T DELEGATED.
SO, WHATEVER ELSE MAY HAVE BEEN
DELEGATED, THOSE WERE NOT.
AND, THIS COURT HAS NO
JURISDICTION TO RESOLVE A
DISPUTE AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THEY SHOULD BE GIVEN UP BECAUSE
THAT WOULD INVOLVE THIS COURT IN
THE PROSECUTION OF THE CASE AND
THE JUDICIAL --
>> CAN THIS COURT DECIDE WHAT'S
NECESSARY FOR TRIAL OF A
CRIMINAL CASE?
>> IT CAN, SIR, WITH RESPECT TO
THIRD PARTIES BUT IT SHOULD NOT
INVOLVE ITSELF WITH THE
EXECUTIVE FUNCTION OF
PROSECUTING THE CASE.
>> MY ONLY QUESTION WAS IF THIS
IS A SUBPOENA DUCES TECUM THAT
WAS ISSUED BY A JUDGE, RIGHT?
>> YES, SIR.
>> SLIGHTLY JUDICIAL.
>> ENTIRELY JUDICIAL.
>> AND THAT'S WHAT'S BEFORE US.
>> AND, THAT, WE MOVE TO QUASH
AS WE --
>> BUT THAT'S WHAT'S BEFORE US.
>> THE DENIAL OF OUR MOTION TO
QUASH IS ONE OF THE ISSUES
BEFORE US.
THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THE ONLY THING BEFORE US IS
WHETHER OR NOT THE SUBPOENA IS
AT ISSUE.
>> I GUESS IT'S ABOUT THE SAME
THING AS WHETHER OR NOT IT
SHOULD BE QUASHED AND I THINK --
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THAT AMOUNTS TO THE SAME
THING.
>> SO, THAT'S NOT POLITICAL.
>> WELL IT IS NOT, IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE PROCEEDINGS HERE
BUT, IN THE CONTEXT OF WHETHER
IT'S IN FACT INVOLVED IN THIS
CASE, IT IS, I SUGGEST,
POLITICAL IN THE SENSE THAT THIS
INFORMATION BEING SOUGHT
ADMITTEDLY WILL BECOME AVAILABLE
THEN TO THE HOUSE.
>> WE MEAN POLITICAL -- WELL, I
DON'T SEE WHETHER HOUSE HAS GOT
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE COURT
THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
YOU SAID IT'S A POLITICAL AND
NOT JUDICIAL.
AND, I SUBMIT IT COULD BE
JUDICIAL BECAUSE IT INVOLVES THE
ISSUE OF SUBPOENA.
>> WELL THE QUESTION IS, IS IT A
PROPER ISSUE OF A SUBPOENA.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> JUDGES MAKE MISTAKES, AS DO
LAWYERS, AND MAYBE EVEN
PRESIDENTS, FOR ALL I KNOW, BUT
THE POINT I WANT TO MAKE WITH
YOU, SIR, IS THAT THIS IS AN
EXECUTIVE FUNCTION, AN EXECUTIVE
DECISION, ONE NOT DELEGATED --
>> WELL THE EXECUTIVE FUNCTION
IS, AS I UNDERSTATED, THE
DISCUSSION AS TO WHETHER HE
SHOULD VOLUNTARILY TURN OVER TO
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
WE HAVE PASSED THAT STAGE.
WE ARE NOW AT THE STAGE WHERE
THE PROSECUTOR HAS ASKED THE
COURT TO ASSIST HIM AND THE
COURT HAS ASSISTED HIM.
DOES THAT NOT TAKE IT A STEP
BEYOND PURE POLITICAL OR
EXECUTIVE?
>> WE SUBMIT THAT THE COURT
IMPROPERLY ASSISTED HIM, THAT
THE COURT HAS NO RIGHT TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE EXECUTIVE
WILL OFFER IN EVIDENCE.
>> I GET THAT.
I SEE.
>> AND, THIS IS THE FUNCTION OF
THE PRESIDENT.
NO ONE HAS CONTENDED THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN UP HIS
EXECUTIVE RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER
THE CONSTITUTION AND, CERTAINLY,
THE PROSECUTION OF CRIMINAL
CASES IS AN EXECUTIVE FUNCTION.
>> AND THAT'S ACTUALLY -- NOW,
YOU'RE ARGUING ABSOLUTE
PRIVILEGE.
>> YES, SIR.
>> ABSOLUTE EXECUTIVE EVEN
THOUGH EVERYDAY IT'S SO YOU
LOOSE ANOTHER ONE.
>> I BEG YOUR PARDON?
>> YOU TURN THINGS LOOSE
EVERYDAY, I SUPPOSE.
>> NO, WE DON'T TURN THEM LOOSE
EVERYDAY BUT WE HAVE TURNED A
NUMBER LOOSE IN THE PRESIDENT'S
DISCRETION IN WHICH HE THOUGHT
WAS AN APPROPRIATE THING TO DO,
AND THAT'S HIS DETERMINATION
THAT GOVERNS, WE SUGGEST.
>> IS HE GETTING READY TO TURN
20 MORE CASE LOOSE.
>> NO, THIS WOULD BE
REPETITIOUS, YOUR HONOR.
WHEN, ALREADY, IT HAS BEEN MADE
PUBLIC.
>> WELL, I THOUGHT YOU SAID IN
YOUR BRIEF YOU WOULD TURN 20
LOOSE?
>> THOSE 20 -- THOSE WOULD BE
THE TAPES OF 20 CONVERSATIONS
ALREADY MADE PUBLIC.
>> YOU RELEASED THOSE TAPES?
>> WE'LL PROVIDE A MEANS WHEREBY
THEIR ACCURACY CAN BE VERIFIED.
>> THAT'S --
>> TO RELEASE A WHOLE REEL OF
TAPE INVOLVING A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS POSES A MECHANICAL
PROBLEM.
>> YOU STILL SAYING THE ABSOLUTE
PRIVILEGE TO DECIDE WHAT SHALL
BE RELEASED AND WHAT SHALL NOT
BE RELEASED IS VESTED IN ONE
PERSON AND NOBODY CAN QUESTION
IT.
>> IN SO FAR AS IT RELATES TO
THE PRESIDENTIAL CONVERSATION
THAT IS CORRECT, SIR.
>> BUT YOU'RE NOW DEALING, AS I
UNDERSTAND --
>> THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE.
>> MR. ST. CLAIR WITH THE
JURISDICTIONAL QUESTION AND, AS
I FURTHER UNDERSTAND IT, THAT
THAT ARGUMENT OF YOURS, AT LEAST
I GOT IT FROM THE BRIEF,
INVOLVES AT LEAST TWO SEPARATE
CONCEPTS AND MAYBE THREE.
ONE IS THAT THIS IS AN
INTRA-BRANCH DISPUTE, AND THAT
ARGUMENT WOULD BE FULLY VALID
UNDER THE ANALOGY YOU USE IN
YOUR BRIEF.
IF THIS WERE A DISPUTE BETWEEN,
LET'S SAY, TWO COMMITTEES IN ONE
OF THE HOUSES OF THE CONGRESS
AND ONE COMMITTEE SUED THE OTHER
FOR JURISDICTION OF A PARTICULAR
MATTER, YOU SUGGEST AND PROBABLY
QUITE CORRECTLY, THAT THAT WOULD
NOT BE A MATTER FOR THE
JUDICIARY TO DETERMINE.
THAT'S ONE ARGUMENT.
THAT THIS IS PURELY AN
INTRA-EXECUTIVE BRANCH
CONTROVERSY, AS IT WOULD BE
BETWEEN TWO CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES.
THIS IS INTRA-ARTICLE 2 BRANCH.
THE HYPOTHETICAL CASE WOULD BE
INTRA-ARTICLE 1 BRANCH.
AND THEN, YOU HAVE QUITE A
SEPARATE ARGUMENT, IT SEEMS TO
ME, I.E. THAT THE PRESIDENT
CONSTITUTIONALLY IS THE CHIEF
PROSECUTOR SINCE HE IS THE
EXECUTIVE.
AND, IT IS NOT FOR THE COURTS TO
DECIDE WHAT A PROSECUTOR SHALL
USE IN PROSECUTING A CRIMINAL
CASE.
NOW, ISN'T THAT -- AREN'T THOSE
TWO SEPARATE ARGUMENTS?
YOU MAKE BOTH OF THEM UNDER THIS
RULE BRICK.
-- RUBRIC.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR.
I DON'T KNOW HOW SEPARATE THEY
ARE BUT I'LL CERTAINLY MAKE USE
OF BOTH OF THEM.
>> WELL, IT SEEMS TO ME THEY'RE
QUITE SEPARATE.
>> BUT I'M MAKING BOTH OF THEM
AND IF THEY'RE SEPARATE, FINE.
NOW, WITH RESPECT TO --
>> WELL, THE SECOND ARGUMENT
WILL HAVE NO RELEVANCE AT ALL TO
YOUR ANALOGY OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH.
>> WELL, I DON'T WANT TO MISLEAD
THE COURT INTO THINKING THAT I
BELIEVE MR. JAWORSKI HAS NO
RIGHT TO DETERMINE ANY EVIDENCE
THAT HE COMMUNES.
>> BUT ULTIMATELY, YOU TELL US
THAT, CONSTITUTIONALLY, THE
PRESIDENT AS CHIEF EXECUTIVE
AND, THEREFORE, AS
CONSTITUTIONALLY THE CHIEF
PROSECUTOR OR WHATEVER THE
STATUTES MIGHT PROVIDE --
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> HAS UNRESTRICTED DISCRETION
TO DETERMINE WHAT EVIDENCE HE
WILL OR WILL NOT USE IN
PROSECUTING A CASE.
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
>> WHICH IS QUITE A DIFFERENT
CONCEPT FROM THE OTHER CONCEPT.
YOU MAKE THEM BOTH UNDER THE
SAME RULE BRICK, AS I SAY.
BUT I -- IT SEEMS TO ME, THEY'RE
QUITE SEPARATE ARGUMENTS.
>> AND I THINK THEY'RE
WELL-FOUNDED IN THE LAW.
>> I KNOW YOU DO OR YOU WOULDN'T
MAKE THEM.
>> NOW I'D LIKE TO MOVE, IF I
MAY, TO BRIEFLY -- THE
SUGGESTION THAT THE ISSUE HERE
IS NON-JUSTICIABLE ON THE
GROUNDS OTHER THAN I'VE ALREADY
MENTIONED, NAMELY, THE CONTEXT
IN WHICH THIS CASE UNFORTUNATELY
FINDS ITSELF.
IT SEEMS TO US, BRIEFLY, THAT
THE CASE IS NON-JUSTICIABLE FOR
SOMEWHAT MORE TECHNICAL REASONS.
FIRST, THIS IS AN ISSUE WHERE IF
SOMEONE HAS TO EXERCISE SOME
DISCRETION, THERE ARE NO REAL
BOUNDS OR STANDARDS BY WHICH
THAT DISCRETION SHOULD BE
EXERCISED.
AND, BY TRADITIONAL STANDARDS OF
THIS COURT WHERE THAT EXISTS,
THEN THIS COURT OUGHT NOT TO
TAKE THE CASE.
SECONDLY, IT SEEMS TO ME, THERE
IS A TEXTUAL CONSTITUTIONAL
GRANT IF WE ASSUME THAT THE
GRANT OF EXECUTIVE POWER
INCLUDES THE MEANS BY WHICH THAT
CAN BE EFFECTIVELY EXERCISED,
SECOND GROUND.
THIRD, OF COURSE, THERE IS THE
POLITICAL INVOLVEMENT WHICH I
HAVE SUGGESTED.
THEREFORE, I SUGGEST QUITE
BRIEFLY THAT EVEN IF THERE IS
SUBJECT MATTER JURISDICTION, THE
CASE IS NON-JUSTICIABLE FOR
THESE ADDITIONAL REASONS.
THE STANDARDS OF BAKER AND CARR,
AND POWELL ARE NOT APPLICABLE
HERE.
THERE ARE NO INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHTS
OVER BEING PROTECTED AGAINST THE
ONSLAUGHT OF GOVERNMENT.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT HERE AS AN
INDIVIDUAL.
HE IS HERE AS A CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICER AND WHOM THE EXECUTIVE
POWERS RESTED.
THERE IS NO PHILOSOPHY THAT
WOULD SUPPORT A FINDING OF
JUSTICIABILITY ON THE GROUNDS
THAT WERE STRENGTHENING THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS, AS WAS TRUE
IN POWELL AND ALSO INTO A
GREATER EXTENT IN BAKER AND
CARR.
IF ANYTHING, A DECISION IN THIS
CASE AGAINST THE PRESIDENT WOULD
TEND TO DIMINISH THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS.
THIS PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED ON
THE THEORY THAT HE WOULD HAVE
ALL THE POWERS, DUTIES, AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT.
AND IF IT'S DETERMINED THAT HE
DOESN'T, THERE IS A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF DIMINUTION OF THE
POLITICAL ASPECT OF THE CASE IN
SO FAR AS THE CONSTITUENTS WHO
VOTED FOR HIM ARE CONCERNED.
THIS PRESIDENT OUGHT NOT TO HAVE
ANY LESS POWERS THAN ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT OUGHT TO HAVE.
ONE OF THE NECESSARY RESULTS, AS
I VIEW IT AND MY BROTHER'S
ARGUMENT, IS THAT BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THIS CASE
RICHARD NIXON IS, LET'S SAY, AN
85% PRESIDENT NOT 100%
PRESIDENT.
AND, THAT CAN'T BE
CONSTITUTIONAL.
THE FRAMERS OF THE CONSTITUTION
HAD IN MIND A STRONG PRESIDENCY.
AS WE KNOW, THEY CONSIDERED A
NUMBER OF ALTERNATIVES, MAYBE A
PRESIDENCY CONSISTING OF THREE
MEMBERS.
ALL OF THOSE SUGGESTIONS WERE
DISCARDED AND A STRONG
PRESIDENCY WAS DECIDED UPON, MAY
I SAY, TO THE DISTINCT ADVANTAGE
OF THIS COUNTRY AS HISTORY HAS
DEVELOPED.
NOW BY REASON OF AN ACTION OF A
GRAND JURY, THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR SUGGESTS THAT THIS
PRESIDENT HAS SOMETHING LESS
THAN ANY OTHER PRESIDENT WOULD
HAVE.
I WOULD ONLY CALL YOUR ATTENTION
TO THE ACTION OF THE FRAMERS IN
CONSTITUTIONAL CONVENTION WHEN
THE ISSUE WAS RAISED AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT A PRESIDENT WHO
WAS UNDER IMPEACHMENT SHOULD BE
SUSPENDED DURING THE PENDENCY OF
THE IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
AND, THE DECISION WAS DEFINITELY
HE SHOULD NOT BECAUSE THE
FRAMERS ENVISIONED A STRONG
ACTIVE PRESIDENT EVEN IN THE
COURSE OF IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
THEY DID NOT WANT THIS COUNTRY
TO BE LED BY SOMEONE WHO DIDN'T
HAVE THOSE FULL POWERS EVEN IF
HE WAS THEN UNDER IMPEACHMENT.
AND, INDEED, THIS PRESIDENT
CONTINUES TO FUNCTION AS
PRESIDENT AS HE SHOULD EVEN
THOUGH THERE ARE IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRIES UNDERWAY.
>> MR. ST. CLAIR, IF I MAY
INTERRUPT YOU AGAIN.
IS THIS -- IS WHAT YOU'RE
TELLING US NOW DIRECTED TO YOUR
POINT THAT THIS IS A
NON-JUSTICIABLE POLITICAL
QUESTION OR IS IT DIRECTED TO
YOUR POINT THAT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IS ABSOLUTE AND THAT
THE DETERMINATION OF IT IS TO BE
MADE PUBLIC?
>> I THINK IT INVOLVES BOTH.
IT'S NON-JUSTICIABLE, IF I MAY,
BECAUSE IT DOES INVOLVE THE
COURT IN A POLITICAL MATTER.
NOW, MERE FACT THAT POLITICS IS
INVOLVE, OF COURSE, HAS NOT
PREVENTED THE COURT FROM TAKING
ACTION IN APPROPRIATE CASES
WHERE INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS WERE
INVOLVED OR WHERE THE FRANCHISE
OF VOTERS COULD BE STRENGTHENED
BY THE DECISION OF THE COURT.
I'M SUGGESTING, IN THIS CASE,
THE CONVERSE IS TRUE.
THEREFORE, THE JUSTIFICATION
BETWEEN BAKER AND CARR AND IN
THE POWELL CASE IS NOT AVAILABLE
OR IS NOT APPLICABLE HERE.
FURTHERMORE, HOWEVER, THE
ARGUMENT STILL, IN MY VIEW, HAS
FORCE WITH RESPECT TO THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE GRAND JURY
ACTION IN NAMING HIM AS A
CO-CONSPIRATOR WHICH WE SUGGEST
THEY WERE NOT QUALIFIED TO DO.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT ABOVE THE
LAW BY ANY MEANS.
BUT THE LAW, AS TO THE
PRESIDENT, HAS TO BE APPLIED IN
A CONSTITUTIONAL WAY WHICH IS
DIFFERENT THAN ANYONE ELSE.
NAMELY, WE SUGGEST THAT HE CAN
ONLY BE IMPEACHED WHILE IN
OFFICE AND CANNOT BE INDICTED
UNTIL SUCH TIME AS HE NO LONGER
IS IN OFFICE.
>> WELL, LET'S ASSUME WE ACCEPT
THAT PROPOSITION.
WHAT FOLLOWS FROM IT?
>> WELL THEN THE NAMING OF THE
PRESIDENT BY A GRAND JURY AS A
CO-CONSPIRATOR, IF THAT HAS THE
EFFECT OF DIMINISHING THE
PRESIDENT'S RIGHTS, IT'S A PRO
TANTO, IF I MAY SAY SO,
IMPEACHMENT.
>> I SHOULD THINK YOU COULD RUN
THE ARGUMENT THE OTHER WAY
SAYING THAT SINCE THE PRESIDENT
CANNOT BE INDICTED THEN ALL THAT
CAN HAPPEN TO HIM IS THAT HE CAN
BE NAMED AS AN UNINDICTED
CO-CONSPIRATOR.
>> THAT COULD BE SAID BUT BY THE
NAMING HIM OF AN UNINDICTED
CO-CONSPIRATOR, WE SUGGEST, IS
AN INTRUSION BY THE GRAND JURY
ON A FUNCTION THAT IS SOLELY
LEGISLATIVE AND NOT JUDICIAL.
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT OR ANY
PRESIDENT COULD BE SUED FOR BACK
TAXES, PENALTIES, OR WHAT NOT?
>> WELL IN QUESTIONS OF
IMMUNITY, I THINK, INDIVIDUALLY
HE COULD BE --
>> BUT IT SPEAKS OF PERSONS, ANY
PERSONS?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT COULD BE
SUED FOR BACK TAXES IN HIS
INDIVIDUAL CAPACITY.
BUT IN TERMS OF HIS POWER TO
AFFECT THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
HIS OFFICE TO PROTECT THE
PRESIDENCY FROM UNWARRANTED
INTRUSIONS INTO THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF HIS
COMMUNICATIONS, THAT'S NOT A
PERSONAL MATTER.
>> IT MAY BE IF ONE OF THESE
DEFENDANTS MIGHT BE EXONERATED
FROM SOMETHING IN ONE OF THOSE
CASES.
>> AS I HAD SUGGESTED, THAT IF
THAT DEFENDANT WILL SATISFY A
COURT THAT THERE IS SUCH A TAPE
AND WILL IDENTIFY OR EVEN COME
CLOSE TO IT AND PERSUADE THE
COURT THAT THAT WOULD EXONERATE
HIM OR THERE'S REASON TO BELIEVE
IT MIGHT, I DON'T BELIEVE WILL
HAVE A QUESTION.
BUT, THAT'S NOT WHAT MY BROTHER
HERE IS ASKING FOR.
HE'S ASKING FOR A SET NUMBER OF
TAPES, NOT FOR BRADY PURPOSES.
ALTHOUGH HE THROWS THAT IN, BUT
HE REALLY WANTS THEM, HE SAYS,
FOR PROSECUTION AND I'D LIKE TO
REVIEW WITH THE COURT THE
QUESTION OF THE NECESSITY SHOWN
FOR THIS BECAUSE, EVEN ON HIS
THEORY OF A QUALIFIED PRIVILEGE,
THERE HAS TO BE A SHOWING OF
SOME NECESSITY.
NOW WE SHOULD UNDERSTAND, I'M
SURE THE COURT KNOWS, THAT ALL
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS HERE
INVOLVED HAVE TESTIFIED BEFORE
THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE WITH
THE EXCEPTION, I BELIEVE OF MR.
COLSON WHO NOW HAS PLEAD GUILTY
UNDER A PLEA BARGAIN WHERE HE'S
AGREED TO COOPERATE SO THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HAS THE FULL
BENEFIT OF HIS TESTIMONY.
THEY HAVE TESTIFIED ON ONE OR
MORE OCCASIONS BEFORE A GRAND
JURY.
IN ADDITION, THE PRESIDENT HAS
FURNISHED TO THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR THE TRANSCRIPTS AND
TAPES OF THE CRITICAL
CONVERSATIONS INVOLVED IN THIS
ALLEGED CONSPIRACY.
I MIGHT REVEAL THOSE VERY
BRIEFLY WITH YOU.
MR. DEAN IN HIS SENATE COMMITTEE
TESTIMONY SUGGESTED THAT ON
SEPTEMBER 15 THE PRESIDENT
ACKNOWLEDGED KNOWLEDGE OF A
COVER UP.
HE CHANGED THAT LATER TO A
TESTIMONY THAT HE BELIEVED THAT
WAS SO OR IT WAS INFERENCE.
BUT IN ANY EVENT, THE PRESIDENT
FURNISHED THAT PORTION OF THAT
TAPE OF THE CONVERSATION WITH
MR. DEAN.
MR. DEAN ALSO TESTIFIED THAT ON
MARCH 13, 1973, HE DISCUSSED THE
COVER UP WITH THE PRESIDENT IN
EFFORTS TO BLACKMAIL THE
PRESIDENT BY ONE OF THE
DEFENDANTS WHO BROKE INTO THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
HEADQUARTERS.
LATER DEVELOPED THAT THAT WAS
MISTAKEN AND IT WAS ACTUALLY ON
MARCH 21 AND THE GRAND JURY
INDICTMENT PROCEEDS ON THE
THEORY OF MARCH 21.
THE TAPE OF THE CONVERSATION OF
MARCH 13 WAS FURNISHED.
ALL OF THE CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
THE PRINCIPALS BEING TWO IN
NUMBER ON MARCH 21 WERE
FURNISHED.
THE CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE
INDIVIDUALS AND THE PRESIDENTS
ON THE NEXT DAY IN THE
AFTERNOON, MARCH 22, WAS
FURNISHED.
AND, A LARGE NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS WERE
FURNISHED.
NOW IF REYNOLDS MEANS ANYTHING
AND REYNOLDS, IN ADDITION TO THE
KAISER ALUMINUM CASE, NOTED A
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION, AS I
THINK ONE OF THE LATER JUSTICES
SUGGESTED, ONE OF THE REASONS
FOR NOT FACING THAT ISSUE IN
THAT CASE WAS IT WAS NOT
NECESSARY BECAUSE IN THE CASE IT
WAS A CRASH OF A BOMBER THAT WAS
ON A SECRET MISSION AND THE
COURT SAID THAT THE PARTIES HAD
THE TESTIMONY OF THE WITNESSES,
THE SURVIVORS, AND OTHER
TESTIMONY SO IT WASN'T NECESSARY
TO GET TO THE CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTION.
I SUGGEST THAT THAT'S TRUE HERE.
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
CONCEIVE A PROSECUTOR WHO HAS
MORE EVIDENCE THAN THIS
PROSECUTOR HAS.
HE HAS THE FULL BENEFIT OF A
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATION WHICH STAFF HAD 50
ODD LAWYERS, EXISTED FOR A YEAR.
HE HAS THE BENEFIT OF HIS OWN
INVESTIGATION OF A GRAND JURY
THAT SAT FOR 19 MONTHS WITH AN
INVESTIGATIVE STAFF OF SIMILAR
PROPORTIONS.
HE SIMPLY SAYS, "I NEED THIS
BECAUSE I WANT TO PRESENT ALL OF
THE EVIDENCE IN THE CASE."
HE DOES NOT SAY --
>> MR. ST. CLAIR, DO YOU SUGGEST
THEN THAT EVEN IF THE PROSECUTOR
COULD GET THIS FROM A NORMAL
THIRD PARTY WITNESS, HE CAN'T
GET IT FROM THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
THAT THERE MUST BE A FURTHER
SHOWING BEYOND THE RELEVANCE
SHOWING 17C?
>> WELL, AS WE POINTED OUT IN
OUR BRIEF, A TAPE OF A
CONVERSATION IS VERY RAW
MATERIAL.
>> WELL YOUR ANSWER IS YES,
ISN'T IT, THAT THERE IS A
FURTHER SHOWING NECESSARY?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
DOES HE REALLY NEED THIS?
WHAT DOES HE SAY HE NEEDS IT
FOR?
HE SAYS --
>> BUT HOW DOES A DISTRICT COURT
GO ABOUT TO DECIDE A QUESTION
LIKE THAT IN ADVANCE OF TRIAL
WITHOUT IT UNLESS THE PROSECUTOR
LAYS OUT HIS ENTIRE EVIDENCE AND
SAYS, "IT'S MY JUDGMENT THAT
THIS IS EVIDENCE.
WITHOUT THIS EVIDENCE, I MIGHT
LOSE THE CASE."
>> HE DOESN'T SAY THAT.
HE MADE A SHOWING TO THE COURT
BELOW.
THE SHOWING IS AVAILABLE TO YOU
HERE.
>> BUT YOU WOULD SUGGEST THAT HE
WOULD HAVE TO DO THAT.
>> HE HAS THE BURDEN.
HE HAS THE BURDEN UNDER
REYNOLDS, UNDER KAISER ALUMINUM,
AND SO FORTH.
THE SHOW THAT HE NEEDS AND WHAT
DOES HE SAYS HE NEEDS IT FOR.
HE DOESN'T SAY HE NEEDS IT TO
OBTAIN CONVICTION.
>> I MUST SAY THAT WHILE I'VE
GOT YOU INTERRUPTED, I WANT TO
ASK YOU SOMETHING ELSE.
>> YES, SIR.
>> AND IT'S RELATED TO THIS.
NO MATTER HOW ABSOLUTE THE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IS THAT YOU
CLAIM ON BEHALF OF THE
PRESIDENT, I ASSUME YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT CONVERSATIONS TO
WHICH THE PRIVILEGE WOULD APPLY.
>> YES.
>> NOW, IS IT --
>> WE HAVE TO MAKE SUCH A
SHOWING AND I SAY THAT'S OUR
ONLY BURDEN.
>> YOU WOULDN'T SUGGEST THAT
EVERY CONVERSATION THE PRESIDENT
HAD WHILE HE WAS IN OFFICE WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
>> NO, IT WOULD HAVE TO BE A
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION.
>> WELL, IT HAS TO BE IN THE
COURSE OF HIS DUTIES AS
PRESIDENT.
>> YES, BUT IT'S PRESIDENT --
>> CARRYING OUT HIS DUTIES AS
PRESIDENT AS UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> YES, SIR.
>> NOW, I DON'T SUPPOSE IF HE
WAS TALKING WITH ONE OF HIS
AIDES, MR. HALDEMAN AND MR.
EHRLICHMAN, ABOUT AN INVESTMENT
OF HIS OUT IN CALIFORNIA OR SOME
OTHER PLACE.
>> OR A TENNIS GAME OR WHATEVER.
>> YES, YOU WOULDN'T SUGGESTED
THAT --
>> MY BROTHER DOESN'T SUGGEST
THAT'S WHAT HE WANTS EITHER.
>> WELL, HOW ABOUT CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT A CAMPAIGN, ABOUT THE
NIXON CAMPAIGN?
NOW, THAT'S HARDLY QUITE AN --
>> THAT'S A LITTLE CLOSER --
>> WELL, IT'S VERY CLOSE TO THE
-- YES, THIS IS VERY CLOSE TO --
>> THE PRESIDENT AS A POLITICAL
OFFICE TO --
>> THIS IS VERY CLOSE TO
EXECUTING THE LAWS OF THE UNITED
SATES AND RUNNING A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S VERY
CLOSE, NO.
>> AND SO CONVERSATIONS --
>> I DON'T THINK MY --
>> CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT
SUBJECT MATTER --
>> MY BROTHER ISN'T SEEKING ANY
SUCH CONVERSATIONS.
>> WELL, I KNOW, BUT SHOULDN'T
YOU -- SHOULDN'T THE PRESIDENT
HAVE TO SAY AT LEAST EVEN IF THE
PRIVILEGE IS AS ABSOLUTE AS YOU
SAY IT IS, SHOULDN'T HE AT LEAST
HAVE TO SAY I BELIEVE OR ASSERT
THAT THE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
APPLIES TO THIS TAPE BECAUSE
THIS CONVERSATION IS IN THE
COURSE OF THE PERFORMANCE OF HIS
DUTIES AS PRESIDENT?
>> WELL, AS I READ SOME OF THE
CASES --
>> YOU HAVEN'T DONE THAT EITHER,
HAVE YOU?
>> WE HAVE NOT DONE THAT.
WE HAVE SIMPLY RESPONDED TO AN
ASSERTION THAT THESE ALL RELATE
TO WATERGATE, ASSUMING THAT TO
BE THE FACT.
>> WOULD YOU AUTOMATICALLY SAY
EVERY CONVERSATION ABOUT
WATERGATE IS IN THE COURSE OF
THE PERFORMANCE OF THE DUTIES OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES?
>> I WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE.
YES, SIR.
>> WHY IS THAT?
>> BECAUSE HE HAS THE DUTY; (A)
TO ENFORCE THE LAWS, THAT IS TO
PROSECUTE THESE CASES AND; (B)
HE HAD TO TAKE CARE TO SEE THAT
THE LAWS ARE ENFORCED, THAT IS
TO INVESTIGATE.
AND, MUCH OF THIS MATERIAL DOES
RELATE TO THE INVESTIGATION AS
1,200 AND SOME PAGES OF THE
PUBLIC TRANSCRIPT FULLY
DISCLOSES.
BUT I WOULD BE READY TO CONCEDE,
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S A
DIFFICULT PROBLEM BETWEEN US,
THAT THE PRESIDENT SHOULD SHOW
THAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE CLAIM OF
SUCH A PRIVILEGE AND I THINK
SUCH LANGUAGE APPEARS IN MINK
AND PERHAPS IN REYNOLDS AND IN
KAISER ALUMINUM.
SIMPLY, IT HAS TO BE A
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION FIRST
OF ALL.
>> AND HOW ABOUT -- DO YOU
CONCEDE OR VIEW -- WHAT IS YOUR
VIEW OF THE PRIVILEGE WITH
RESPECT TO WHETHER IT REACHES
FACTUAL ASSERTIONS IN A
CONVERSATION?
THE DIFFERENCE THAT WAS MADE IN
THE MINK CASE AND ANOTHER WITH
RESPECT TO OPINIONS AND
JUDGMENTS AS DISTINGUISHED FROM
THE FACTS?
>> FIRST, MINK, I BELIEVE, WAS A
--
>> STATUTORY CASE.
>> STATUTORY CASE, BUT THAT WAS
ONE OF THE EXCEPTIONS.
>> SO WHAT IS YOUR VIEW?
WOULD YOU SAY IF A CONVERSATION
IS MERELY A RECITATION OF FACT,
IT IS STILL COVERED BY EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE OR --
>> YES, IT IS, IF IT'S
CONFIDENTIAL AND IT'S BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT AND SOME ADVISOR
WITH RESPECT TO HIM BECAUSE,
OTHERWISE --
>> THAT HASN'T GOT MUCH TO DO
WITH THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS, JUST PURE COLD FACTS.
>> IT MIGHT WELL HAVE TO DO WITH
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS IF
THE FACTS ARE SUCH AS WERE
DEVELOPED IN THE COURSE OF AN
INVESTIGATION WITH REGARD TO THE
EXISTENCE OF A OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE CHARGE, MUCH OF WHICH
THE PRESIDENT WAS INVOLVED IN.
BUT THE FACT AGAINST OPINIONS
AND DECISIONS REALLY RELATE TO
ANOTHER SITUATION, AS I SUGGEST,
IN THE STATUTE.
BUT, THE CONVERSATION THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS WITH HIS ADVISERS,
WE SUGGEST, IS ABSOLUTELY
PRIVILEGE.
IT'S A DISCRETIONARY MATTER THAT
HE HAS TO EXERCISE IN WHAT HE IS
GOING TO RELEASE AND NOT
RELEASE.
AND SINCE MARBURY AND MADISON,
MISSISSIPPI AND JOHNSON, IT'S
BEEN CLEAR THAT THE COURT WILL
NOT DIRECT A PRESIDENT TO
EXERCISE HIS DISCRETION IN ANY
MANNER.
THIS IS NOT TO SAY THE COURT
WON'T STRIKE DOWN, AS IN SAWYER,
EXCESSIVE ACTION ON THE PART OF
THE PRESIDENT OR EXCESSIVE
ACTION ON THE PART OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
THAT HAS HAPPENED IN A NUMBER OF
TIMES.
BUT, IT'S A FAR DIFFERENT THING
TO SUGGEST THAT THE COURT SHOULD
UNDERTAKE TO DIRECT THE
PRESIDENT TO EXERCISE HIS
DISCRETION IN A CERTAIN MANNER.
IT'S NOT A MINISTERIAL DUTY BY
ANY MEANS.
IT'S A MATTER OF DISCRETION.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS HE FEELS
HE PROPERLY SHOULD, UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES, MAKE AVAILABLE
AND OTHERS HE SHOULDN'T.
>> WITH RESPECT WITH THAT
PARTICULAR INCIDENCE, THE ONE
HERE INVOLVES THE RELEVANCY OF
MATERIALS TO A CRIMINAL TRIAL
AND, THAT, NORMALLY HAS BEEN A
PART OF THE JUDICIAL POWER UNDER
ARTICLE III, NOT THE EXECUTIVE
POWER.
>> I'D LIKE TO DISCUSS VERY
BRIEFLY GRAVEL, IF I MAY, FOR
EXAMPLE.
I THINK THIS RAISES A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION.
THERE IS, OF COURSE, AN EXPLICIT
SPEECH AND DEBATE IMMUNITY IN
PROVIDING THE CONSTITUTION.
AS OUR BRIEF INDICATES, THE
REASON FOR THIS IS QUITE CLEAR.
IT'S TO PROTECT THE LEGISLATURE
FROM UNWARRANTED INVASION FROM
THE EXECUTIVE AND PERHAPS THE
JUDICIAL.
IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT THE
EXECUTIVE IS NOT ENTITLED TO
SUBSTANTIALLY THE SAME THING BY
IMPLICATION.
AND AT LEAST IN THE CIVIL FIELD,
AS WE HAVE POINTED OUT, THE
COURTS HAVE WORKED OUT BY
IMPLICATION AS A NECESSARY
INGREDIENT TO THE FUNCTION OF
THE DUTIES OF THE EXECUTIVE AN
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY FROM CIVIL
LIABILITY FOR ACTIONS TAKEN
WITHIN THE SPHERE OF THE
OFFICIAL.
SWELLING AND VIOLAS, I GUESS, IS
THE LEADING CASE AS CITED AND
BARR V. MATEO, AND OTHER CASES.
IF SUCH A MATTER CAN BE WORKED
OUT WITH RESPECT TO THE
EXECUTIVE ON CIVIL MATTERS, WE
SUGGEST THERE IS NO REASON WHY
AND, IN FACT, THE COURT SHOULD
SPELL OUT A SIMILAR EXEMPTION IN
CRIMINAL MATTERS ESPECIALLY AS
THEY RELATE TO THE PRESIDENT,
HIMSELF, BECAUSE WHILE I SAID
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT ABOVE THE
LAW, THE LAW CAN ONLY BE MADE
APPLICABLE TO HIM IN A CERTAIN
WAY WHILE HE IS IN OFFICE.
NOW IF A JUNIOR CONGRESSMAN CAN
COMMIT A CRIME ON THE FLOOR OF
THE HOUSE AS APPARENTLY AS
POSSIBLE, UNDER GRAVEL AND
JOHNSON, IS IT TO BE SAID THAT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS LESS IMMUNITY THAN A
JUNIOR CONGRESSMAN?
I THINK NOT.
SO THAT, I SUGGEST TO YOU THAT
COMMON SENSE AND PROPER
CONSTRUCTION OF THE CONSTITUTION
IMPINGED WITHIN THE GRANT OF
EXECUTIVE POWER ALL OF THOSE
NECESSARY INGREDIENTS TO MAKE IT
WORK TO BE EFFECTIVE WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE IMMUNITY AND CRIMINAL
IMMUNITY.
THE PRESIDENT, WE SUGGEST,
CANNOT BE INDICTED, CAN'T EVEN
BE NAMED AS A CO-CONSPIRATOR
BECAUSE THAT'S AN ASSUMPTION OF
A LEGISLATIVE FUNCTION UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION.
AND, THEREFORE, WE SUGGEST THAT
EVEN IF THIS IS CRIMINAL THE
PRESIDENT IS IMMUNE FROM THE
ORDINARY CRIMINAL PROCESS.
HE IS NOT IMMUNE FROM PROCESS,
BUT THAT PROCESS THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO THE PRESIDENT IS A
PROCESS OF IMPEACHMENT WHICH
DOES NOT INCLUDE THE FUNCTION OF
THE JUDICIARY BRANCH.
AND, THEREFORE, WE SAY THAT IF,
UNDER GRAVEL, THE CONGRESSMAN IS
ENTITLED TO IMMUNITY EVEN FROM
CRIMINAL CONDUCT WHERE ACTIONS
TAKEN WITHIN THE LEGISLATIVE
SPHERE OF HIS CONDUCT, THEN IT
WOULD BE VERY HARD TO SUPPORT A
PROPOSITION THAT THE PRESIDENT,
AS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OF THE
COUNTRY, IS ENTITLED TO LESS.
>> EXCEPT THEY DIDN'T PUT HIM IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> RIGHT, AND THE REASON THEY
DIDN'T, SIR, WAS IT WAS NOT
FOUND TO BE NECESSARY.
THEY DIDN'T PUT CIVIL IMMUNITY
IN THE CONSTITUTION EITHER FOR
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND THIS
COURT HAS FOUND, OF COURSE, THAT
THERE IS SUCH AN IMMUNITY.
I'M SORRY, SIR?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> IT WAS A SPEECH AND DEBATE
CLAUSE CASE AND IT EVEN FORBAD
AS I UNDERSTAND THE GRAVEL CASE,
THE GRAND JURY INQUIRY INTO
MOTIVATIONS AND ACTIONS OF THE
SENATOR AND HIS AID.
>> BECAUSE THE CONSTITUTION SAID
SO.
>> RIGHT, AND I SUGGEST THE
CONSTITUTION, BY CLEAR
IMPLICATION PROVIDES THE SAME
NOT ONLY FOR THE EXECUTIVE BUT
FOR THE JUDICIAL AS WELL, BUT
CERTAINLY FOR THE EXECUTIVE.
>> AND IF WE CAN'T FIND IT IN
THE CONSTITUTION, WHAT HAPPENS
TO YOUR ARGUMENT?
>> WELL, I WOULD SUGGEST YOU
SHOULD FIND IT IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT NEED NOT BE EXPLICIT.
IT CAN WELL BE IMPLIED.
>> THE QUESTION IS IF WE CAN'T
FIND IT, WHAT HAPPENS TO YOUR
ARGUMENT?
>> IF YOU CANNOT FIND IT?
>> YES, SIR.
>> THEN, IF YOUR HONOR PLEASE,
THAT PORTION OF THE ARGUMENT IS
LOST AS FAR AS THIS COURT'S
CONCERNED, I GUESS.
>> DON'T YOU -- YOU HAVEN'T LOST
YOUR OTHER POINT WHICH SAYS THIS
COURT CAN SET UP THE SAME KIND
OF PRIVILEGE THAT THEY'VE SET UP
IN OTHERS.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
AND, WE'RE SUGGESTING THAT IT
SHOULD IN THIS CASE NOT
NECESSARILY BECAUSE A GREAT DEAL
IS NOW LEFT TO BE GAINED BY
EXPUNGING THE GRAND JURY ACTION.
MY BROTHER IS RIGHT.
THE DAMAGES HAS BEEN DONE AND WE
THINK QUITE IMPROPERLY SO.
WE THINK THE TACTICS INVOLVED
WITH THE PROSECUTOR IN SEEKING
TO MAKE, ENLARGING THE SCOPE OF
ADMISSIBLE TESTIMONY IS HARDLY
WORTH WHAT HAS BEEN DONE HERE
BUT IT'S BEEN DONE.
BUT, IT SEEMS TO ME, HISTORY
WOULD E SERVED BY GRANTING OF
THE RELIEF WE HAVE PRAYED FOR
BELOW, NAMELY, TO EXPUNGE THIS.
SECONDLY, IT SEEMS TO ME THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULD FEEL
BETTER ABOUT THE FAIRNESS OF THE
ISSUES NOW PENDING BEFORE THE
HOUSE IS THIS ACT WHICH WE SAY
WAS IMPROPER AND ILLEGAL WERE
EXPUNGED.
BUT IN SO FAR AS THE MECHANISMS
OF THIS CASE ARE CONCERNED, IT
DESTROYS OR REMOVES A BASIS UPON
WHICH THEY CONTEND THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO THESE DOCUMENTS.
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT FOR A
MOMENT.
>> WE'VE BEEN ASKED MANY TIMES
TO DO THAT IN OTHER CASES WITH
RESPECT TO THE GRAND JURIES.
UP TODAY, I DON'T THINK WE'VE
EVER COME NEAR ANYWHERE TO IT.
>> AND UP TODAY, YOU'VE NEVER
HAD A PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES NAMED AS A CO-CONSPIRATOR
EITHER, SIR.
>> THAT'S VERY TRUE.
>> AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES --[LAUGHTER]
AND I DON'T MEAN TO BE FACETIOUS
ABOUT IT BUT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WE SUGGEST,
CAN BE PROCEEDED AGAINST ONLY BY
IMPEACHMENT WHILE IN OFFICE AND
HIS POWERS ARE UNABATED UNTIL
SUCH TIME AS HE LEAVES THAT
OFFICE.
NOW, WITH RESPECT TO THIS
SUGGESTION THAT A GRAND JURY
FINDING HIS PRIMA FACIE EVIDENCE
--
>> THAT, OF COURSE, HAVE NEVER
BEEN DECIDED EITHER.
>> NO.
THIS CASE IS UNUSUAL IN MANY
RESPECTS.
THIS SUGGESTION THAT A GRAND
JURY FINDING IS PRIMA FACIE
EVIDENCE AND, THEREFORE, THE
PRESIDENT HAS LOST WHATEVER
PRIVILEGE HE OTHERWISE WOULD
HAVE HAD IT JUST ISN'T BORNE OUT
BY EITHER THE FACTS OR THE LEGAL
ISSUES AND PRINCIPALS INVOLVED.
THE GRAND JURY FINDING IS NOT
PRIMA FACIE EVIDENCE.
EVEN IF IT'S MENTIONED IN AN
OPENING ARGUMENT IN A CRIMINAL
TRIAL, THERE'S A GRAVE RISK OF A
MISTRIAL.
THE CASES CITED BY MY BROTHER,
PARTICULARLY THE CLARK CASE, ARE
CLEARLY CASES WHICH REQUIRE A
SHOWING IN COURT OR, IN CLARK, A
SHOWING TO THE JUDGE THAT THERE
WAS PRIMA FACIE EVIDENCE OF
WRONG DOING.
YOU MAY RECALL THAT'S A CASE
INVOLVING INVESTIGATION INTO A
JUROR AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THE
JUROR HAD PERFORMED PROPERLY,
AND THE JUROR HAD BEEN SHOWN,
HAD TESTIFIED FALSELY IN THE
QUALIFICATIONS THAT SHE HAD
NEVER HAD ANY BUSINESS RELATIONS
WITH ONE OF THE PARTIES WHEN, IN
FACT, SHE HAD.
THE COURT SAID "WELL, THERE'S A
FINDING OF WRONG DOING AND,
BASED ON THAT, NOW I WILL LOOK
INTO THE JUROR'S DELIBERATIONS
TO SEE WHAT SHE DID."
BUT, JUSTICE CARDOZO MADE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT IF HE HADN'T
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE A PRIMA FACIE
SHOWING A WRONG DOING BY
EVIDENCE BEFORE HIM THERE WOULD
HAVE BEEN NO CAUSE FOR "LETTING
IN THE LIGHT," AS HE PUT IT.
AND, THE UN CASE AND OTHER CASES
WHICH ARE RELIED ON BY MY
BROTHERS ARE ALL CASES WHERE
THERE WAS A PRIMA FACIE SHOWING
IN A COURTROOM.
A GRAND JURY CHARGE IS NOT PRIMA
FACIE.
IN THE FIRST PLACE, IT'S ONLY
ACCUSATORY.
IT'S NOT EVEN ADMISSIBLE NOR CAN
IT BE REFERRED TO IN A TRIAL.
SECONDLY, IT CAN WELL INVOLVE
INCOMPETENT EVIDENCE, AS THIS
COURT RECENTLY DECIDED, AND IT'S
TOTALLY INAPPROPRIATE TO SUGGEST
THAT A PRESIDENT WHO OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE A VERY VALUABLE
PRIVILEGE AND I THINK I SHOULD
EMPHASIZE THE VALUE OF THESE
PRIVILEGES BECAUSE IT IS A
VALUABLE PRIVILEGE.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS READ
JUSTICE REED'S DECISION IN
KAISER ALUMINUM WHEN HE SPELLS
IT OUT QUITE CLEARLY THE
IMPORTANCE AND VALUE OF THIS
PRIVILEGE TO SIMPLY SAY TO HAVE
A GRAND JURY MAKE A CHARGE THAT
DESTROYS THAT PRIVILEGE IS AN
ARGUMENT THAT I DON'T THINK CAN
BE SUSTAINED.
>> MR. ST. CLAIR, YOU HAVE NOT
MENTIONED IN YOUR ARGUMENT A FEW
MOMENTS AGO ON THE QUESTION OF
THE ABSENCE OF ANY PROVISION FOR
IMMUNITY FOR JUDGES OR
PRESIDENTS, YOU HAVEN'T
MENTIONED THE HOLDING OF THIS
COURT IN PIERSON AGAINST RAID
WHEREAS, I RECALL IT, THE COURT
ASSUMED WITH THE SENTENCE OR TWO
THAT THERE WAS ABSOLUTE
PRIVILEGE FOR THE JUDICIARY BUT
THAT THE PRIVILEGES OF THE
EXECUTIVE, IN THAT CASE A
POLICEMAN, WAS QUALIFIED.
THE COURT HAD NO DIFFICULTY IN
CONCLUDING THAT IT DID NOT
REQUIRE AN EXPRESS
CONSTITUTIONAL PROVISION TO
SPELL OUT AN ABSOLUTE PRIVILEGE
FOR JUDGES.
THESE WERE STATE JUDGES IN THAT
CASE OF COURSE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WELL, IF YOUR HONOR PLEASE, I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE CONSTITUTION DOES
NOT EXPLICITLY STATE IMMUNITY,
AS IT DOES IN THE SPEECH AND
DEBATE CLAUSE, SHOULD THIS COURT
HOLD IT DOES NOT EXIST IN
CRIMINAL MATTERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ONE POINT
WITH THE COURT HOWEVER, BECAUSE
I'M SURE THE POINT WILL BE
RAISED CONCERNING JUSTICE CARR
FOR EXAMPLE.
THERE IS A DISTINCT DIFFERENCE,
AS WE POINTED OUT IN OUR REPLY
BRIEF AS WE VIEW IT, BETWEEN A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
A SINGLE INDIVIDUAL IN WHO THE
ENTIRE EXECUTIVE FUNCTION IS
VESTED.
A PRESIDENT SERVES 7 DAYS A WEEK
24 HOURS A DAY, AND ONLY HE OR
THOSE UNDER HIM PERFORMING HIS
FUNCTIONS CAN EXERCISE THE
EXECUTIVE FUNCTION OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
NOW, IF A CONGRESSMAN OR A
SENATOR OR EVEN A JUDGE --
>> OR A VICE PRESIDENT.
>> OR A VICE PRESIDENT IS
REMOVED FROM HIS DUTIES, MATTERS
GO ON.
BUT A PRESIDENT DOESN'T HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A
VACATION AND IT'S VESTED IN ONE
INDIVIDUAL AND DELIBERATELY SO.
>> THIS IS PRETTY FAR-FIELD FROM
THE BASIC QUESTION HERE, WHICH
IS THE TESTIMONIAL PRIVILEGE.
>> WE SAY IT'S A CONSTITUTIONAL
--
>> NOT PROSECUTORIAL IMMUNITY,
BUT TESTIMONIAL PRIVILEGES ARE
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE
BASICALLY.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
I THINK SO.
I WOULD WANT TO THE POINT WITH
YOU THAT WE THINK THE PRIVILEGE
WE'RE ARGUING FOR IS BOTH COMMON
LAW AND CONSTITUTION.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> IT'S CONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE
IT'S INHERENT IN THE EXECUTIVE
POWER.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOUR ARGUMENT.
BUT THIS MATTER --
>> AND IT'S COMMON LAW BECAUSE
IT HAS ALWAYS EXISTED.
>> WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN -- A
JUDGE CAN BE PROSECUTED
CRIMINALLY OR IS --
>> IT HAS TO DO WITH THESE
QUESTIONS OF IMMUNITY.
>> IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
TESTIMONIAL PRIVILEGE, DOES IT?
>> WELL, MY BROTHER SEEMS TO
THINK IT DOES BECAUSE THEY SAY,
BECAUSE OF THE IMPLICATIONS OF
CRIMINALITY HERE THE PRESIDENT
HAS LOST SOMETHING HE OTHERWISE
WOULD NOT HAVE HAD.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
SINCE I HAVE ALREADY INTERRUPTED
YOU, MAY I?
>> PLEASE DO.
>> TO RAIL UPON YOUR GOOD NATURE
A LITTLE MORE MR. ST. CLAIR, TO
ASK YOU WHETHER IT IS YOUR CLAIM
THAT ANY OF THESE MATERIALS HAVE
TO DO WITH WHAT HAVE SOMETIMES
BEEN CALLED MATTERS OF STATE,
I.E. MATTERS OF INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS OR NATIONAL DEFENSE.
MR. JAWORSKI ASSURE TO US THAT
THEY DID NOT INVOLVE MATTERS OF
STATE, BUT I'M ABOUT TO HEAR
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY ABOUT THAT,
BECAUSE AS YOU WELL KNOW BOTH
THE COMMENTATORS AND COURT
DECISIONS HAVE MADE A DICHOTOMY
BETWEEN THE PRIVILEGE THAT EXIST
WITH RESPECT TO ORDINARY GENERAL
CONFIDENTIALITY ON ONE HAND OF
THE EXECUTIVE, AND MATTERS OF
STATE ON THE OTHER TO WHICH A
HIGHER PRIVILEGE HAS SOMETIMES
BEEN THOUGHT TO BE ACCORDED.
>> WELL, I THINK IF A HIGHER
PRIVILEGE HAS BEEN ACCORDED, IT
SHOULD NOT.
BUT IN ANY EVENT, THE PRIVILEGE
OF CONFIDENTIALITY IS NOT
UNIMPORTANT.
HOWEVER, LET ME DIRECT MYSELF TO
YOUR QUESTION.
THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS
NO ONE KNOWS.
>> BUT YOU --
>> YOU WON'T KNOW UNTIL YOU
LISTEN TO THESE TAPES AS TO WHAT
SUBJECTS ARE DISCUSSED.
MY BROTHER CAN ONLY STATE THAT
IT'S PROBABLE THEY RELATE, AT
LEAST IN PART, TO WHATEVER HE
SAYS, WATERGATE.
OR IT'S LIKELY THAT IT MIGHT.
AND, I HAVE HAD THE EXPERIENCE
FOR EXEMPT WHERE CIRCUMSTANCES
WERE SUCH THAT THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE FELT THAT IT WAS
LIKELY THAT A CONVERSATION TOOK
PLACE BETWEEN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, MR. MITCHELL, AND THE
PRESIDENT REGARDING PLANS FOR
SURVEILLANCE OF DEMOCRATIC
PARTIES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
CONVERSATION, IT WASN'T THERE AT
ALL.
>> BUT IN THIS TAPE --
>> SO, I HAVE NO WAY OF KNOWING
NOR DOES THE PROSECUTOR KNOW
WHAT ADDITIONAL MATTERS MAY BE
INTERWOVEN INTO THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
ONE THING IS CERTAIN.
>> AM I CORRECT IN BELIEVING,
MR. ST. CLAIR, IN UNDERSTANDING,
MR. ST. CLAIR, THAT IN THIS CASE
TO DATE NO REPRESENTATION HAS
BEEN MADE BY AFFIDAVIT OR
PROFESSIONAL REPRESENTATION OR
OTHERWISE THAT ANY OF THESE
MATERIALS HAVE TO DO WITH
NATIONAL DEFENSE OR
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS?
>> NO, AND NO REPRESENTATION
COULD BE MADE TO THE CONTRARY
EITHER.
>> AND THAT WOULD BE, THEREFORE,
A MATTER TO BE UNDER THE
EXISTING ORDER NOW UNDER REVIEW
OF JUDGE SIRICA.
THAT WOULD BE SUBMITTED TO HIM
LATER IN CAMERA, CORRECT?
>> IF THIS COURT FINDS --
>> I SAY UNDER HIS EXISTING
ORDER.
>> YES, THAT'S RIGHT.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND THE PRESIDENT PRESUMABLY,
IF HE WERE TO COMPLY WITH THAT
ORDER, WOULD MAKE SUCH A
REPRESENTATION IN AN APPROPRIATE
CASE.
BUT THE FUNDAMENTAL POINT IS WE
BELIEVE THE REASON STATED THAT
THE PRESIDENT'S RIGHT TO
CONFIDENTIAL ADVICE IS IMPORTANT
AND IT'S ACTUALLY FUNDAMENTAL TO
THE PROPER FUNCTION OF HIS
GOVERNMENT AND IN MANY
INSTANCES, AS I SUGGESTED, EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT IN MILITARY
MATTERS OR MATTERS OF STATE, SO
TO SPEAK, BECAUSE NO MATTER WHAT
THE CONVERSATION IS OF COURSE
IT'S THE FACT THAT IT MIGHT
BECOME PUBLIC THAT INVOLVES THEM
THIS CHILLING EFFECT WE'VE MADE
REFERENCE TO IN OUR BRIEF UNDER
THE FIRST AMENDMENT BUT AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER.
AND, I CAN SEE IT MYSELF.
THE COMMUNICATIONS ARE NOT FREE
AND OPEN BECAUSE WHO IS TO SAY
THAT IT WON'T BE BECALMED BEFORE
A GRAND JURY?
AND, MOST EVERYONE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS BEEN BECALMED BEFORE A
GRAND JURY, SOMETIMES SEVERAL
TIMES.
THE FBI HAS INTERVIEWED EVERY
SECRETARY THAT HAS ANY KNOWLEDGE
OF ANY ASPECT OF THIS CASE.
THIS PROSECUTOR HAS A PLETHORA
OF INFORMATION.
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO TRY THIS
CASE WITH ALL THE EVIDENCE, SO
HE KNOWS BETTER THAN THAT.
NOBODY TRIES ANY CASE WITH ALL
THE EVIDENCE.
YOU'D BE BURIED IN MINUTIA.
YOU SELECT THE EVIDENCE THAT YOU
THINK MOST APPROPRIATE TO YOUR
CASE.
YOU DON'T TRY IT WITH ALL THE
EVIDENCE.
AND THIS SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HAS
MOUNTAINS OF INFORMATION.
>> WHO IS TO DETERMINE HOW MUCH
EVIDENCE A PROSECUTOR NEEDS?
ONLY THE PROSECUTOR --
>> THAT'S CORRECT, NOT THE
COURT.
AND IF THAT EVIDENCE CONSTITUTES
PRESIDENTIAL CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATION, AND I SUGGEST IF
YOUR HONOR PLEASE --
>> MANY CASES --
>> THE PRESIDENT DETERMINES
THAT.
>> MANY CASES HAVE BEEN LOST
BECAUSE THE PROSECUTOR HAD TOO
MUCH EVIDENCE.
>> WELL, I SUGGEST THAT'S
PROBABLY THE FACT HERE.
SO, WHEN MY BROTHER SAYS "I
DON'T NEED THIS EVIDENCE TO WIN
THESE CASES IN MY OPINION, BUT I
NEED THEM SO I CAN PRESENT ALL
THE EVIDENCE," I'VE BEEN TRYING
CASES LONG ENOUGH TO KNOW AND SO
DOES HE THAT'S NOT WHAT HE'S
REALLY AFTER.
>> YES, I'VE TRIED A FEW TOO,
BUT MR. ST. CLAIR-[LAUGHTER]
I WAS JUST WONDERING.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THE BURDEN
HERE?
IS IT ON THE PROSECUTION?
>> THE BURDEN UNDER 17C IS
CLEARLY ON THE PROSECUTION AND
THE BURDEN IN CLEARLY ON THE
PROSECUTION ON EVERY OTHER
ASPECT.
>> ALRIGHT, AND NOW, HOW MUCH IS
ENOUGH FOR OUR PHRASE TO BE
KICKING AROUND PRIMA FACIE HERE?
>> WELL, I SUGGEST WHATEVER WAS
CONSIDERED BY THIS COURT IN
REYNOLDS TO BE ENOUGH IS MORE
THAN ENOUGH IN THIS CASE.
WE HAVE THE TESTIMONY OF EVERY
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED.
A NUMBER OF THEM HAVE PLED
GUILTY.
DEAN HAS PLED GUILTY.
COLSON HAS PLED GUILTY.
COMEBACK HAS PLED GUILT, ETC.,
ETC.
ALL UNDER PLEA BARGAINS WHERE
THEY ARE UNDER OBLIGATION TO
FULLY COOPERATE.
THIS PROSECUTOR IS NOT, NOR DOES
HE SAY AT ANY POINT THAT HE
NEEDS THIS INFORMATION TO
PROSECUTE SUCCESSFULLY THESE
CASES.
>> MR. ST. CLAIR, JUST TO
PINPOINT ANOTHER ISSUE, LET'S
ASSUME FOR THE MOMENT THAT WE
DIDN'T AGREE WITH YOU ON YOUR
TEST OF PRIVILEGE AND LET'S JUST
ASSUME THAT THE ONLY ISSUE THAT
WAS LEFT IN THE CASE WAS THE 17C
ISSUE.
NOW --
>> THEN THE PRESIDENT WINS, IN
MY VIEW.
>> WELL, BECAUSE?
>> BECAUSE THE PROSECUTOR CANNOT
SHOW THAT THE EVIDENCE HE SEEKS
IS RELEVANT AND ADMISSIBLE.
>> YOU THINK --
>> BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCE, HE DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT'S IN THERE.
>> WELL, I SUPPOSE THERE ARE TWO
PARTS TO THE QUESTION.
ONE, HOW MUCH OF A SHOWING DOES
HE HAVE TO MAKE AS TO WHAT'S ON
-- WHAT MIGHT BE ON THE TAPE
AND, SECONDLY, IF THAT MATTER
THAT HE CLAIMED IS ON THE TAPE
IS ON THE TAPE, IS THAT RELEVANT
AND ADMISSIBLE UNDER 17C?
>> BUT YOU'D HAVE TO KNOW WHAT
THE MATTER WAS OR WHAT THE
ISSUES IN THE CASE WERE.
BUT UNDER BOWMAN AND IOZIA, IT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO SHOW THAT IT
PROBABLY IS OR IT MIGHT BE OR IS
LIKELY TO BE.
IT MUST BE SHOWN TO BE RELEVANT
AND MUST BE SHOWN TO BE
ADMISSIBLE.
>> BUT, MR. ST. CLAIR --
>> THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT A THIRD
PARTY SCHEME.
>> YOU CAN'T PUT AN IMPOSSIBLE
TASK ON SOMEONE WHO WANTS A
SUBPOENA AGAINST A THIRD PARTY
WITNESS OR AGAINST ANYBODY ELSE.
AS TO SHOWING WHAT IS PRECISELY
ON INNOCENT DOCUMENTS, I WOULD
SUPPOSE.
>> WELL --
>> HERE --
>> IF YOU WANT TO UTILIZE THE
17C, THEN I SUGGEST THAT'S WHAT
YOU HAVE TO DO.
>> HE'S NEVER LISTENED TO THE
TAPES.
HE DOESN'T KNOW PRECISELY WHAT'S
ON THEM.
YOU WOULD SAY THAT HE COULD
NEVER SUBPOENA A TAPE UNLESS HE
HAD ALREADY GOTTEN IT.
>> AS A PROSECUTOR, THAT'S
RIGHT.
AS A GRAND JURY, THAT'S ANOTHER
MATTER.
IF HE HAD BROUGHT -- SOUGHT THIS
UNDER A GRAND JURY SUBPOENA, WE
WOULD THEN BE DIRECTLY FACED
WITH NIXON AGAINST SIRICA WHICH
WE HAPPEN TO THINK WAS
IMPROPERLY AND INCORRECTLY
DECIDED.
BUT UNDER 17C, WE ARE DEALING
WITH THE PROSECUTOR'S SUBPOENA.
THE EVIDENCE OF DECIDED CASES
MAKES IT QUITE CLEAR THERE MUST
BE A SPECIFIC SHOWING OF
RELEVANCE AND ADMISSIBILITY.
NOW, IF HE CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE
OF THE NATURE OF THE MATTER THEN
--
>> WELL, THAT ISN'T WHAT 17 --
>> THAT'S HIS PROBLEM, NOT MINE.
>> THE CASES YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE CASES WHERE A
DEFENDANT SOUGHT DISCOVERY OF
EVIDENCE FROM THE -- OR SOUGHT
MATERIAL IN A PROSECUTOR'S
FILES.
>> MOST OF THOSE CASES ARE BUT
THERE IS AT LEAST ONE CASE, I
THINK IT'S GROSSMAN, THAT SAYS
THE RULES ARE EQUALLY APPLICABLE
TO THE PROSECUTION.
IT'S CITED IN ONE OF THE
FOOTNOTES IN OUR BRIEF.
BUT, THE 17C SUBPOENA IS
CONCEPTUALLY A SUBPOENA FOR
KNOWN INFORMATION.
CONCEPTUALLY, IF THE PROSECUTOR
IS LOOKING FOR THINGS, HE SHOULD
UTILIZE A GRAND JURY SUBPOENA.
IN THAT CASE, I THINK IN BOWMAN,
THEY WANTED THE PROSECUTOR TO
PRODUCE EACH DOCUMENT HE WAS
GOING TO USE IN THE PRESENTATION
OF HIS CASE.
THAT'S SPECIFIC.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY RELEVANT AND
ADMISSIBLE.
>> SO ONCE HE GETS THROUGH WITH
THE GRAND JURY, HE SHOULDN'T BE
USING A SUBPOENA TO DEVELOP HIS
CASE?
>> THAT'S CORRECT, AND CERTAINLY
NOT UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCE.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT'S THE
PRACTICE IN THE --
>> I THINK IT IS THE PRACTICE.
I THINK THAT THE GRAND JURY
PRACTICE IS FAR GREATER THAN
PERHAPS THE CONSTITUTION HAS
ENVISIONED.
IT'S REALLY USED TODAY, FRANKLY,
AS AN EFFECTIVE DISCOVERY TOOL.
>> MR. ST. CLAIR, MAY I GET BACK
TO WHAT SEEMS RATHER FUNDAMENTAL
TO ME?
LET US ASSUME THAT IT HAD BEEN
ESTABLISHED THE CONVERSATIONS WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY DID
INVOLVE A CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY.
WOULD YOU STILL BE ASSERTING AN
ABSOLUTE PRIVILEGE?
>> YES, QUITE CLEARLY, UNDER THE
ANALOGY THAT WAS PROVIDED, I
MAY.
>> RIGHT, AND AS I UNDERSTAND
IT, THE PUBLIC INTEREST BEHIND
THAT PRIVILEGE IS THE
PRESERVATION OF CANDOR IN
DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS CLOSES DID.
>> QUITE CLEARLY SO.
THE SIMPLE REASON, SIR --
>> MAY I FOLLOW THAT UP?
>> I'M SORRY.
>> WHAT PUBLIC INTEREST IS THERE
IN PRESERVING SECRECY WITH
RESPECT TO A CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY?
>> THE ANSWER, SIR, IS THAT
CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY IS CRIMINAL
ONLY AFTER IT'S PROVEN TO BE
CRIMINAL, AND WE'RE NOT AT THAT
POINT YET.
>> MY QUESTION WAS BASED ON THE
ASSUMPTION THAT IT HAD BEEN
ESTABLISHED THAT THE
CONVERSATION DID RELATE TO A
CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY.
>> THAT IS, THE CASE HAS BEEN
TRIED AND DEFENSE FOUND GUILTY.
>> WELL, NO.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED
IN VARIOUS WAYS.
AS YOU'VE JUST SAID, A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY CONFESSED
AND THESE PEOPLE WERE
PARTICIPANTS IN SOME OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
>> BUT THE FACT THAT ONE
DEFENDANT CONFESSED DOES NOT
MAKE THE OTHER DEFENDANT GUILTY.
>> OF COURSE.
BUT ANYWAY, YOUR ANSWER IS THAT
YOU WOULD STILL ASSERT THE
ACTION THROUGH.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE ANSWER IS
YES EVEN IF IT IS CRIMINAL BUT,
MORE IMPORTANTLY, IT IS YES
BECAUSE CRIMINALITY IS SOMETHING
THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY
DETERMINED AT THE TIME THAT YOU
MUST RESOLVE THE ISSUE.
AND, THAT YOU SHOULD NOT DESTROY
HE PRIVILEGE IN THE ANTICIPATION
OF A LATER FINDING OF
CRIMINALITY WHICH MAY NEVER COME
TO PASS.
IT IS QUITE CONCEIVABLE THAT A
NUMBER OF THESE DEFENDANTS WILL
BE FOUND INNOCENT AND IN FACT,
IN THEORY, THEY ARE INNOCENT
RIGHT NOW.
>> WHAT IS THE PUBLIC INTEREST
IN KEEPING THAT SECRET?
>> TO AVAIL THE PRESIDENT, IF
YOUR HONOR PLEASE, OF THE FREE
AND UNTRAMMELED SOURCE OF
INFORMATION AND ADVICE WITHOUT
THE THOUGHT OR FEAR THAT IT MAY
BE REVIEWED AT SOME LATER TIME
WHEN SOME GRAND JURY, IN THIS
CASE, OR SOME OTHER REASON
SUGGEST THERE IS CRIMINALITY.
FOR EXAMPLE, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
-- I'M SORRY.
>> HE DID RELEASE THEM FOR THE
GRAND JURY IN THIS CASE.
>> YES, IN THE PRESIDENT'S
DISCRETION, HE DID THAT.
AND, IT'S A DISCRETIONARY
MATTER.
BUT, FOR EXAMPLE, THE SIMPLE
MATTER OF APPOINTMENT, IF I MAY,
AN APPOINTMENT OF A JUDGE.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
JUDICIARY TO HAVE GOOD JUDGES.
IT'S NOT AT ALL UNHEARD OF FOR
LAWYERS TO BE ASKED THEIR
OPINION ABOUT A NOMINEE.
NOW, IF THAT LAWYER WANTS TO BE
SURE THAT HE'S GOING TO BE
PROTECTED IN GIVING CANDID
OPINIONS REGARDING A NOMINEE FOR
THE BENCH, IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL THAT THAT BE
PROTECTED.
OTHERWISE, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
GET CANDID ADVICE.
NOW, THIS ISN'T A STATE SECRET.
IT ISN'T NATIONAL DEFENSE.
I SUGGEST IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THAT JUDGE MAY SIT ON
THAT BENCH FOR 30 YEARS.
>> BUT DON'T YOU THINK IT WOULD
BE IMPORTANT IF THE JUDGE AND
THE PRESIDENT WERE DISCUSSING
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE
APPOINTMENTS FOR MONEY?
>> I'M SORRY, SIR.
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION.
>> DON'T YOU THINK IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT IN A HYPOTHETICAL CASE
IF AN ABOUT TO BE APPOINTED
JUDGE WAS MAKING A DEAL WITH THE
PRESIDENT FOR MONEY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> BUT UNDER YOURS IT COULDN'T
BE.
IN PUBLIC INTEREST, YOU COULDN'T
RELEASE THAT.
>> I WOULD THINK THAT THAT COULD
NOT BE RELEASED IF IT WERE A
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION.
IF THE PRESIDENT DID APPOINT
SUCH AN INDIVIDUAL, THE REMEDY
IS CLEAR.
THE REMEDY IS HE SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
LET ME GIVE YOU THIS --
>> HOW ARE YOU GOING TO IMPEACH
HIM IF YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT?
>> WELL, IF YOU KNOW ABOUT IT,
THEN YOU CAN STATE THE CASE.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT, YOU
NEVER HAD IT.
>> YOU'RE ON A PRONG.
IT'S A DILEMMA.
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
>> IF YOU KNOW THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING SOMETHING WRONG, YOU CAN
IMPEACH HIM BUT THE ONLY WAY YOU
CAN FIND OUT IS THIS WAY.
YOU CAN'T IMPEACH HIM SO YOU
DON'T IMPEACH HIM.
YOU LOOSE ME SOMEPLACE ALONG
THERE.[LAUGHTER]
>> THIS IS I THINK WHAT WAS
SUGGESTED IN THE SEABORG CASE
WHERE THE COURT SAID "GEE!
IF THAT'S SO, THEN FLOYD COULD
BE ALL COVERED OVER AND SO
FORTH."
HUMAN EXPERIENCE IS NOT
DEMONSTRATED AND THAT'S A FACT.
VERY FEW THINGS FOREVER ARE
HIDDEN.
SECONDLY, HOWEVER, THIS CASE IS
NOT THAT CASE.
AS I POINTED OUT, THERE IS A
PLETHORA OF INFORMATION.
THIS IS NOT A CASE WHERE THERE
IS NO INFORMATION.
IF ANYTHING, THERE IS MORE THAN
ENOUGH.
>> WHAT YOU'RE TELLING US ALSO
COULD BE ARGUED THE OTHER WAY,
THAT THERE HAS BEEN A WAIVER AND
NEITHER --
>> THAT IS SUGGESTED BY MY
BROTHERS.
>> YOUR BROTHER HAS TALKED ABOUT
WAIVER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE SUGGESTED.
>> MY BROTHER SUGGESTS A WAIVER,
BUT THIS PRIVILEGE IS NOT LIKE
FIFTH AMENDMENT PRIVILEGE OR
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE WHERE
IF YOU LET OUT ONE WORD, YOU'D
LOST THE WHOLE THING.
THAT WOULD DEFEAT THE PURPOSE OF
IT.
AS WE POINT OUT IN OUR BRIEF,
PUBLIC POLICY REQUIRES AS MUCH
PUBLICITY AS THE PRESIDENT IN
HIS DISCRETION DETERMINES WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE AND THE MORE
INFORMATION, THE BETTER.
AND IF YOU REQUIRE -- IF YOU
RULE THAT ONE UTTERANCE
CONSTITUTES A WAIVER, YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GET IT.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE THAT
THING.
THIS IS A DISCRETIONARY
PRIVILEGE THAT THE CONSTITUTION,
BY IMPLICATION OF NECESSITY, AND
HISTORY HAS SHOWN IS INHERENT IN
THE EXECUTIVE FUNCTION AS,
INDEED, IT IS IN OTHER
FUNCTIONS.
WE'VE CITED IN OUR BRIEF SIMILAR
EXAMPLES OF THE LEGISLATURE
INSISTING UPON SUCH A PRIVILEGE
EVEN AGAINST SUBPOENAS FROM
COURTS, EXECUTIVES, AND THE
COURTS THEMSELVES.
>> MR. ST. CLAIR, YOU'RE CUTTING
INTO YOUR REBUTTAL TIME NOW.
>> I KNOW I AM.
I DO APPRECIATE BEING REMINDED
OF THAT AND I THINK I WOULD
PRESERVE OF WHICH I THINK IS 10
MORE MINUTES.
ARGUMENT OF PHILIP A. LACOVARA
>> MR. LACOVARA.
>> THANK YOU, MR. CHIEF JUSTICE.
IF I MAY, I WOULD LIKE TO ADVERT
FIRST TO PROCEDURAL QUESTIONS
THAT MR. BLACKMUN AND MR.
JUSTICE STEWART HAVE RAISED
ABOUT WHETHER THE MANDAMUS CASE
IS PROPERLY HERE.
MR. JUSTICE, WE DID, IN OUR
CERTIORARI PETITION, REFER TO
THE FACT THAT WE WERE TRYING TO
BRING BEFORE THE COURT FOR
REVIEW BEFORE JUDGMENT IN THE
COURT OF APPEALS THE ORDER OF
THE DISTRICT COURT WHICH WE SAID
THE PRESIDENT HAD TRIED TO
OBTAIN REVIEW OF IN TWO WAYS IN
TWO CASES IN THE COURT OF
APPEALS, AND WE GAVE THE DOCKET
NUMBERS OF THOSE TWO CASES.
AND, THAT CERTIORARI PETITION
WAS FILED ON MAY 24 AND JUDGE
SIRICA, WHO WAS THE RESPONDENT
AS JUSTICE STEWART PROPERLY
NOTES IN THE MANDAMUS CASE IN
THE COURT OF APPEALS, WAS SERVED
WITH A COPY OF THE CERTIORARI
PETITION AS HE HAD BEEN SERVED
WITH THE MANDAMUS PETITION AS,
INDEED, HAD ALL THE RESPONDENTS
WHO WERE OTHERWISE BEFORE THE
COURT, THE DEFENDANTS IN UNITED
STATES AGAINST MITCHELL.
ON MAY 28 IN ACCORDANCE WITH A
MOTION THAT WAS FILED IN A COURT
OF APPEALS, A COPY OF WHICH I
BELIEVE IS IN THE FILES OF THIS
COURT, THE COURT OF APPEALS
TRANSMITTED TO THIS COURT THE
RECORDS IN BOTH OF THOSE CASES,
THE APPEAL AND THE MANDAMUS
CASES.
NOW, MR. JUSTICE STEWART, WITH
RESPECT TO JUDGE SIRICA'S
APPEARANCE HERE, HE IS A PARTY
BEFORE THIS COURT AND I BELIEVE
THERE IS A LETTER ON FILE WITH
THE CLERK OF THIS COURT FROM
JUDGE SIRICA IN WHICH HE STATES
THAT HE WILL NOT APPEAR
SEPARATELY THE UNITED STATES
THROUGH THE SPECIAL PROSECUTORS
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF JUDGE
SIRICA AS, INDEED, WE WOULD HAVE
IN THE COURT OF APPEALS TO
UPHOLD HIS DECISION ENFORCING
OUR SUBPOENA.
SO THE CASE, PROCEDURALLY, IS
PROPERLY BEFORE THE COURT BOTH
WITH RESPECT TO THE APPEAL AND
THE MANDAMUS PROCEEDINGS.
I'D LIKE TO-
>> THE FACT THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK
BEFORE YOU GET TOO FAR, LET'S
ASSUME YOU GET BY THE
JURISDICTIONAL MATTERS AND ALSO
THE STANDING QUESTION, THE
INTRA-EXECUTIVE DISPUTE MATTER,
AND WE GET TO THE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE OR WE GET TO THE
MERITS, SO-CALLED.
>> YES.
>> WHICH INTO THIS CASE WOULD WE
NORMALLY START AT ANYWAY, THE
17C END OR THE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE END?
>> WELL I THINK, NORMALLY, YOU
MIGHT START WITH 17C END BECAUSE
THAT WOULD PROVIDE FOR A
CONCEIVABLY FOR DISPOSITION ON
NON-CONSTITUTIONAL GROUNDS IF
YOU FOUND THAT WE HAD NOT MADE A
SUFFICIENT SHOWING TO SATISFY
THE ORDINARY REQUIREMENTS OF THE
RULE.
SO, IN ACCORDANCE WITH COURT'S
NORMAL JURISPRUDENCE --
>> MR. LACOVARA, JUDGE SIRICA
FOUND THAT YOU HAD SATISFIED THE
REQUIREMENTS.
>> ABSOLUTELY, HE --
>> THEN WHAT'S THE SCOPE OF OUR
REVIEW?
>> WE HAVE MADE THE SUGGESTION
THAT ANY APPELLANT COURT
REVIEWING THIS KIND OF
DETERMINATION APPLIES THE
STANDARD OF WHETHER THE DISTRICT
JUDGE WAS INTIMATELY FAMILIAR
WITH THIS INDICTMENT AND WITH
THE 49-PAGE APPENDIX SHOWING
THAT WE SUBMITTED IN
DEMONSTRATING WHY EACH OF THESE
64 SUBPOENAED CONVERSATIONS WAS
MATERIAL.
HE MADE THE FINDING THAT WE HAD
CLEARLY DEMONSTRATED RELEVANCE
AND AN EVIDENTIARY NATURE --
>> WHAT'S OUR STANDARD OF
APPELLATE REVIEW?
>> AND YOUR STANDARD REVIEW
SHOULD BE WHETHER HE HAS ABUSED
HIS DISCRETION.
>> CLEARLY ERRONEOUS?
>> CLEARLY ERRONEOUS STANDARD,
YES, SIR.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE STANDARD?
>> I'M SORRY, WHICH --
>> BASED ON THE STANDARD HE
FOLLOWED, WHAT ABOUT THE BASIC
STANDARD OF 17C?
>> THE PARTIES ARE IN AGREEMENT
THAT BOWMAN DAIRY AND IOZIA THAT
DISTRICT COURT DECISION
ESTABLISHED THE BASIC CRITERIA
--
>> THE GOVERNMENT IS IN
AGREEMENT THAT THE STANDARDS OF
IOZIA MUST BE SATISFIED IN THIS
CASE UNDER 17C?
>> WELL, WE HAVE SUGGESTED THAT
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT A LOWER
STANDARD CAN BE APPLIED.
>> WELL, THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING
YOU.
WHAT IS YOUR POSITION?
>> WELL, MY POSITION WOULD BE
THAT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
SUBPOENA TO A THIRD PARTY, AS
DISTINGUISHED FROM AN INTRA-CASE
SUBPOENA BETWEEN GOVERNMENT AND
DEFENDANT, A LOWER STANDARD OR
RELEVANCY OR MATERIALITY SHOULD
--
>> SO THE PARTIES ARE NOT IN
AGREEMENT AT ALL?
>> WELL, WE HAVE SUGGESTED THAT
EVEN IF THE PROPER STANDARD IS
APPLIED, THAT WE MEET THAT
STANDARD BECAUSE OF THE SHOWING
THAT WE MADE THAT EACH OF THESE
ITEMS IS --
>> DO YOU MEAN A NECESSITY
STANDARD?
>> NECESSITY IN A SENSE OF BEING
RELEVANT TO THE ISSUES TO BE
TRIED AND BEING OF AN
EVIDENTIARY NATURE.
NOW, THE NECESSITY STANDARD
COMES IN MORE IN DETERMINING
WHETHER THE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
CLAIM SHOULD BE OVERWRITTEN IF,
APART FROM THE WAIVER FACT AND
WHAT WE CALL THE CLOT POINT --
>> WELL, WHAT ABOUT MR. ST.
CLAIR'S ARGUMENT?
UNDER 17C YOU CAN'T POSSIBLY
SATISFY ITS REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN THE
TAPES.
>> THAT, OBVIOUSLY, WE DON'T
THINK IS A PROPER LEGAL STANDARD
AND THE COURTS HAVE SAID.
IN FACT, WE GO BACK TO CHIEF
JUSTICE MARSHALL'S OPINION IN
THE BURR CASE WHERE EXACTLY THE
SAME SUGGESTION WAS MADE BY THE
UNITED STATES ATTORNEY IN
OPPOSING THE SUBPOENA, THAT BURR
HASN'T SPECIFIED WHICH PORTIONS
OF GENERAL WILKINSON'S LETTER
WERE REALLY GOING TO BE
MATERIAL.
AND CHIEF JUSTICE MARSHALL
APPLIED WITH HIS ELOQUENT COMMON
SENSE, OF COURSE NOT, BECAUSE HE
HASN'T SEEN THE LETTER YET BUT
HE'S MADE A SUFFICIENT AVERMENT
THAT IT DOES CONTAIN SOMETHING
MATERIAL, THAT AT LEAST IT
SHOULD BE BROUGHT INTO COURT.
NOW WE HAVE, AS I SAY, GONE MUCH
FURTHER THAN COLONEL BURR DID.
>> YOU THINK IOZIA JUST MEANS
ONLY EVIDENTIARY AND RELEVANT.
IS THAT WHAT YOU -- IS THAT YOUR
READING?
>> WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
SUBPOENA BETWEEN THE PARTIES,
YES, SIR.
THEY TALKED ABOUT OTHER
CRITERIA, WHICH I THINK ARE
REALLY SUBSUMED WHETHER IT'S A
FISHING EXPEDITION, WHETHER
YOU'RE GOING OFF ON A FROLIC.
BUT AS THE LATER CASES, AS I
BELIEVE JUDGE SIRICA INDICATES,
SEEM TO HAVE DISTILLED THAT --
>> SO YOU DON'T THINK IOZIA AND
BOWMAN REQUIRES ANY SHOWING THAT
THIS PARTICULAR EVIDENCE BE
SOMETHING MORE THAN EVIDENTIARY
AND RELEVANT?
>> THAT IT'D BE CRITICAL?
NO, SIR, I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
I THINK THAT, AS YOU WERE
SUGGESTING BEFORE AND AS JUDGE
SIRICA HELD, IT'S NEVER BEEN THE
LAW THAT ONCE AN INDICTMENT IS
RETURNED THE PROSECUTION IS NOT
ENTITLED TO CONTINUE GATHERING
EVIDENCE.
THE BURDENS OF PROOF BEFORE A
GRAND JURY AND A TRIAL JURY ARE
CLEARLY DIFFERENT.
IT'S AN ABUSE OF THE GRAND JURY
PROCESS THAT HAS BEEN HELD TO
USE A GRAND JURY SUBPOENA, AS
MR. ST. CLAIR SUGGESTED, TO
CONTINUE GATHERING EVIDENCE
AFTER AN INDICTMENT IS RETURNED.
>> YES, BUT YOU APPARENTLY
CONCEDE THAT YOU CAN'T USE IT
JUST FOR DISCOVERY.
>> YES, SIR.
>> AND YOU SAY THE EVIDENCE
YOU'RE SEEKING BY A SUBPOENA,
YOU MUST MAKE SOME KIND OF A
MINIMAL SHOWING OF
ADMISSIBILITY.
YOU CAN'T, FOR EXAMPLE, SEEK
SOMETHING THAT WOULD ADMITTEDLY
BE AN ADMISSIBLE HEARSAY.
>> WELL, I HOPE I'M NOT
CONCEDING MORE THAN I SHOULD.
BUT, THE RULE DOES TALK ABOUT
SUBPOENAING MATERIAL FROM A
PERSON ON A SHOWING THAT IT WILL
BE RELEVANT.
IT'S RULE 17 AND I'M TALKING A
POSITION WHICH IS NARROWER THAN,
OF COURSE, YOU'RE SUGGESTING,
MR. JUSTICE, THAT I MIGHT TAKE.
BUT, IN ALL CANDOR, THE RULE
TALKS ABOUT SUBPOENAING
DOCUMENTS FROM A PERSON NOT ONLY
FROM A PARTY.
MR. JUSTICE DOUGLAS, I BELIEVE
YOU EARLIER MENTIONED THAT THE
RULE APPLIED ONLY TO SUBPOENAS
TO PARTIES, BUT THE RULE
SPECIFICALLY PROVIDES FOR
SUBPOENAS TO PERSONS WHO ARE NOT
PARTIES TO THE CASE.
BUT IT SAYS, AND THIS WAS THE
CLAUSE THAT WE WERE RELYING ON
HERE, THE COURT MAY DIRECT THAT
THE BOOKS OR PAPERS BE PRODUCED
BEFORE THE COURT AT A TIME PRIOR
TO THE TRIAL OR PRIOR TO THE
TIME WHEN THEY ARE TO BE OFFERED
IN EVIDENCE.
SO, THERE DOES SEEM TO BE SOME
NATURAL FOCUS ABOUT THE
EVIDENTIARY NATURE OF THE
MATERIALS.
>> I JUST WANT TO GET THE
GOVERNMENT'S POSITION BECAUSE IT
IS A RATHER IMPORTANT PART OF
THE CASE.
>> YES, SIR.
WE INSIST, AS JUDGE SIRICA
FOUND, THAT WITH CITATION OF
CHAPTER AND VERSE, IF I MAY, IN
OUR 49-PAGE SHOWING BEFORE THE
DISTRICT COURT WITH REFERENCES
TO SWORN TESTIMONY AS WELL AS
WITH REPRESENTATIONS ABOUT WHAT
WITNESSES WILL TESTIFY TRIAL WE
DEMONSTRATED WHY EACH OF THESE
SUBPOENAED CONVERSATIONS
SATISFIES THE BOWMAN DAIRY V.
IOZIA RULE 17C STANDARD.
NOW, THAT LEADS ME INTO THE
RELATED POINT.
WHAT IS THE RELEVANCE OF THE
GRAND JURY'S FINDING THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS A CO-CONSPIRATOR
IN THIS CASE?
IT HAS BEEN ALLEGED THAT WE DID
THIS IN ORDER TO PREJUDICE THE
PRESIDENT'S RIGHTS.
I THINK WE HAVE SOUGHT TO
DEMONSTRATE IN OUR REPLY BRIEF
THAT THAT WAS IN NO SENSE --
>> MR. LACOVARA, I DON'T THINK
IT'D BE VERY HARD TO UNDERSTAND
THE DEVELOPMENTS OF A SHOWING AT
THE TRIAL FOR PURPOSES OF
EVIDENCE THAT CERTAIN PEOPLE ARE
CO-CONSPIRATORS --
>> YES, SIR.
>> FOR PURPOSES OF INTRODUCTION
OF EVIDENCE.
BUT, THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT
QUESTION THAN THE RELEVANCE OF
GRAND JURY HAVING COME TO THAT
CONCLUSION.
>> YES.
NORMALLY, I WILL CONCEDE, IT IS
NOT THE PRACTICE, AS ANYONE
WHO'S BEEN A PROSECUTOR KNOWS,
FOR THE GRAND JURY IF IT IS NOT
IDENTIFYING THE CO-CONSPIRATORS
IN THE BODY OF ITS INDICTMENT TO
PLACE THEM ON THE RECORD.
IT IS FAIRLY COMMON PRACTICE,
HOWEVER, FOR AN INDICTMENT TO
SAY IN ADDITION TO THE
DEFENDANTS NAMED PERSONS OR
UNINDICTED CO-CONSPIRATORS.
THIS IS NOT AN ORDINARY CASE AND
--
>> IT MAY BE SO BUT EVEN IF THEY
NAMED IT IN THE INDICTMENT, THAT
ISN'T ENOUGH ON WHICH TO BASE
THE INTRODUCTION OF OUT-OF-COURT
STATEMENTS BY AN UNINDICTED
CO-CONSPIRATOR.
>> YES, THAT WAS THE POINT THAT
I WANTED TO GET TO IN DISCUSSING
WHAT WE CALL OUR CLOT ARGUMENT.
WE HAVE NEVER ARGUED, AND OF
COURSE THERE WOULD BE NO BASIS
FOR ARGUING THAT THE MERE GRAND
JURY FINDING, WHETHER ON THE
FACE OF THE INDICTMENT OR IN THE
GRAND JURY'S MINUTES, THAT THE
PRESIDENT OR ANY OF THE OTHER 18
UNINDICTED CO-CONSPIRATORS WERE
MEMBERS OF THIS CONSPIRACY
WOULD, ITSELF, BE ENOUGH AT
TRIAL TO WANT JUDGE'S ADMISSION
OF EXTRA JUDICIAL STATEMENTS
GIVEN BY THOSE CO-CONSPIRATORS.
WE ARE NOT MAKING THAT
CONTENTION HERE.
THE ISSUE ARISES BECAUSE A
MOTION TO QUASH A SUBPOENA WAS
FILED PRIOR TO TRIAL.
AND, THE BASIS FOR THAT MOTION
WAS A CLAIM OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, A GOVERNMENTAL
PRIVILEGE THAT EXISTS FRO THE
BENEFIT OF LEGITIMATE
GOVERNMENTAL PROCESSES.
WE COUNTERED THAT APART FROM
NIXON VERSUS SIRICA AND THE
BALANCING PROCESS, AND APART
FROM THE WAIVER ARGUMENT THAT WE
ALSO DEVELOP IN SOME LENGTH,
THIS PRESIDENT, AS DIFFICULT AS
IT WAS TO SAY THIS NOT BECAUSE
OF THE EVIDENCE BUT BECAUSE OF
THE INHERENT AWKWARDNESS OF IT,
THIS PRESIDENT IS NOT IN A
POSITION TO CLAIM THIS PUBLIC
PRIVILEGE FOR THE REASON THAT A
PRIMA FACIE SHOWING CAN BE MADE
THAT THESE CONVERSATIONS WERE
NOT IN PURSUANCE OF LEGITIMATE
GOVERNMENTAL PROCESSES OR THE
LAWFUL DELIBERATION OF THE
PUBLIC'S BUSINESS.
THESE CONVERSATIONS, AS WE
SHOWED IN OUR 49-PAGE APPENDIX
AND AS THE GRAND JURY ALLEGED,
WERE IN FURTHERANCE OF THE
CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD
THE UNITED STATES AND OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE.
WE DID NOT RELY EVEN BEFORE
JUDGE SIRICA AND WE DO NOT RELY
HERE MERELY ON THE FACT THAT THE
GRAND JURY MADE THIS
DETERMINATION.
WE DO SUBMIT THAT, FOR PURPOSES
OF A PRETRIAL CONSIDERATION OF A
SUBPOENA THAT IS CHALLENGED ON
GROUNDS OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
WE ARE NOT CONFRONTED WITH THE
NEED THAT WE WILL BE CONFRONTED
WITH A TRIAL IN WHICH WE FULLY
INTEND TO DISCHARGE OF SHOWING
BY EVIDENCE TO THE TRIAL JUDGE
THAT THE PRESIDENT AND THE OTHER
CO-CONSPIRATORS WERE MEMBERS OF
THE CO-CONSPIRATORS.
>> ONE OF YOUR GROUNDS FOR THE
NON-APPLICABILITY OF THE
PRIVILEGE IS THAT THESE
CONVERSATIONS WERE IN THE COURSE
OF THE CONSPIRATORS.
>> YES, SIR, AND WE --
>> AND THAT, YOU SAY, IS
SATISFIED BY MERELY THE GRAND
JURY?
>> NO, SIR.
NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT --
>> JUST A MOMENT.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> IT ISN'T SATISFIED MERELY BY
THE GRAND JURY FINDING SO A
COURT MUST GO ON AND MAKE IT SO
A DETERMINATION IF THEY WERE
GOING TO AGREE WITH YOU ON THIS
GROUND.
>> LET ME BACK UP A LITTLE.
I SEE THE POINT THAT YOU'RE
MAKING.
WE ARE TAKING THE POSITION THAT
THE GRAND JURY'S DETERMINATION
IS CONCLUSIVE ON THE COURT ON
TWO ISSUES: (A) THAT A
CONSPIRACY EXISTED, AND (B) THAT
PRESIDENT NIXON WAS A MEMBER OF
THE CONSPIRACY.
THAT IS NOT ENOUGH, WE CONCEDE,
TO OVERRIDE A CLAIM OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE BECAUSE, AS MR. ST.
CLAIR WELL SAYS, HE IS STILL THE
PRESIDENT AND HE STILL IS IN THE
POSITION TO INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
WHERE WE HAD SAID WE MUST BEAR
AN EVIDENTIARY BURDEN TO THE
SATISFACTION OF THE COURT IS ON
DRAWING THE NEXUS BETWEEN THE
SUBPOENAED CONVERSATIONS AND THE
CONCLUSIVELY DETERMINED PRIMA
FACIE SHOWING THAT THERE IS A
CONSPIRACY IN WHICH THE
PRESIDENT IS A MEMBER.
WE MADE THAT EVIDENTIARY SHOWING
TO JUDGE SIRICA.
THAT SHOWING IS BEFORE THIS
COURT.
JUDGE SIRICA FOUND THAT SHOWING
WAS SUFFICIENT AND FOR THAT
REASON, AS I BELIEVE HIS OPINION
ALTHOUGH IT HAD TO BE GUARDED
BECAUSE THESE ITEMS WERE PLACED
UNDER SEAL, REFLECTS THAT HE DID
MAKE THE SHOWING.
>> THAT SHOWING OR SUCH A
SHOWING COULD ARGUABLY HAVE BEEN
MADE WHETHER OR NOT THE GRAND
JURY HAD NAMED THE PRESIDENT,
WOULD IT NOT?
>> YES, SIR.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN MADE AS AN
EVIDENTIARY MATTER, BUT WE ARE
--
>> AND YOU SAY IT WAS?
>> PARDON ME?
>> ISN'T IT YOUR POSITION THAT
IT WAS INDEPENDENTLY OF THE
NAMING OF THE PRESIDENT AS AN
UNINDICTED CO-CONSPIRATOR?
>> YES, SIR.
THE EVIDENCE THAT WAS PLACED
BEFORE JUDGE SIRICA, WE WOULD
SUBMIT, WOULD BE SUFFICIENT TO
MAKE THAT SHOWING.
NOW, WE HAVE SAID THAT THAT IS
NOT LEGALLY NECESSARY.
THAT WE DID NOT HAVE TO MAKE,
DIDN'T HAVE TO PROVE A
CONSPIRACY, IN EFFECT, PROVE THE
WHOLE CASE THAT MAY TAKE THREE
MONTHS TO TRY IN ORDER TO DEFEAT
A CLAIM OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
BEFORE TRIAL.
THIS COURT HAS FREQUENTLY SAID
THAT CRIMINAL PROCESS WOULD BE
BURDENED DOWN UNDULY IF
PROCEEDINGS WERE PRECEDED BY
MANY PROCEEDINGS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE
HERE.
WE SUBMIT THE EVIDENCE IS
SUFFICIENT.
JUDGE SIRICA, THE EVIDENCE, THIS
IS A SITUATION IN WHICH THE
SHOWING THAT WE DID SUBMIT
INTRINSICALLY, WE SUBMIT, TRACKS
THE ALLEGATIONS OF THE
INDICTMENT AND PROVIDES
INDEPENDENT EVIDENTIARY SUPPORT
FOR THOSE ALLEGATIONS.
WE HAVE SAID, THOUGH, THAT IT IS
NOT LEGALLY NECESSARY IN A
PROCEEDING LIKE THIS FOR THE
COURT INDEPENDENTLY TO DECIDE
WHETHER THE GRAND JURY HAD
ENOUGH EVIDENCE BEFORE IT TO SAY
THERE IS A CONSPIRACY OR THAT A
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL WAS A
MEMBER OF THE CONSPIRACY.
WE SAID ALL YOU NEED TO FIND IS
THAT WE HAVE SHOWN THAT THESE
CONVERSATIONS WERE IN
FURTHERANCE OF THAT CONSPIRACY.
>> MR. LACOVARA.
>> SIR.
>> JUST BACK UP A MINUTE.
DO YOU CONCEDE THAT AN INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
COULD NOT BE INDICTED AND TRIED
FOR CRIME?
>> NO, SIR.
>> YOU DO NOT.
DO YOU THINK HE COULD BE?
>> WE HAVE NOT EXPRESSED A
POSITION ON THAT, MR. JUSTICE
POWELL.
>> LET'S ASSUME FOR THE MOMENT
THAT HE COULD NOT BE, WOULD YOU
STILL ARGUE THAT THE GRAND JURY
HAD THE POWER OR THE RIGHT AND,
IF SO, BY VIRTUE OF WHAT?
>> YES, WE ARGUE THAT --
>> TO NAME HIM AS AN UNINDICTED
CO-CONSPIRATOR.
>> WE DO, IN FACT, MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT AT SOME LENGTH.
I GUESS ALL OF OUR ARGUMENTS ARE
MADE WITH TOO MUCH LENGTH, BUT
WE DO ARGUE AT LENGTH, SIR,
SERIOUSLY THAT THE QUESTION OF
PRESIDENTIAL INDICTABILITY WHICH
WE OFFER SOME VIEWS ON JUST TO
SHOW THAT HET QUESTION IS AN
OPEN ONE BECAUSE OF OUR
OBLIGATION, WE BELIEVE TO THE
LAW AND TO THE COURT, IS NOT
REALLY DETERMINATIVE OF THE
QUESTION THAT IS REALLY IN THIS
CASE TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
COURT REACHES THE EXPUNGEMENT
ARGUMENT ADVANCED BY COUNSEL OR
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE COURT
DOES NOT REACH THE SO-CALLED
CLARK ARGUMENT THAT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE JUST CANNOT BE INVOKED
HERE.
THE ISSUE OF PRESIDENTIAL
INDICTABILITY DOES NOT DETERMINE
THE ISSUE WHETHER AN INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT CAN BE NAMED AS AN
UNINDICTED CO-CONSPIRATOR BY A
GRAND JURY.
WE HAVE SHOWN IN OUR BRIEF WHY
EVEN PERSONS WHO DO HAVE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL IMMUNITY, AND
COUNSEL ARGUES THAT, IMPLICITLY
UNDER THE FRAMEWORK OF THE
CONSTITUTION THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD HAVE AN IMPLICIT IMMUNITY
FROM PROSECUTION EVEN SUCH
PERSONS CAN BE AND FREQUENTLY
ARE NAMED BY GRAND JURY AS
UNINDICTED CO-CONSPIRATORS.
THE PRACTICAL ARGUMENTS THAT MAY
MILITATE IN FAVOR OF A JUDICIAL
RECOGNITION OF SOME UNIQUE
IMMUNITY FOR THE PRESIDENT
ALONE, NOT FOR CIRCUIT JUDGES,
NOT FOR SUPREME COURT JUSTICES,
NOT FOR MEMBERS OF CONGRESS BUT
THE PRESIDENT ALONE, IT MAY BE
HELD AT SOME LATER DATE, IS
IMMUNE FROM PROSECUTION BUT, BY
NO MEANS, SUGGEST THE ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION HERE.
AND, THE GRAND JURY ELECTED NOT
TO TEST THAT ISSUE.
>> THE THING THAT I WAS
WONDERING ABOUT IS THAT THERE IS
ONLY ONE PRESIDENT AND THE
EXECUTIVE POWER IS VESTED IN
HIM, AND I DO WONDER WHETHER OR
NOT THE PRECEDENTS YOU SAID WITH
RESPECT TO OTHER PEOPLE WOULD
VEST THIS TO A GRAND JURY EITHER
ON HIS OWN MOTION OR BECAUSE OF
SOME PROSECUTOR SUGGESTED WHILE
THE PRESIDENT IS IN OFFICE TO
NAME HIM AS AN UNINDICTED
CO-CONSPIRATOR WITH GRAND JURY
SITTING ALL OVER THE UNITED
STATES.
AND, OCCASIONALLY, YOU FIND A
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
PROSECUTOR.
THAT'S A RATHER FAR-REACHING
POWER, IF IT EXISTS.
>> IT IS, MR. JUSTICE, AND
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
WE ARE CONSCIOUS OF THE DELICACY
OF THE ISSUE.
WE HAVE SUGGESTED, HOWEVER, THAT
ALTHOUGH THERE IS SOME
CONCEIVABLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ABUSE OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM, OUR
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM, IS BASED ON A
SEVERAL FUNDAMENTAL
PROPOSITIONS.
ONE OF WHICH IS THAT GRAND
JURIES USUALLY ARE NOT
MALICIOUS.
EVEN PROSECUTORS CANNOT BE
ASSUMED TO BE MALICIOUS.
WE ALSO ASSUME, AS THIS COURT
REGULARLY HOLDS IN FIRST
AMENDMENT CASES DEALING WITH
PUBLIC OFFICIALS, THAT WE HAVE A
RESILIENT SOCIETY WHERE PEOPLE
CAN BE TRUSTED TO SORT OUT TRUTH
FROM FALSITY.
WE HAVE A ROBUST DEBATE.
I SUBMIT TO YOU, SIR, THAT JUST
AS IN THIS CASE A GRAND JURY
WOULD NOT LIKELY ACCUSE THE
PRESIDENT OF A CRIME.
SO, TO THAT FEAR THAT PERHAPS
WITHOUT BASIS SOME GRAND JURY
SOMEWHERE MIGHT MALICIOUSLY
ACCUSE A PRESIDENT OF A CRIME IS
NOT NECESSARILY A COMPELLING
REASON FOR SAYING THAT A GRAND
JURY HAS NO POWER TO DO THAT.
I THINK THE SYSTEM MAY BE
VIBRANT ENOUGH TO DEAL WITH THAT
AND I THINK THE INHERENT DIGNITY
OF THE PRESIDENTIAL OFFICE AND
ANY INCUMBENT PROVIDING HIM WITH
A NOTABLE CHECK AGAINST BEING
DEFEATED OR, AS MY COLLEAGUE
SAYS, IMPEACHED BY THE ACTION OF
A GRAND JURY.
THIS IS PERHAPS THE MOST
NOTORIOUS EVENT AND NOTORIOUS
CASE IN RECENT TIMES.
WHEN THE GRAND JURY'S ACTION WAS
DISCLOSED, I VENTURE TO SAY THAT
ALTHOUGH IT WAS DIFFICULT TIME
FOR ALL CONCERNED, INCLUDING
PROSECUTORS AS WELL AS OTHER
COUNSEL AND THE PRESIDENT AND
THE COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT BEEN
DISPLACED FROM OFFICE.
HE STILL IS PRESIDENT.
HE STILL FUNCTIONS IN ACCORDANCE
WITH HIS CONSTITUTIONAL POWERS.
>> MR. LACO --
>> EXCUSE ME.
>> MR. LACOVARA, I WANTED TO GET
TO THIS MECHANICAL QUESTION THAT
MR. ST. CLAIR BROUGHT UP. ASSUME
FOR THE MOMENT THAT A GIVEN
TAPE, ONE OF THE 46 IS IT THAT
YOU'RE ASKING FOR?
>> 64, SIR.
>> 64, I HADN'T TRANSPOSED.
ONE OF THE 64 TAPES IS, IN FACT,
ONE-EIGHTH OF THE TOTAL TIME,
WHICH MIGHT BE SEVERAL HOURS
APPARENTLY BECAUSE THEY'RE LONG
TAPES BUT, ONE-EIGHTH INVOLVES
DISCUSSIONS OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE INDICTMENT HERE.
BUT THE SEVEN-EIGHTHS OF IT IN
FACT, NOW YOU HAVE TO ASSUME
THIS, INCLUDES CONFERENCES WITH
THE SECRETARIES OF THE CABINET,
THE JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFFS, THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE ATOMIC ENERGY
COMMISSION, VERY HIGH-LEVEL
PEOPLE AND PERHAPS SOME STAFF
PEOPLE AS WELL.
INCLUDING IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
SOME HIGHLY SENSITIVE MATERIAL,
NOT SENSITIVE IN THE SENSE THAT
IT'S NATIONAL MILITARY SECRETS
OR DIPLOMATIC SECRETS BUT
SENSITIVE IN THE SENSE OF
CONFIDENTIALITY.
WOULD YOU NOT THINK THAT SOME
MECHANISM OUGHT TO BE AVAILABLE
THAT IF THE PARTICIPANTS ARE
IDENTIFIED, AS YOU GOT THEM ALL
IDENTIFIED BY THE VOLUNTARY
SUBMISSION OF THE PRESIDENT AS
TO THE 64, THAT IF THE
PARTICIPANTS ARE IDENTIFIED IN
THE TIMEFRAME SPECIFIED THAT THE
CERTIFICATE OF THE MAJOR PERSONS
PRESENT THAT THE SUBJECT WAS
ATOMIC ENERGY, ALL SORTS OF
OTHER THINGS, WOULD BE
SUFFICIENT TO FORECLOSE THE
COURT FROM EXAMINING IT IN
CAMERA.
>> WELL, TO FORECLOSE --
>> I'M ASKING YOU, WOULD YOU
THINK SO?
>> THE ANSWER TO MY QUESTION,
MR. CHIEF JUSTICE, IS YES
BECAUSE THESE ARE THE PROCEDURES
THAT HAVE BEEN SET UP IN THE
COURT OF APPEALS DECISION OF
NIXON VERSUS SIRICA WHICH WERE
FOUND TO BE EMINENTLY PRACTICAL
WHEN THE TAPES SUBPOENAED BY THE
GRAND JURY WERE SUBMITTED.
THESE ARE SIX-HOUR REELS AND,
UNDER THE SO-CALLED INDEX AND
ANALYSIS WHICH THE COURT OF
APPEALS IN THAT CASE REQUIRED TO
BE SUBMITTED AND WHICH JUDGE
SIRICA HERE HAS REQUIRED TO BE
SUBMITTED, COUNSEL FOR THE
PRESIDENT SAYS THIS IS A
SIX-HOUR REEL.
THE WATERGATE-RELATED PORTIONS
ARE MINUTES 312 -- NO, THAT'S
TOO MANY -- 112 THROUGH 146.
PRIOR TO THAT, THERE IS A
MEETING BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
AND THE SECRETARY OF HEALTH,
EDUCATION, AND WELFARE ON A
SCHOOL BILL.
AFTER THE WATERGATE-RELATED
DISCUSSIONS, THERE IS A MEETING
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF MANUFACTURERS.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS THAT WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL HAS COME TO THE
JUDGE'S CHAMBERS WITH THE
ORIGINAL REELS.
THEY HAVE MARKED THE BEGINNING
OF THE WATERGATE-RELATED
PORTIONS ON THOSE REELS FOR THE
COURT TO MAKE HIS INDEPENDENT
DETERMINATION.
THIS IS WATERGATE-RELATED AND,
THEREFORE, OFFSET BY WHATEVER
OVERCOMING OF THE PRIVILEGE HAS
BEEN HELD.
AND AFTER THAT IS DONE, A COPY
OF THE WATERGATE-RELATED
PORTIONS IS MADE.
THE JUDGE DOES NOT LISTEN TO THE
NON-WATERGATE-RELATED PORTIONS
WHICH ARE STILL COVERED BY A
PRESUMPTIVE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
WHICH WE HAVE FREELY CONCEDED
FROM THE TIME THE GRAND JURY
BEGAN THIS PROCESS IN JULY OF
'73 TO OUR BRIEFS IN THIS COURT.
>> THEN, AS TO THESE
HYPOTHETICAL SEVEN-EIGHTHS,
THERE IS, YOU SUGGEST, NO
DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN YOU AND MR.
ST. CLAIR AND MR. JAWORSKI, AND
YOU ON THE ONE HAND.
>> THAT'S CORRECT, SIR, AND I
MIGHT SAY THAT UNDER THE
PROCEDURE THAT WAS WORKED OUT,
THIS MAY PRE-DATE MR. ST. CLAIR
SO YOU'LL HAVE TO RELY SOLELY ON
MY REPRESENTATION, PRESIDENT
INDICATED A WILLINGNESS TO ALLOW
THE JUDGE TO LISTEN TO A FEW
MOMENTS OF CONVERSATION ON
EITHER END OF THE PORTION OF THE
TAPE THAT HAD BEEN LISTED IN
THIS INDEX AND ANALYSIS AS BEING
WATERGATE-RELATED JUST SO HE
WOULD HAVE AN ASSURANCE THAT
THERE WAS A TRANSITION FROM ONE
SUBJECT TO ANOTHER SUBJECT.
THAT WAS CREATED BY THE
PRESIDENT AS BEING -- IF A
MINIMAL INTRUSION ON THE
CONFIDENTIALITY PRIVILEGE FOR AN
UNRELATED SUBJECT CERTAINLY, BY
NO MEANS, AN EXCESSIVE ONE.
>> MR. LACOVARA, I KNOW YOU HAVE
ONLY VERY FEW MINUTES.
ARE YOU GOING TO ADDRESS MR. ST.
CLAIR'S OPENING ARGUMENT THAT
THE PENDENCY OF THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
EITHER SHOULD LEAVE THE COURT TO
CONCLUDE THAT THIS WHOLE
BUSINESS BEFORE US ARE
NON-JUSTICIABLE MATTER.
THEREFORE, NECESSARILY WITH
JUDGE SIRICA'S ORDER SHOULD BE
QUASHED OR, IN ANY EVENT, THAT
BECAUSE OF THE POSSIBLE EFFECT
OF A DECISION ON THE ISSUE
PRESENTED UPON THE IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY, THAT THE COURT SHOULD
STAY ITS HAND.
>> THAT WAS TO BE MY LAST POINT,
SIR, AND I WILL MAKE IT RIGHT
NOW.
THE NOTION THAT BECAUSE THERE IS
CONCURRENTLY UNDERWAY AN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY BEFORE THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES THAT,
SOMEHOW, MAKES THIS A
NON-JUSTICIABLE POLITICAL
QUESTION.
IT IS, WE THINK, A REMARKABLE
NOTION WHICH IS NOT SUPPORTED BY
SOUND AND CONSTITUTIONAL LAW OR
BY ANY OF THE DECISIONS OF THIS
COURT.
AND INDEED, I SUBMIT, THAT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE COURT HAS
DISCRETION IN THE MATTER AND
ALTHOUGH THIS COURT HAS NOW BEEN
GIVEN DISCRETIONARY CERTIORARI
POWER, DISTRICT COURTS HAVE NO
SUCH OPTION.
IT WOULD NOT EVEN BE A WISE
EXERCISE OF DISCRETION FOR THIS
COURT TO STAY ITS HAND.
THIS CASE BEFORE THE COURT IS
NOT A REQUEST FOR AN OPINION
BETWEEN TWO CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES AS TO WHO HAS
JURISDICTION OVER A PARTICULAR
BILL.
IT'S NOT EVEN A REQUEST FOR A
DISPUTE BETWEEN CABINET OFFICERS
OR THE PRESIDENT AND A CABINET
OFFICER OVER WHAT PROPER
EXECUTIVE POLICY OUGHT TO BE.
THIS IS A CRIMINAL PROCEEDING OF
FEDERAL CRIMINAL CASE AGAINST
SIX DEFENDANTS.
A SUBPOENA HAD BEEN ISSUED TO
OBTAIN EVIDENCE FOR USE AT THE
TRIAL WHICH IS SCHEDULED TO
BEGIN ON SEPTEMBER 9.
THE COURT CANNOT ESCAPE THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A TRIAL OF
TREMENDOUS NATIONAL IMPORTANCE,
BUT A TRIAL THAT WAS BROUGHT TO
AHEAD WITHOUT REGARD TO THE
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
THIS IS AN INDEPENDENT SEPARATE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS THAT IS
UNDERWAY, AND A TRADITIONAL
PROSAIC REMEDY.
A SUBPOENA HAS BEEN UTILIZED TO
OBTAIN EVIDENCE FOR THAT TRIAL.
THERE'S SOME DEBATE ABOUT
WHETHER THE EVIDENCE IS CRITICAL
TO OUR PROSECUTION.
I KNOW THAT IN JUSTICE
REHNQUIST'S OPINION A FEW WEEKS
AGO IN MICHIGAN AGAINST TUCKER
THAT HE ECHOED OR PRESAGED
PERHAPS THE SAME POINT THAT
JUDGE SIRICA MADE THAT IT'S
REALLY THE OBLIGATION OF THE
PROSECUTION TO PRESENT ALL OF
THE MATERIAL EVIDENCE FOR THE
JURY, FOR THE FACT-FINDER TO
PASS UPON.
THAT'S WHAT THIS CASE INVOLVES.
NOW TO SAY THAT THERE WILL BE
PUBLIC CONSEQUENCES, EVEN
POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES, TO THE
COURT'S ACTION DOES NOT MEAN
THIS IS A POLITICAL QUESTION SO
THAT THE COURT MUST REGARD IT AS
NON-JUSTICIABLE.
THE SAME ARGUMENT WOULD HAVE
PREVENTED THIS COURT FROM
DECIDING MARBURY AND MADISON.
IT'S COMMON KNOWLEDGE THAT CHIEF
JUSTICE MARSHALL, HIMSELF, WAS
THREATENED WITH IMPEACHMENT IF
HE DECIDED THE CASE AGAINST
PRESIDENT JEFFERSON.
HE WENT AHEAD AND DID HIS DUTY
ON BEHALF OF THIS COURT.
LATER, IN CONNECTION WITH THE
BURR TRIAL --
>> HE DECIDED IT IN FAVOR OF
PRESIDENT JEFFERSON, DIDN'T HE?
>> NO, SIR.
>> HE DIDN'T?
HE SAYS THAT, EXPRESSLY --
>> HE SURELY DECIDED IT THAT
JEFFERSON WON THE CASE OF THE
BATTLE BUT THE LOST THE WAR.
>> WELL, IF YOU --
>> OF A JUDICIAL SUPREMACY.
>> THE CASE IS NORMALLY THOUGHT
OF AS BEING SOLELY CONCERNED
WITH ORIGINAL JURISDICTION.
BUT IF --
>> BUT IN THAT SENSE --
>> IF ONE READS THE CASE AGAIN,
SIR, I SUBMIT, CHIEF JUSTICE
MARSHALL GOT TO THE ORIGINAL
JURISDICTION POINT ONLY AFTER HE
HAD BEEN VERY DECISIVE IN SAYING
THAT A LOWER COURT COULD ISSUE
AND SHOULD ISSUE AND WOULD BE
OBLIGED TO ISSUE THE MANDAMUS TO
SECRETARY MADISON BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT HAD NOT LEGAL POWER TO
ORDER SECRETARY OF STATE MADISON
NOT TO ISSUE THAT COMMISSION.
HE HELD THAT.
IT MIGHT BE CALLED DICTUM BUT IT
CERTAINLY, AT THE TIME, WAS A
COURAGEOUS ACT.
>> BUT THE BASIC RULING IN THE
CASE RELATED TO THE ORIGINAL
JURISDICTION OF THE COURT UNDER
ARTICLE III, DID IT NOT?
>> I CONCEDE THAT, SIR.
LATER, HOWEVER, WHEN HE DID GO
ON IN 1807 TO ISSUE THE SUBPOENA
TO PRESIDENT JEFFERSON, THAT WAS
AN ACT OF PROFOUND POLITICALCONT
AGAIN ELOQUENTLY THAT IT WAS THE
COURT'S DUTY TO OBTAIN EVIDENCE
IF IT WERE MATERIAL TO THE
TRIAL.
THE NOTION THAT POLITICAL
CONSEQUENCES SHOULD STAY THE
HAND OF THE COURT IS A NOTION
THAT, AGAIN SPEAKING THROUGH
MARSHALL, THE COURT REJECTED IN
COHENS AGAINST VIRGINIA AND THE
CHEROKEE NATION CASE WHERE IT
WAS COMMON KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
STATE LEGISLATURES IN VIRGINIA,
IN GEORGIA, WOULD INTERPOSE
THEMSELVES AND DEFY THIS COURT.
AND MARSHALL UTTERED THE WORDS,
WHICH I THINK ARE JUSTLY FAMOUS,
"JUST AS THE COURT CAN'T REACH
OUT FOR JURISDICTION IT DOESN'T
HAVE, IT HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
EXERCISE THE JURISDICTION IT
DOES HAVE WHATEVER MAY BE THE
POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
ACT."
THE COURT'S ACTION IN EX PARTE
MILLIGAN IN TELLING PRESIDENT
LINCOLN THAT HE DID NOT HAVE THE
POWER TO CONDUCT THE CIVIL WAR
THE WAY HE WANTED TO CONDUCT IT,
AGAIN, PROFOUND POLITICAL
CONSEQUENCES.
COME TO THE WAR POWER CASES IN
WORLD WAR II, THE JAPANESE
EXCLUSION CASES, THIS COURT DID
NOT SAY BECAUSE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE PRESIDENT
OR BECAUSE OF THE POLITICAL
REACTION TO A DECISION ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER THE COURT SHOULD
STAY ITS HAND.
IN YOUNGSTOWN, OUR COLLEAGUE'S
BRIEF CLOSES BY QUOTING JUSTICE
FRANKFURTER'S BRILLIANT
CONCURRING OPINION SAYING HOW
THE COURT SHOULD, AS AN
INSTITUTION, BE RELUCTANT TO
DECIDE GREAT CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTIONS.
BUT, HE WENT ON TO SAY WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO LOOK INTO AN
ASSERTION OF PRESIDENTIAL POWER.
AND EVEN IF THE EMBARRASSMENT TO
BE CAUSED TO THE PRESIDENT BY
OUR DISAGREEING WITH HIM WOULD
BE PROFOUND, IT IS STILL THE
DUTY OF THE COURT TO TELL HIM
WHEN HE'S WRONG.
THIS COURT, IN POWELL AGAINST
MCCORMACK, HOW COULD THERE BE A
MORE POLITICAL CASE THAN TELLING
A HOUSE OF CONGRESS THAT IT HAD
TO SEE THE MEMBER THAT IT
EXCLUDED.
BUT, THE COURT SAID THE
CONSTITUTION FORBAD IT.
IT'S UP TO THE COURT TO DECIDE
WHAT THE CONSTITUTION ALLOWS,
AND EVEN THOUGH THE COURT
INTERPRETS THE CONSTITUTION
DIFFERENTLY FROM ANOTHER BRANCH,
THAT'S THE JUDICIAL PROCESS.
SO, SEPARATION OF POWERS HERE
WITH THE NOTION OF POLITICAL
QUESTION WHETHER SOMETHING IS
COMMITTED TO THE FINAL
DETERMINATION OF ANOTHER BRANCH
FAR FROM SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENT'S POSITION DEMANDS
THAT THE COURT AFFIRM THE ACTION
THAT JUDGE SIRICA HAS TAKEN.
THIS IS EMPHATICALLY THE
PROVIDENCE OF THIS COURT TO
DECIDE.
NOT TO BELABOR THE POINT, BUT
PERHAPS THE FINEST CHAPTER IN
THE COURT'S RECENT HISTORY HAS
COME UPON THESE CHAPTERS AND HAD
COME IN THE FIELDS OF
REAPPORTIONMENT, CIVIL RIGHTS,
AND THE PROCEDURAL RIGHTS OF THE
CRIMINALLY ACCUSED WOULD BE
NAÏVE TO SAY THAT THOSE WERE NOT
PROFOUNDLY POLITICALLY IMPORTANT
DECISIONS BUT THEY WERE MADE AS
DECISIONS OF CONSTITUTIONAL LAW
DESPITE THE CONSEQUENCES THAT
POLITICAL BRANCHES MIGHT FACE.
DESPITE THE PUBLIC REACTION, THE
COURT UNDERSTOOD ITS DUTY TO
INTERPRET THE CONSTITUTION.
THAT'S ALL WE ASK FOR TODAY.
THAT'S ALL JUDGE SIRICA HAS
DONE.
WE BELIEVE HE HAS DONE IT
CORRECTLY.
WE BELIEVE THE CASE IS FULLY
JUSTICIABLE.
WE BELIEVE THE PRINCIPLES THAT
HAVE BEEN BRIEFED BY THE PARTIES
SUPPORT THE CORRECTNESS OF THE
DECISION BELOW.
AND, WE SUBMIT THAT THIS COURT
SHOULD FULLY EXPLICITLY AND
DECISIVELY AND DEFINITIVELY
UPHOLD JUDGE SIRICA'S DECISION.
>> THANK YOU, MR. LACOVAR.
MR. ST. CLAIR, YOU HAVE 15
MINUTES LEFT.
>> THANK YOU, MR. CHIEF JUSTICE
AND MEMBERS OF THE COURT.
IN RESPONSE TO MY BROTHER'S MOST
RECENT ARGUMENT, OF COURSE
SAWYER WAS AN IMPORTANT CASE
WITH POLITICAL IMPLICATIONS.
OF COURSE, THE OTHER CASES WERE
IN IT OF THEMSELVES IMPORTANT
CASES WITH POLITICAL
IMPLICATIONS.
BUT, THIS CASE IS DIFFERENT IN
THAT THE DECISION IN THIS CASE
WILL HAVE AN UNDENIABLE IMPACT
ON ANOTHER PROCEEDING IN ANOTHER
PROCEEDING WHICH THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS IS ESSENTIALLY
A POLITICAL PROCEEDING FROM
WHICH THE COURT IS EXCLUDED.
AND FOR THIS COURT TO BE DRAWN
INTO THAT THICKET, IF I MAY CALL
IT THAT, SEEMS TO ME HIGHLY
INAPPROPRIATE AT LEAST AT THIS
TIME.
AS I INDICATED AT THE OUTSET,
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE HAS MADE
CERTAIN POLITICAL DECISIONS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE CERTAIN
POLITICAL DECISIONS.
THEY WILL EACH HAVE TO BEAR THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THOSE
DECISIONS WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THIS COURT SHOULD NOT IMPAIR,
INTERFERE WITH, OR OTHERWISE
PARTICIPATE DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY IN THAT PROCEEDING.
AND, IT'S INEVITABLE IT WOULD
HAPPEN.
THIS COURTROOM WOULDN'T BE FULL
TODAY IF THIS WERE SIMPLY A SUIT
ON A SUBPOENA BROUGHT BY THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT EVEN THOUGH THAT WOULD
BE AN IMPORTANT POLITICAL MATTER
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT IS
INVOLVED.
BUT, THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR OTHER
REASONS QUITE APART FROM THAT.
OTHER REASONS WHICH I SUGGEST
INDICATE QUITE CLEARLY THAT THIS
COURT OUGHT TO, IN ITS
DISCRETION AND IN ITS JUDGMENT,
STAY ITS HAND AT LEAST UNTIL
SUCH TIME AS THOSE PROCEEDINGS
HAVE RUN THEIR COURSE BECAUSE
THOSE ARE POLITICAL DECISIONS
BEING MADE.
THEY SHOULD NOT BEAR THE BURDEN
EITHER WAY OF A JUDICIAL
DECISION.
>> WELL, UNDER THAT THEORY, ALL
THE CRIMINAL TRIALS THAT ARE
GOING ON SHOULD STOP TODAY.
>> THAT WOULD NOT BE THE FIRST
TIME, MR. JUSTICE DOUGLAS, THAT
A CRIMINAL TRIAL WAS DELAYED.
AND IN BALANCING THE IMPORTANCE
TO THIS NATION, I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THAT IS CLEARLY INDICATED
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THE
DEFENDANTS WOULD BE CRYING VERY
BITTER TEARS.
BUT IN ANY EVENT, THE
JUSTICIABILITY OF THIS CASE,
SEEMS TO BE, THE SINGLE
IMPORTANT OBVIOUS MATTER THAT MY
BROTHER WOULD PREFER NOT MUCH TO
TALK ABOUT, BUT THERE CAN BE NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT.
IF YOU READ PAGE 59 IN HIS
BRIEF, HE SAYS "HE, THE
PRESIDENT, IS NOW THE SUBJECT OF
AN IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY OF
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES AND
THE SUBPOENAED EVIDENCE MAY HAVE
A MATERIAL BEARING ON WHETHER HE
IS IMPEACHED AND, IF IMPEACHED,
WHETHER HE IS CONVICTED AND
REMOVED FROM OFFICE."
AND, I SUGGEST THE CONSTITUTION
IN ALL OF THE HISTORY, THE
FRAMERS MAKES IT QUITE CLEAR
THAT THE FRAMERS CONCEIVED
IMPEACHMENT AS A LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
THE COURT WAS EXCLUDED
SPECIFICALLY FROM THAT FUNCTION.
MARBURY AGAINST MADISON, ITSELF,
I AGREE WITH THE CHIEF JUSTICE
THAT IT DECIDED THE CASE IN
FAVOR OF THE PRESIDENT.
THE RULE WAS DISCHARGED AND THE
COMMISSION WAS NOT ISSUED.
BUT IT ALSO HELPS, AND IT'S BEEN
THE LAW SINCE THAT CASE, THAT
THE COURTS WILL NOT INTERFERE
WITH OR DIRECT A DISCRETIONARY
ACT ON THE PART OF THE PRESIDENT
OR ANY OTHER BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT, AND THAT'S BEEN
CONFIRMED IN MISSISSIPPI AGAINST
JOHNSON AND ANY CASE SINCE THAT
TIME.
AND, THE DISCRETION THAT THE
CONSTITUTION BY IMPLICATION AND
BY NECESSITY THAT HAS BEEN
VESTED IN THE PRESIDENT IN
DETERMINING WHICH OF HIS
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
SHALL BE MADE PUBLIC OR RELEASED
IS A DISCRETIONARY ACT THAT THIS
COURT OUGHT NOT BY ITS DECISION
TO UNDERTAKE TO DO FOR HIM
BECAUSE THIS COURT IS NOT
EQUIPPED IN KNOWLEDGE,
BACKGROUND, OR IN ANY OTHER WAY
TO EXERCISE THAT DISCRETION FOR
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THIS IS NOT A MINISTERIAL ACT.
FINALLY, I OBSERVE A SLIGHT BUT
SIGNIFICANT SHIFT IN MY
BROTHER'S POSITION WITH RESPECT
TO THE PRIMA FACIE NATURE OF
NAMING OF THE PRESIDENT AS A
CO-CONSPIRATOR.
I SAY IT CAN BE MADE NOW THAT IT
CAN BE MADE PRIMA FACIE, I TAKE
IT, THAT IS BY EXAMINING THE
EVIDENCE BEFORE THE GRAND JURY
IN ORDER TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT THAT EVIDENCE IN FACT
SUPPORTS THAT DETERMINATION.
WE HAVE INVITED THIS COURT AND
JUDGE SIRICA TO DO JUST THAT.
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR HAS
OPPOSED IN EACH INSTANCE THIS OR
ANY OTHER COURT LOOKING BEHIND
THAT TO SEE WHETHER, IN FACT,
THE EVIDENCE CAN BE MADE AS HE
NOW STATES A POSITION TO SUPPORT
A CHARGE OF CRIMINALITY.
BEFORE THE ARGUMENT, THE
ARGUMENT WAS THAT BECAUSE IT WAS
A FINDING OR A VOTE, IT WAS
PRIMA FACIE.
NOW IT IS, I TAKE IT, SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT.
BUT IN ANY EVENT, AN ACTION BY A
GRAND JURY PURPORTING TO ASSESS
CRIMINALITY TO A PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IS A CLEAR
INTRUSION UPON THE LEGISLATIVE
FUNCTION AND POWER WITH RESPECT
TO IMPEACHMENT.
AS I SAID EARLIER, THE PRESIDENT
IS NOT ABOVE THE LAW NOR DOES HE
CONTEND THAT HE IS, BUT HE DOES
CONTEND THAT, AS PRESIDENT, THE
LAW CAN BE APPLIED TO HIM IN
ONLY ONE WAY AND THAT'S BY
IMPEACHMENT, NOT BY NAMING AS A
CO-CONSPIRATOR IN A GRAND JURY
INDICTMENT, NOT BY INDICTMENT,
OR ANY OTHER WAY.
THEREFORE, IN THIS CASE, I URGE
THAT THIS COURT TAKE SUCH ACTION
AS IS APPROPRIATE AND OVERRULE
JUDGE SIRICA'S DECISION AND
ORDER THAT THIS CASE BE
DISMISSED.
THANK YOU, MR. ST. CLAIR.
>> THANK YOU, MR. JAWORSKI, MR.
LACOVARA.